hey everyone in this week's episode
we'll talk about the most popular and
commonly used programming language
python so let's begin and learn about
the development of python and gain
insights about the current ID Trends but
before that make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to get
notified every time we come up with new
content python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax co-readability
and English like commands that make
coding a lot easier and efficient due to
this it is the most popular and
preferred language python has
interpreted high level general purpose
programming language developed by Widow
and Rossum at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after this snake python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus Guido van Rossum
formulated python in the late 1980s as a
successor to the ABC language in 1994
python version 1.0 was released with
features like exception handling Lambda
map filter and reduce python 2.0
released in 2000 introduced features
like list comprehensions and a garbage
collection system capable of collecting
reference Cycles python 3.0 was released
on the 3rd of December 2008. undoubtedly
Python 2.x and three point x have proven
to be the most used versions as of today
python 3.7.4 is the latest stable
version released in the summer of 2019.
python is popularly used for development
scripting and software testing top ID
companies like Google Facebook Instagram
Spotify and Netflix among others use
Python some major applications of python
can be seen in the fields of machine
learning artificial intelligence data
science and iot python also offers many
libraries like numpy sci-fi Keras
tensorflow Django and flask pep 8 is the
official style guide that defines the
styling conventions for python code a
few popular open source python projects
include fit EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing maps and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytorch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry python is
a widely popular programming language
that is used for web development game
development data analysis as well as
data visualization
hi everyone
welcome to this python developer full
course by simply learn in this session
we will cover all the important python
Concepts techniques and projects that
will help you become a successful python
developer a highly experienced trainers
will take you through this live session
but before I begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
so we will start by learning the history
of python and understand the top 10
reasons to Learn Python you will look at
the job role of a python developer the
skills they need to possess and how the
resume of a python developer should be
then we'll see how to install Python and
the Anaconda distribution of python then
we will shift our Focus towards learning
the basics of python such as data types
variables operators lists tuples and
dictionaries next we will understand
about loops and conditional statements
after that we'll get an idea about
object oriented programming Concepts and
functions in Python we will also cover
some important Advanced Python
Programming Concepts such as iterators
modules generators as well as packages
finally we will see the important python
interview questions that are often asked
so let's get started let's begin and
learn about the development of python
and gain insights about the current ID
Trends python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax core
readability and english-like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high-level general
purpose programming language developed
by Guido van rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after the snake python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus Guido and Rossum
formulated python in the late 1980s as a
successor to the ABC language in 1994
python version 1.0 was released with
features like exception handling Lambda
map filter and reduce python 2.0
released in 2000 introduced features
like list comprehensions and a garbage
collection system capable of collecting
reference Cycles python 3.0 was released
on the 3rd of December 2008. undoubtedly
Python 2.x and 3.8 have proven to be the
most used versions as of today python
3.7.4 is the latest stable version
released in the summer of 2019. python
is popularly used for development
scripting and software testing top ID
companies like Google Facebook Instagram
Spotify and Netflix among others use
Python some major applications of python
can be seen in the fields of machine
learning artificial intelligence data
science and iot python also offers many
libraries like numpy sci-fi Keras
tensorflow Django and flask pep 8 is the
official style guide that defines the
styling conventions for python code a
few popular open source python projects
include EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing math and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytotch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so what
really is Python programming language
python is an object oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it's supposed multiple programming
paradigms such as structured object
oriented and functional programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by Guido van Rossum
and its implementation started in
December 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994 python 2.0 came out in October
2000 while python 3.0 was released in
December 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the Python programming language let's
now look at the top 10 reasons why you
should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to like
python is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to Java or CC plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in Java as you can
see
if you have to write a program in Java
you first have to declare the class name
along with its scope
next using curly braces you need to pass
the main method along with its arguments
and then using system.out dot printlnm
method you can print hello world that's
quite a tedious task isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here you can write
the print function and pass whatever you
want to display inside the brackets and
that will print the output it is so
simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at 9 we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active Community
to assist Engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum the
community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack Overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the design of
python written by Tim petos that
represents the guiding principles for
python development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross-language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on Windows and they want to
execute on a Mac operating system or
Linux operating system or Solaris they
can easily do it without any Amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java.net C and C plus plus codes
with python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next Reason To Learn Python is
testing Frameworks
python supports several built-in
Flawless testing tools and Frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and Frameworks
supported by python are by test selenium
and Splinter
this is the reason for which every
tester tries to use python-based tools
and Frameworks to test any application
or code or to validate it in an easier
manner fightest is the most recommended
testing framework for functional
integrational and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
Python programming language to automate
various tasks and Splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting URLs and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
task simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
Frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
development machine learning and data
science
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via python
package index the repository of python
software python provides the default
package called pip Anaconda is a third
party python ecosystem other examples
include numpy scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later further it is
interpreted by the machine and checked
for errors at runtime
the machine is used to read and
interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to Learn Python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
Frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are Django flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie Etc
these Frameworks are written in Python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in PHP
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
Django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out URL routing Etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
Python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
Pinterest and Linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask it will assist users with URL
routing and authentication support
turbo gears is a highly recommended and
scalable framework that supports
features such as authentication caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in Python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand python is robust scalable
and provides extensible visualization
and Graphics options hence it is widely
used in data science
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas for
operations to manipulate data on
numerical tables and time series it also
provides simpi for symbolic computation
and sci-fi for Technical and scientific
computations
it has another Library called Pi brain
which is sought for python-based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network library
scikit-learn is the machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms and
finally it provides Pi torch and
tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to Learn Python which is
career opportunities and salary
Python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and Promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
Giants
industry leaders using python are Amazon
Google Facebook IBM NASA Netflix and
YouTube
next you can see the Google Trends
but I have considered three programming
languages python Java and C plus I have
compared them for the past 12 months you
can see it clearly on your screens that
python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in Python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the YouTube
search
there also you will find that Python
programming language is the most
searched language on YouTube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
Google
it is a leading indicator
the raw data comes from Google Trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
Java then JavaScript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph shows the popularity of
python and Java over the years starting
from 2004 till the current period which
is 2020 worldwide python is the most
popular language
python grew the most in the Last 5 Years
by 19.4 percent and Java lost the most
by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into If You Learn
Python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second
you can become a web developer here you
will be responsible for writing
server-side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components connect the application with
third-party services and support the
front-end developers by integrating
their work with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python as a data analyst you
have to gather data from multiple
sources using scripts analyze that data
develop and Implement databases and data
collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best Solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of Scopes If You Learn
Python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job rules
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the United States
while in India you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
If You Learn Python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of 113
000 per year in the United States while
in India you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at
eight we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven we saw
the testing Frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
sense at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon a
python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science so basically a python
developer develops deploys debugs and
maintains a project so let's go through
the skill set of a python developer now
the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack queues trees and
graphs there's oop Concepts like
inheritance classes and objects and
abstraction thus packages and functions
that is importing external packages into
a python code database and its
connection that is connecting a python
backend to a database like MySQL when it
comes to data science skills there's
numpy that is a library for performing
mathematical calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this scipy and then there is
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
back-end part of a web application
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up is python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team together
end users requirements develops the
server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlip
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect by using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software Engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe
the average salary of a python developer
in India is around 7 lakhs 55 000 rupees
per annum the average salary of a python
developer in the US is about 79 000 US
dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resuming so if
you're a fresher these are some of the
points that you need to know
first you have the resume header now the
summary is supposed to be clear and
concise just say what exactly you want
and some of your strengths next is the
profile links and your portfolio so you
can mention your LinkedIn profile link
and also your GitHub repository link if
you have next up is the projects now
clearly depict the goal of your project
so just in case you worked on like C5
projects make sure you keep it concise
and crisp next up is your education do
not lie here make sure you give a
relevant education with grades next you
have the certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you'll have to
clearly depict your work you'll have to
make sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job Rule and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as I mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
Python we since python is open source as
as I had already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in in Python
and we create it in a particular system
here on Windows we don't need to make
any changes if we wanted to use the same
script or that same piece of code on
some other system say on a Linux system
or a Mac system python itself comes with
a very large standard Library this this
facilitates us a lot because we don't
need to create our own libraries or
modules or have to download very
specific libraries most of the problems
that we do encounter uh quite commonly
can already be solved by the standard
libraries that have already been
provided by the developers of python
right right from the beginning now later
later on during the course we will
encounter what is the meaning of a data
structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific runtime just for that so this
allows us to create our programs and
solutions much faster and allows us to
debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to reminder like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop be
creating desktop guis image processing
graphic design applications and uh
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses uh there are many Technologies
in the environment of python that were
almost designed for the specific purpose
of being able to present certain
Concepts or to be able to teach certain
classes and I can't think of too many
programs or too many environments
outside of python that are better to
solve these Education and Training
course related problems and situations
let's uh let's get to actually
installing python so now that so I will
show you how to install python on
Windows since I have a Windows system uh
however I will also point out the way
you you would have to install python on
a on Mac OS or Linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your Windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the download
section when you do click on downloads
you get redirected to this website that
this webpage that I'm on out here it by
default it will ask you if you want to
download python 3.9 which is the latest
version but of course if you for
whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well by just scrolling
down and choosing the option that you
want now it's important to note that
whatever option you choose of course I
would recommend the latest one but no
matter what option you choose I would
recommend you choose a version of python
three point something because previous
versions of python namely Python 2.7 and
uh and basically every version of python
2. something has it will not receive any
more maintenance and updates because the
developers have decided that python will
that trying to shift towards the
maintaining and updating python three
point whatever completely right now so
yeah let's not delay this uh any further
and let's download python 3.9 so once
you select the option out here uh you'll
be you'll get an installer all you have
to do is click on that and it'll give
you two options to customize
installation or install now I would of
course recommend this blue install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into uh the drive where your windows is
actually installed your your main drive
so as you can see now that once my setup
is done it should give me a pop-up soon
so my setup is done for Python and this
is essentially how you would
um download python on your Windows
system uh but what if you had Mac OS or
if you were using Linux well for Mac
it's a it's actually almost as simple
you just go if you see out here below
this download button python option you
get the website asking you are you
looking for python on a different OS and
it gives you the options of Linux Mac
and even other os's but for Mac if you
wanted you would just open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if I
wanted say python the latest one I would
just download this installer and I would
install in my Mac system now when it
comes to Linux I cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
just choose the Linux option out here it
will take you to a page with a different
installers and essentially packages for
Linux systems in specific what I would
recommend to you if you are a Linux user
and you need python is to go over to the
realpython.com website and they have a
very good essentially instructions on
how to install Python and since I don't
have a Linux system I cannot directly
show you how to install python on Linux
so yeah if you do have Linux please head
over to this website and this should be
of a lot of help to you now as I had
mentioned you can actually install
python on your mobile devices as well so
if you were say an iOS user you would go
to the iOS App Store and download an app
called the python is the app for iOS it
essentially is like a full-fledged
python environment where you can develop
in Python on your iPhone or even iPad
and if you're an Android User you could
you would go and download an app called
the pi Droid 3. there's a free version
and a paid version for this app and of
course the difference between the free
and paid is that the paid supports uh
code analysis and code prediction these
are certain details you don't have to
worry about right now and honestly if I
wouldn't worry too much about installing
python on your mobile devices currently
since I am assuming most people would be
learning program programming and
programming in Python on their PCS or
laptops what I had actually shown you
was installing what is called an
implementation of python on your system
and implementation is essentially a
program or a software or an environment
that allows you to actually work and
python so what I showed you was how to
install the by default or the most basic
or reference implementation that has
been created by the developers which is
actually called C python even though you
were not you would not have seen the
word the letter c or the prefix C but
yeah that implementation that I had I
had downloaded myself and I had shown
you to download is actually the C python
implementation which is python built on
top of C the the C language essentially
there are other implementations such as
iron python which uses the.net framework
and J python that uses Java virtual
machines that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that I would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python I want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you this
distribution is called Anaconda Anaconda
is a very important distribution
especially if you are looking to use
python in data science and machine
learning and AI which I am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards the
moving towards data science and if that
is your goal or in any case whatever
your goal may be I would recommend that
you install Anaconda distribution now do
not get confused between anaconda and
python their Anaconda is python with in
the form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that I had shown you to
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and Technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
what you need to download both of course
not if you download a python you do not
need Anaconda to work on Python and if
you have already downloaded Anaconda
which I will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
Anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so I'll just speak
about Anaconda little briefly so as I
said it's a distribution it it contains
a bundle which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of Technologies
and softwares and applications that have
essentially help us to use python in in
in specifically managing their big data
applications and data science related
projects so so now I will show you
actually how to install python I mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if I did
a quick quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where It'll ask you if you want
to download and again there are options
depending on which machine you're using
if you're using a Linux you would choose
one of these two if you are using Mac OS
you would use one of these two and since
I am a Windows user and I have a 64-bit
system this is the option I would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been downloaded so upon
opening it it will open up this
installation thing and you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the C drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so this
is how you install an account on Windows
and it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done I
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that Anaconda contains
that are not there if you installed
python like the way I had shown you
earlier just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete and
now I will open anaconda and I'll show
you what how you can actually use this
Anaconda so if I search for anaconda in
my system I would look for something
called Anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when I open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the Anaconda Navigator and as you can
see there are a bunch of applications
you don't need to worry about what these
mean right now just understand that this
this is essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install Anaconda Navigator now now
that we have actually tackled where
we've seen how to install and I'm hoping
and I would recommend definitely that
everyone is watching this video installs
Anaconda not just the normal python
installation or implementation now that
we have gotten all the introductions in
the basics and the installations
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is how
do we actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed uh python like uh now let's
how do we start doing something so the
answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic thing that you
can do is create a python script and
execute a script script essentially a
sequence of commands and instructions
that you give for python to run and
execute to give you a certain result so
I will show you how you can create a
python script now there are multiple
ways of creating a python script you can
create it directly from command line
which is obviously something I would not
recommend because it is not convenient
and easy and it's not very useful for a
beginner another way is using a text
editor such as the one I have opened
right now which is the notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows or wordpad for that
matter in fact text editors such as
notepad and wordpad that you are more
familiar with create text and files in a
form that is called Rich Text Now Rich
Text is something is text that contains
format setting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and these
formattings and it only respects white
spaces and indentations those two being
actually useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents that is very that
was actually created with programming in
mind obviously you can use a bunch of
other text editors such as vim and atom
and you can Google for these there are
plenty of them so without any further
Ado let's create our first python script
so one of the most common one of the
most famous examples of a first program
in any program for that matter not just
python is creating a print statement
that gives us a statement saying hello
world so enter in Python this is how you
would go about oh this is the syntax you
would use to create the statement all
right now weight is very important when
you are saving your Python program that
you use the dot py prefix so so if I
were to save this I can choose whatever
folder I am going to choose yeah this
folder seems fine so now I give the file
name over here as say I want to keep it
as test I need to prefix this Dot py and
this tells any uh sort of interpreter or
anytime we need to read the script to
know that it's a python script we need
to add a DOT py otherwise it will not be
treated as a python script it'll be
treated as some normal document sort of
a thing so now that I have stored it as
dot py I have created my first python
script now obviously the next question
is I need to see what happens when I
execute this line when I run this script
essentially so to see that there are
multiple ways the first way that I will
show you is a command line method which
is obviously 3 again before we get into
it it's not something that I will be
using to teach you it's not something I
would recommend you to immediately start
using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that I am in in
my command line I would just have to
enter this Command right now so if I
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what I wanted I wanted it to
print this uh these two words and of
course the command line is now waiting
for the next command for me so this is
uh one of the most simple ways for the
most rudimentary ways of executing a
python script now another question would
be well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to the
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you see here it's
a Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
common solar console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the idle IDE it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle IDE comes as
part of the basic python implementation
that I had shown you in the previous
video where you if you just installed a
basic uh python implementation it would
come along with a basic IDE known as
idli or integrated development and
learning environment but of course since
we are using Python and this is what I
would recommend it comes with a more
robust IDE called spider which is
actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of it in Python let's
say python programs and it's something
that I will be using extensively
throughout this course to explain
different concepts so this technology is
called or the software is called uh
notebooks now before I get into the
details I will state I will just open
node a basic notebook so the notebook
that comes as part of anaconda is called
the Jupiter notebook and when I open
when I launch the Jupiter notebook this
is what I get now a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here now you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs or
larger program terms you like you'll
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like uh what
is the result of just this print
statement or just this uh it's not
typically what an IDE is used for and
this is where notebooks come in super
handy if I had to break down my previous
script essentially where I first did a
print statement where I said some random
thing say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means five plus three which is
8 and I've essentially broken down
various different parts of my previous
script into into its individual tasks
and I'm able to see what each part of
that script does and this is very good
when it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with Expressions well an expression in
Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
audio calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually it's much easier to store
objects in Python instead of using the
objects explicitly themselves because
objects may be very compute complicated
whereas variables are very simple to use
and very simply very are named in a very
simple manner so that we can use them
quite often in our programs now it's
important to note that in Python we do
not have to explicitly declare or Define
a variable to create them in fact
variables are created in the same
statement where we assign some object to
the variable in Python the assignment of
variables happens using the assignment
operator which is the equals design so
if I were to if I wanted to assign a
number say 100 to a variable say B well
it would be as simple as doing this now
anytime I want to know what is stored in
B I just have to enter B and I will get
the value that is stored in it and we
can store different types of objects
inside any variable let's say I store I
want to store this particular word in
the form of a string now this is stored
in X and if I want to know what is an X
I can just see what is here and it's a
string hello which I had stored earlier
now it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown error so we might get
some problems in our program
so the first rule is that you cannot
start your variable name with a number
so if I were to give a variable name
like 4 num is equal to something say the
same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and I would get an
error when I try this so if I were to
choose a num 4 is equal to hello this
would be perfectly fine I won't get an
error the second rule is we are not
allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are user identifiers for
certain special functions in Python that
we that have a special purpose like that
particular word has a special purpose
within the Python programming language
and you cannot use them to name our
variables so a list of them as you can
see over here some of them are like
false def if Del Rays and there are like
are there are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh where we try to
really understand what do we mean by
storing data inside a variable now when
I say that we are storing something
inside a variable you get an image or
you get an idea in your head that this
variable is like a container where we
store or we put a particular object
inside it so does this mean that
variables have a place in the memory are
they are also an object that is placed
in a memory where we can put other
objects inside of well I'll show you an
example where this idea is kind of
disproven or where I'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say I'm storing the same object I
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and I'm going to
store it into two different variables so
I take X is equal to 100 over here and
in the next line I will store 100 in y
as well now if objects were I mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then X and Y should have two
different IDs but let's see what happens
when I check the ID of X and the ID of Y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the ID of X and the ID of
Y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
Python cannot have the same ID so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in Python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
I said X is equal to 100 and Y is equal
to 100 what I am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called X that I want to refer or
Point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and I do the
same thing with another other variable y
so I am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and idea 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in this system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else in y see I stored this
list in my 50 60 100 and when I do that
now Y is pointing towards a different
object in Python and X is also pointing
towards something else so what happens
to this object 50 well now that there's
no variable referring to this object 50
it becomes what we call an orphaned
object and we can actually see that when
we do the ID of X now let's go back to
my example on the right where I stored X
is equal to 100 so as you can see it
gives me some ID represented by this
number now let's say I stored x i stored
something different say 200 now if I do
the ID of X it should give me a
different ID because as you can see the
values are different and this is because
this object 200 is what is stored in X
and when I do the ID of X I'm actually
getting the ID of this new object now
200 so as you can see Point as you can
see variables are they should be and
they are treated more like references or
pointers instead of containers for a
particular object in this video you will
be introduced to the concept of objects
in Python now what are objects in Python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually stored in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the Boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in Python has three
important properties that kind of Define
that particular object they are its
ident entity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one at once it has been
created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in Python have an identity we
have another operation with regarding
the identity of an object it's the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example in numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string Str stands for string similarly
if I did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
Python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system now within this
memory we have objects created called 50
and hello and this list containing
smaller objects called cat pen and 40.
now what I'm trying to show you here is
each of these objects have a type an ID
and a value and let's see what they are
if I wanted to see as we had already
seen the type of 50 now let's find the
ID of 50 as you can see we get this
unique ID for the object 50 which is
obviously not the same as the ID of the
object hello above and the value of this
object is the value as 50 itself so that
was a brief and introduction into
objects in Python in this video we will
cover the topics of numeric object types
and type conversions in Python now let's
get started numeric object types in
Python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in Python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in Python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
Python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent new builds that contain
decimal points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8
minus 6.8 and so on then there is the
complex object type which is used to
represent complex numbers in Python and
this is an example of a complex number 3
plus 7j okay this is a complex number
three plus seven J where the real
component is 3 and the imaginary
component is seven all complex numbers
have a real and imaginary component and
this is how we denote them now it's
important to note that this J is a very
common symbol in maths and Engineering
used to denote the imaginary portion of
a complex number and it's the same in
python as well so moving on let's talk
about type conversion in Python type
conversion refers to the conversion of
an object from one data type to another
for example from string to an integer
and there are different types of
conversions and let's go through some of
them first of all let's consider the
conversion of something to an integer
and more specifically let's consider the
example where we convert a string to an
integer so let's consider my example
string to be some something called 145
and I'm sewing this within a string for
a reason because I want to convert is
string to an integer so as you can see I
have stored this one for 5 within my
within a variable X and if I were to
confirm that is actually an integer I
can use the type function and see that
it is actually an integer Str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the End
by passing the variable that we want to
convert into the int function and as you
can see this is what I've done over here
but before this I will also store it
into another variable all right now
let's see what's in y well y gives us 1
4 5 but are we sure there is an end we
can just check it by using the type
function and as you can see the type
gives us the answer end that means that
we've converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and also specify what base we have to
treat the number as by default when we
pass something in the in function the
program or python will treat whatever we
have passed uh within the string as
something in base sub decimal but what
if we were to pass something that is
well not in a decimal maybe we could do
it like this now let's store Y and in y
let's store
let's do this and I will show you what
this means X and I will give a comma and
eight what this tells python is well I
want to convert the string in X into an
integer but I want to treat whatever is
an X as a number of Base 8 so 145 is
actually 145 in the base 8 now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 120.0 and
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and 1.120.0
is a different object which is a float
and this is how we convert something to
a float now what if we wanted to convert
an integer to a string well we can use
the Str function we can also use the hex
and the OC function if we want to
convert a particular number to a
hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what's in a it gives
688 in the form of a string but we can
confirm by checking the type of a it is
an Str so it is a string similarly we
can use hex if we wanted to convert an
integer into its hexadecimal equivalent
in the in in as an output of a string as
you can see this comp this or is sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero should not be treated
as anything it's more like a an
identifier which says that the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2 B 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688 similarly if I
did opt if I use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first 0 is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this 0 is the base of the
number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an OCT
represented by this letter O and the
number itself that we are dealing with
is one two six zero and one two six zero
in octal system is the equivalent of 688
in the decimal system so this is how
we've converted a an integer in an
integer into a hexadecimal or a an octal
string now what if we wanted to convert
two numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if I passed complex 5 and say say
something like 3.1 let's see what this
gives us as you can see it gives us an a
complex object where our real part is 5
and our imaginary part is 3.1 so what
this does is essentially you pass two
numbers the first one is the real
component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if I
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
I will use the Tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say I have a
string called random let's call it
random all right now if I want to
convert this to a tuple I will use the
Tuple function as you can see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual component end of this
Tuple are the individual components or
the individual characters of my string
random similarly if I wanted to convert
the string to a list I would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters of the
word or the the string random and I
could do the same thing with the set
function to create a set of individual
characters of the string random as you
can see here so yeah these were some of
the basic python type conversions that I
have shown you as we learn about more
complex data types and different object
types in Python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
Python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence now
strings in Python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
Python which contain components placed
one of the other where each component is
given what we call an index a numeric
Index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and its
position within the sequence now since
python is a zero index based language
the first object of any sequence is
always index 0 the second is index 1 the
third is index 2 and so on now let's
move on to defining strings how do we
Define them well strings are defined
using what we call delimiters and
delimiters occur in pairs in opening and
a closing delimiter in Python these
zerometers are pairs of single or double
quotes so for example if I were to use
single quotes to define a string I could
I would do it like this this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if I were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see now a valid question
arises what if I wanted to include a
single code within my string well if I
try to let's see what happens if I try
to print a statement with a single quote
naturally inside it so say I'm saying
it's my birthday all right let's see
what happens if I try to print this
statement it says invalid syntax and
this is because as I had mentioned in
Python single quotes and double quotes
are delimiters so they have a special
function in Python and we cannot simply
just use them within a string because
python will treat them specially for a
special purpose so what python will do
is it will pair this and this delimiters
or single quotes and say okay this looks
like a string to me and it's not going
to understand the rest of this and then
it will find a random single quote and
it won't find its pair and it will
basically throw us an error because of
this so one way or one word around to
introduce single quotes into a string is
simply to delimit our string itself
using the other type of delimiter or
double quotes So if I want to include a
single quote I will close my string
using double quotes So if I did this
instead of what I had done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and I could I
would do the opposite if I had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string I would use single quotes to
close it so if I were to write a speech
statement she said
I am
hungry all right I have I want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and I'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has this two double quotes now I
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how array sequences
so first of all all sequences in Python
are a
um it's a essentially a sequence of
smaller objects that form the sequence
right so let's try to understand like
how do how are strings to be treated as
sequences some sequences that we will
learn later are like lists or tuples and
in all sequences we can retrieve any
particular object or component in that
sequence using its index and how do we
use indexes in Python well we enclose a
numeric index within square brackets now
let's see what I'm trying to talk about
by this example now say I'm storing a
particular string called say random
within so now my variable name here is
test and I'm storing the string random
within it all right and this is the way
of retrieving a particular index from
test I write the variable name and then
next to it I put the square brackets now
I'm supposed to put a numeral within the
square brackets to tell python like what
a particular index I'm looking for so
let's try 0. now as I said python is
zero index based language so the zero
index essentially means the first part
of or the first component of a sequence
so let's see what happens when I ask
python to retrieve the first part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string R in fact it's just one character
R and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is R so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
Random is essentially a collection of
the string R the string a the string n
and so on together combine to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if I wanted the character at
the third position of this thing I would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in Python I would
use the index too and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter N so this is how we can
show that strings are also sequences in
Python well now let's move on to
um certain string operations and
functions that we can perform well as
you have seen already that we can
retrieve any particular character within
a
um within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we wanted to know what
index is a particular character at then
we can do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and I want
to know where where or what position the
character D is in my string random so
this is how I would use the index
function index and within the index say
I'm looking for the character D and now
I it should give me the answer 0 1 2 it
should give me the answer three so if I
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is uh the index function that we
could use for our strings now what if we
want to
um say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part you want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say I'm gonna I'm gonna use the same
string called random and stored in test
right so let's so one way of so the way
of doing this is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if I went to my
string random A and D is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what I
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice from the first position uh the
first index which is the character a up
until the fourth position which is the
character o but it has not included o so
it's very important when I index like
this every every time I put something to
the right of this colon I am not
including this itself all right so it's
essentially one when I say one colon
four what I'm telling python is give me
the first the second and the third
character but not the fourth one so it's
given me a n and d and it's that's this
is how we do a slicing operation in
Python similarly if I were to say slice
from the first if I wanted only first
and the second character I would do this
is what I would do if I wanted the first
and the second character I would do one
two three so this way it says python
that I want the first I want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
I get a and N now so this is a basic
slicing what if I wanted the portion of
a string from a particular Point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where I want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way I would do
this is test now since I want it all the
way to the left I don't enter any index
to the left of my colon sign and since I
want everything to the left of the
fourth character I enter 4 here so as
you can see it gives me A R A and D
which is everything from the fourth
character of my string random to the
left similarly if I wanted something to
the right of it I would just do it like
this I would enter some index here and I
I would leave the portion to the right
of the colon blank so this will give me
everything including the third character
since this is how we treat the indexing
in Python everything including the third
character all the way to the right so
this is Dom as you can see now another
perfectly valid um slicing is say I want
to slice or take out different
characters from the string but I want to
skip certain characters like I want this
one then I want to skip one and I want
to take the next one and then I want to
skip one well in that case we have to
introduce a step so one way of doing
this is now how do we read this so as
you can see I've written 0 colon six
colon two so what this is telling python
is I want every character from my string
test uh starting from the zeroth
character up until the sixth but not
including the sixth after skipping or
taking two at a time taking two at a
time can also be assumed as uh skipping
one at each step or skipping one
character at each step so what this will
do is it'll go to random it will take
the zeroth one we'll take R and then it
will skip the next one so it will not
consider a and then it will pick n and
then it will not consider D and then it
will consider o up until the sixth
character whichever that whichever that
may be and if you see the output it
gives us R and O which is exactly what
we wanted we wanted R we wanted n we
wanted o where we skipped uh A and D or
we skipped the every second character
essentially so this is a way of
um slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if I were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is the minus one index it
gives me the character M now remember a
string Is Random so minus 1 gave us the
last character of the string random
which was m so this is a way of using
negative indexes and similarly if I used
to test minus 2 it would give me the
second last character which should be
the character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in Python for that
let's create another let's create
another string let's call it upper lower
all right I'm sorting it again in the
same variable test let's see what
happens when I use the upper function
and what happens when I use the lower
function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full
uppercase and the second one created
this by the string in four lowercase now
another important and probably one of
the most important methods that we use
for Strings especially when it comes to
data science is the split function so
let's see what I mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I stored both
of these into what we call a list now
you might ask well how does python know
that it has to separate at a blank space
well the split function by default will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or at every comma so for example
if I wrote hello world using comma and
if I put a comma inside over here and
now if I try to execute this like for
example I am going to find I'm going to
look for commas in the string and I'm
gonna try to split it as you can see
there's no splitting happening I have
one list with my original string itself
because it's not found a comma what if I
introduced a comma over here now let's
see what happens as you can see the
splitting has happened it's found this
comma and is caused a split between
hello and World similarly if I in my
string if I put this comma again and I
put something else it should give me the
split over there again so we can Define
our split using some whatever we put
between these Circle brackets after the
split function it's just important to
note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting uh
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if I have two
strings first and say another string
second and I want to join these together
well the operator I would use to do this
is called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
uh this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenate concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use a single coat in my string I
just close it using double quotes or if
I want to use a double quote I close it
using single well another way of doing
this is using what we call an escape
sequence and an escape sequence in
Python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when I
use the backslash character where I want
to introduce my single code so if I use
my previous example where I wanted to
introduce a single quote and say I am
going to close it using single quotes as
well so I'm going to go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if I
used the escape sequence that I
mentioned the Escape sequences is
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where I want my my
single code so I introduce a backslash
now I have my single quote and I
continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python do
not trade this special character or the
single quote to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other use
case of Escape sequences is when we want
to give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views the character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the character T itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t let's see what it does it
introduces this thing that we called a
tab space which is a larger than normal
space similarly if I were to use the
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combinational
backslash m a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that I use
in this video I will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what a sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we Define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way or a
simple list that I have just created and
assigned to a variable a which contains
three objects one two and three let's
talk about some of the features of
python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and see if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they're not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are Dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making our as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are programming without having to go
through a compilation stage so if we had
to say increase the or we had to add
certain elements to an already created
list that original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now
and I can put strings as well into my
list all of these are valid uh when it
comes to objects that can be put inside
a list we have no such restrictions so
we can put any arbitrary objects inside
our list the final property that I want
to talk about is that lists are they can
be nested to any arbitrary depth what
this means is that I can put a list
within a list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it'll
give me one two and three index objects
so it should give me 2 3 and 4 in this
case as you can see here two three and
four I can do the same thing by
considering elements say two at a time
if I wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what I
would do is this syntax I would use this
syntax and when I give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is I want every element from a from
index 1 to index 4 but not including
index 4 but I am going to consider
considered to every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
double changes to four all right so
let's see what happens when I take every
second element it should give it should
give me uh it will consider say from one
to index three right so it should
consider essentially this section but
since it's going to skip one it's going
to consider this skip this and then
consider this it should give me two and
four as you can see it has given me two
and four and like in other sequences we
can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus 1 on it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
object six if I did a minus 2 it gives
me the second last element similarly
another neat trick that we can use for
sequences is the following syntax double
colon and we give a minus one what this
tells the what this tells the system is
I want the list a but with all the
elements reversed so as you can see I
get my element uh my list a but the
elements have been reversed right now
let's move on to uh concatenation and
replication well concatenation much like
in strings is done by using the plus
sign so as we know on either side of the
plus sign should be two similar objects
so if I'm doing a plus something a being
a list on the other side it should be a
list as well so let's add a list like
this now let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning of a list I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this
it will throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an end object and it's
not a list but when I put the square
brackets I make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if I did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where I'm repeating
the values in a twice if I did a star 3
it's the same function but now I'll have
the elements repeated Thrice as you can
see here let's move on to modifying list
values uh this also shows the mutable
property of lists that I had mentioned
earlier so let's consider this example
so I created a list with elements where
it is the three strings eggs apples and
carrots and I have five int objects one
two three four and five now if I wanted
to change say the first element all I
have to do is take the 0th index and say
if I want to replace eggs with same
mango this is how I would do it now
replace eggs with mango if I check
what's in B you can see the eggs have
been replaced with the element mango
similarly I can use the slice syntax to
replace a particular slice from my list
with a slice essentially so let's look
at this I'm replacing I want to replace
the first three elements I want to
replace mango I want to replace apple
and carrot so what I will do is I will
consider this since this carrot is the
second index so I will consider 0 to 3
because third is not counted now I'm
going to replace this with three
different
um let's see kiwi
and it's a sponge now let's check what's
in B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how I'll do
it let's say
wine now let's check what's here as you
can see three elements have been
replaced with one mine I can double vice
versa as well I can replace smaller
number of elements with a larger number
of elements but here there is a slight
caveat that I want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if I wanted to replace the first element
wine with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
that elements index and then put
whatever objects you want say I want to
add instead of wine I want to add beer I
want to add ball and say Club yeah well
let's see what happens now if I say B
check what's inside my you can see my
elements have been added but they seem
to have been added as is you know I had
entered a list over here and that whole
list has been replaced uh or this wine
has been replaced by this whole list in
the first position but that's not
exactly what I want wanted I wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what I'm going to show you now
if you want to replace one if I want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 I would give this statement a slice
statement where I will give 0 colon 1 so
when I do this and if I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I had wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so when I do a append
and say if I want to append the list by
one object called four I just do it like
this now let's see what's in a I put so
as you can see the append has put the
object 4 into my original list now say
if I wanted to append three different
objects I want to append five six and
seven now let's see what a pen function
does oh no as you can see it's done a
similar operation to what we have seen
earlier when we gave a single index or
the single element replacement uh that
we saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what I
wanted I wanted five six and seven to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what I'll
show you next now if I want to extend
Say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when I use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what I wanted now the next
method that I want to discuss is the
remove method so the remove method is
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the object that is
present in the list that you want to
removed so you don't give an index over
here you give the object itself so if I
want the object 8 all right this number
if I want 8 itself removed what I will
do is put the value 8 here and it will
remove it from my list so if I check my
list a as you can see the value 8 has
it's gone an X another similar function
to remove is the pop function now the
pop function by default will remove the
rightmost value from the list but unlike
remove the pop function actually outputs
a value and that value is what we have
popped out of the list so by default it
will pop out the right route right most
value of a list right most element of a
list and in this case that element is 10
so it should give me 10 but of course if
we want to pop out any particular object
in this case we will not give that
particular object we give its index so
now say if I want to remove this uh this
list object from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two Key Properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parenthesis instead of square
brackets so this is how I would Define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that differentiates
tuples from lists is that tuples are
immutable and what this means is that
once we create an object of type Tuple
we cannot make any modifications to it
we would have to only create a new
object if we wanted something different
and this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this every operation that we have
done on lists are actually possible to
do in the case of tuples as well so any
operation that we did to lists that did
not modify the list or that does not do
any modification we can actually apply
to tuples as well so if I wanted the
first element of this difficult all I
have to do is call it by the index 0 it
should give me the value 1 as you can
see if I wanted a slice I can do that as
well it should give me 2 and 3 and if I
wanted to reverse my Tuple well I can
use my same neat technique that I've
used for lists and that I can use for
the sequence I mean strings as well so
it gives me my old Tuple but with the
elements reversed so now the natural
question is why do we use Tuple server
lists well one important difference is
that when we can when we make a program
execution where or where we are
manipulating a tuple if we did the same
thing for the exact same objects in uh
that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over this
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an ordered list of
objects that we don't need to or we
don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over lists or why we need a tuple
instead of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what uh what I mean by uh the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually uh learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuples
over a list uh a brief section on Tuple
unpacking and packing is what I would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when I create when I give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a variable T
now what's very interesting is and this
is something that's very key to tuples
is that I can unpack a tuple onto
another Tuple so let me show you what I
mean by that so now that I have packed
one two three and four Tuple into T
let's unpack it into another Tuple let's
call this let's uh put these elements
into this Tuple and I put this into T
alright now let's see what I mean by
unpacking something onto something let's
see what's the what what happens when I
put a if I just want to see what's in a
it actually gives me the value one if I
see what's in B it gives me the value 2
if I see what's in three invalid 3 and D
gives me value four so essentially if
you think of it what I have done is I
have matched this Tuple then put it into
T and then put that Tuple T into this
Tuple a b and c d so what it's what what
has happened essentially is the element
a has been or a better way to say this
would be the element one has been packed
onto or unpacked onto a two has been
unpacked onto B three has been unpacked
onto C 4 has been unpacked onto D to
show you what I've done in a single line
is essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's the value in y it
is six if I see what is the value of x
and z it should give me a tuple
containing five and seven as you can see
over here so this is a neat feature of
tuples called packing and packing in
this video we will cover Concepts
surrounding dictionaries dictionaries
are another type of composite data type
in Python there are also a collection of
objects much like tuples and lists and
like lists they are also mutable Dynamic
and can be nested however a key
difference and property of dictionaries
is that they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlisted tuples where the objects
are assigned numerical indexes to define
a dictionary we use curly braces each
key value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
I have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each repair themselves are separated
by commas and these are enclosed in
curly braces to define the whole
dictionary in this example the these are
the keys banana apple and grape and
their respective values are yellow red
and green so this is very important that
in this particular data type we have
what we call a key and that key is
assigned a value and we can have
multiple such pairings and we have three
such pairs in this particular example
another example or the or another type
of way to define a dictionary is using
the dict function this is how we use it
as you can see I have inputted two value
or two object tuples this is a tuple
this is atopal and this is 80 opal and
when I use it in a dict function when I
place it within a list what python will
do is it will consider the first element
of each Tuple as a key and the second
element of each Tuple as its respective
value now if I check what's in D as you
can see the key banana has a value
yellow the key apple has a value red the
key grape has a value green so this is
another way of defining dictionaries an
important note over here is that the the
objects that we use for Keys have to be
of an immutable data type so we cannot
use for example lists as an example of
keys but we can use say integers or
strings for our dictionary Keys also
Keys have to be unique when it comes to
a dictionary you cannot have two
different keys with uh or should I say
the same key having two different values
you can have only one key and that one
key will have a unique value assigned to
it duplicate keys are not allowed
however when we speak about values we
have no such restrictions you can have
immutable or an immutable data type as a
value in a dictionary and you can have
duplicates as well so if I created a
dictionary with a key say banana
and if I give if I associate it with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I'll give
it a value yellow or say green if I
created another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as as you can see over here now what if
I wanted to remove if I wanted to remove
a key value pair from my dictionary I
can use the delete function which is
called by using this the Del function
now how do I do it say if I want to
remove the key value Apple in Red so all
I have to do is do del d and within
square brackets I have to only mention
the key I don't even need to mention the
value just the key so you can probably
draw parallels in how we use indexes
when it comes to lists and tuples and
even strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I oops I
think red is actually not a key as you
can see red is a value my key is Apple
actually it's not red it's apple as you
can see now if I see my dictionary the
key apple and its value red has been
removed so these are some of the
operation questions that we can do for
dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use a
get function all we have to do is enter
a key inside the parenthesis and it will
get the value associated with that key
so if I gave the key grip let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green there is also a function
called items that Returns the key and
value pairs in our dictionary as a list
of two object tuples where the first
object is the key and the second object
is the Tuple so let's see what it does
as you can see it gave me a list and in
this list the objects inside the list
are two object pupils where the first
object is always the key and the second
is the value and and it's the same for
each of the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called KV so as I had mentioned I will
use two object tuples in this case and
say I give this also a value green all
right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with a value yellow
and I already have a dictionary D with
these values all right now if I want to
merge these two dictionaries I can use
the update function what I do is say if
I want to merge D with X or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video I will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type
item it's also known as the data model
in Python and it probably has other
names so essentially in what we do or
what we speak about in this is uh how
the different types that we use in
Python are categorized and classified
and what are their subtypes so it's
important to note before we continue
further that there in future versions of
python there might be new types that are
introduced or the existing ones may be
modified but it's safe to say that what
I will speak about in this video will
still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the non-type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it uh then there is the
ellipses uh ellipse is something that
you might encounter later it is accessed
through the built-in name Ellipsis
um it is used to indicate the presence
of this particular
um syntax this particular symbol or
expression uh or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we've seen
we've worked with numbers a lot they are
an immutable type they are created
through numeric literals and they are
the outputs of arithmetic expressions
and built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers
um within integers you have plain
integers that represent numbers in the
range this number and this number so
this this number is basically the
largest positive value that you can
represent using 32 bit notation induce
complement and this is the equivalent a
for the the negative the negative side
long in teachers on the other hand are
used to represent numbers in an
unlimited range that is only subject to
the available memory of your system so
these are two types of integers and as
we know floating Point numbers represent
Machine level double Precision floating
Point numbers or numbers with a decimal
point and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating Point number that represents a
real part and a floating Point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed by natural numbers
so each element in a sequence has an
index and that index is a natural number
the different types of sequences are
based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify I don't know and that is
how we differentiate different types of
sequences so there are mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
lists lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are again
um sets of objects but these objects are
now indexed using arbitrary index sets
you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects and sequences
are always numbers they're natural
numbers whereas in mappings they are not
natural numbers but they are certain
arbitrary objects that we can set for
ourselves again in Python there is only
one built in standard mapping type that
is the dictionary dictionaries are there
they represent finite sets of objects
indexed by nearly arbitrary values the
only condition is that these indexes
must be of an immutable data type so
these uh so what I have mentioned until
now are probably the most common data
types that we encounter or that we have
encountered now so next types are like
callable types such as user defined
functions user defined methods built-in
functions built-in methods classes and
class instances so again callable types
as a whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type of
modules so modules are module objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning in this video I will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in Python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so so a simple
addition operation would be like five
plus six giving me the value 11 I can do
5 minus 3 and that's subtraction
similarly I can do a multiplication
using five say five into two there's
division where I use the backslash so
say I did division of 8 divided by 2.
now you might encounter another type of
division which is called the flow
division where we use a double backslash
and what this does is it returns us the
largest whole number that is lesser than
the result of our division so the
division difference between the float
Division and and the normal fluid and
the floor division or the single and the
double backslash is this say I did 9
divided by 2 using a single backslash it
should give me as you can see 4.5 right
so this is the actual value now let's
see what happens when I do 9 double
backslash 2 it will give me 4 which is
the largest number lesser than or equal
to 4.5 that is also a whole number so
this is what we call flower division
essentially finally we also have if we
want to raise something to the power or
something so if I want to do fire say 6
raised to the power 3 because I would
use double asterisks and this is how I
would do it it'll give me 216 as you can
see uh if I wanted remainder between the
division between two different numbers I
will use the percentage sign so if I
wanted the remainder of the division
between seven and three this is how I
would do it I get the answer 1 as you
can see so next category of operations
are logical operations the first one is
the logical and operation where we use
the operator end all right so let's see
what we mean by this I am creating so as
we know the and operation Returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so let's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value false
so it should be done like this false so
now think of it like one and zero so a
one and zero is obviously zero right so
if I did A and B I should get the answer
false or zero because I'm doing true and
false so it's like doing one and zero so
if you see this I should get the answer
false if I change this to true as well
now if I do this I will get the answer
true as you can see uh the next logical
operation is the or operation where well
uh logical or is if either of the
operands are true then we should get the
answer to our or operation as true as
well so in this case obviously if I did
or over here it will naturally give us
true if I change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3. if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and why are not
the same so there's false they are not
equal if I change this also to 2 now I
will get the answer to another the next
comparison is the not equal to or maybe
use the exclamation sign so over here
this is this um the result of this is
true if X and Y are not actually it's
the same so I should get false over here
as you can see but if I change this to
say 5 now I will get true because X is
not equal to Y in this case the next one
is greater than so if I did X greater
than y as we can see 2 is not greater
than 5 I will get false over here
similarly there is a lesser than if I
did X less than y I should get true over
here as you can see well there's also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if I say x is
lesser than or equal to 3 I should get
true because X is 2 and if I put 2 here
I should also get true but what if I put
one here since X is equal to 2 and 2 is
not less than equal to 1 this is a false
statement and I can do the same thing
with like this using the greater than
equal to now it's true because 2 is
actually greater than equal to 1. and so
this was comparison operations the next
set of operations that we can do in
Python are assignment operations we've
already seen a whole bunch we've already
been assigning values to variables we've
been doing assignments throughout
already but let's go over them and see
some of the assignment operations so as
we already know the equal to operation
is assigning everything that is on the
or the value on the right hand side of
the equal to sign to what is on the left
so if I did a is equal to 5 plus 6 it
will assign the value 5 plus 6 or 11 to
a let's check what's in a as you can see
it is 11. there is a plus equal to sign
and what this does is so for example if
I did say a now since a is 11 let's
create another variable called B and
call this 5 all right so now if I did a
plus equal to B what this will do is it
will add B to a and then store it in a
so let's see what this does once I do
this now let's check what's in a it
should be 5 plus 11 as you can see 16.
so this a plus this is this plus equal
to sign is essentially the same as doing
a is equal to a plus b it's essentially
the same thing they're both the same uh
there's a similar thing for this the
negative symbol or subtraction as well
minus equal to so now that a is 16 and B
is still 5 of course if I did minus
equal to B now I'm subtracting the value
5 from 16 so I should get a is equal to
11 again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus B A is
equal to a minus B I mean as you can see
so uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say B is equal to I
will say 2 right now if I do a star star
equal to B what this does is it
multiplies B to a and then assigns it
back to a so if I see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is a similar thing for
subtraction as well so if I did a is
equal to 6 and B is equal to 2 and if I
did a sorry for division so if I did a
division symbol and equal to sine and
then if I give B what it will do is it
will divide a by b or 6 by 2 and it will
assign that back to a so my value in a
should be 3 as you can see here 3.0
obviously this is a single uh single
backslash so this is a float division
the resultant of a single backslash is
always a float I can do the same thing
with a double backslash so let's see if
I did a is equal to 7 now and then B is
equal to 3. now if I did a double
backslash equal to B now it will do the
same division but uh it will do a floor
function so it should give me 2 in this
case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment uh say a is equal to say 5
now B is equal to 2 now if I do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 I mean b
which will give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left hand
upper end now let's see what's in a as
you can see it it did a divided by 2 the
modular symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by B and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if I have a is equal to say so 5 b is
equal to 2 and I want to raise a by if I
wanted to raise the value of a by the
value of B and then store that back in a
this is how I would do it so it should
be 5 to the power 2 which is 25 as you
can see here so this is assignment
operations so finally we move on to uh
two special sets of operators one is the
identity set identity operators and the
other is the membership operators uh
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to one thousand and one
and B is equal to one thousand plus one
all right if I did a is equal to 2. this
is an equality check are they the same
values true now if I say a is B let's
see what happens as you can see it's
false this is because this object and
this object are not the same and this is
what the is Operation does uh we can
confirm this by checking the ID of a the
ID of a gives us some value like this
and the ID of B gives us as you can see
a different value so the two objects are
not located in the same place in the
memory as we have seen using the ID
function and that is what we check uh
through the is operator and is not is
essentially just the opposite of that so
so that is the identity operator now the
membership operator is used for checking
whether something is present in a
sequence or not so let's create a
sequence I will create a list to show in
this example my list is one two and
three basically simple list with three
integer objects one two and three I will
check whether now say 2 in a so is 2 in
a if it is it will give me true as you
can see is 5 in a it should give me
false because 5 is not in a and the a
naught n operator is just the opposite
of that it checks the other condition
essentially so this is the membership
operators in Python in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
Python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in Python so starting off
what is this math module well uh the
python map module is an important
library or a feature that is uh designed
to deal with mathematical operations
this math module is part of the basic
python installation so you don't have to
install this separately to use this math
module all you have to do is import this
module and this is how you would do it
you just do import math and this will
import your math module for you to use
in your programming and in this in the
course of this video I will be showing
you certain Concepts surrounding the
math module such as what are the
constants that come with the mass module
some of the arithmetic functions the
logarithmetic functions power functions
and even trigonometric functions that we
can do using this math module and the
function inside the math module so
starting off let's look at some of the
constants that are part of this so as
you can see the standard constants are
available in this module are Pi there is
Tau there is Euler's number Nan which is
a special it's a it's a programming
specific concept and infinity so let's
look at this one by one so starting off
our first constant is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this Pi
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the match module
all you have to do is do match dot pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default thing for python that if
you call the pi a constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be in any
units 3 meters or whatever you want and
you want to find out it's say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if I had to find the circumference of a
circle in my C in my code for some
application with the radius 3 however
all I would have to do is use the
formula 2 pi r and to call the value 2
pi r instead of specifically writing
3.14 something I can just use this
function math dot pi over here and then
I can enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on uh the next constant that we
will talk about is Tau Tau is similar to
Pi in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to know this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use or this is the
syntax so as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default uh next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community
um you will be using the Euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or AI or something like
that so what is the Euler's number it is
uh it is the base of the natural
logarithm if you know what the natural
logarithm is it is used to calculate
rates of growth over rates of Decay and
as with number is a constants like pi
and Tau even the Euler's number is an
irrational number with infinite decimal
places uh the value of the Euler's
number in short it's denoted by the
small letter e so this value of e is our
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this constant is simply as
math dot e this is how we do it so you
get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
Infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is all
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this Infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of method.inst will give us
INF and this is this INF is actually not
a string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when I do a
type when I check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5 a special
type known as math.inf it returns this
INF data type which is equivalent waste
float so this is this is how we use
Infinity if you wanted to get the value
of say minus infinity all you would have
to do is match dot INF with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus INF now let's check if the
concepts or the properties of infinity
are maintained you know like every a
positive Infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
Infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this
um so I will take method in and I will
do a check is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact I can
change this number to anything as large
as I want this will be true because
Infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know and similarly if I
did minus math dot in INF and I checked
some very small number you know a very
very small negative number so just
consider some minus 10 to the power
something right this should also be true
uh sorry it should be a smaller sense
symbol this should also be true because
I'm checking minus infinity is smaller
than any known number to us and it is
true as you can see so it's very uh also
if you did a if you did something like
so let's say if we do let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when I add say 10 to positive Infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be Infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot INF
or the infinity constant in Python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of INF or Infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of math.inf you know
say minus say again let's say minus 100
so if you subtract something from minus
infinity we're technically still minus
infinity itself so this will again give
us my S and then minus INF as you can
see and this is absolutely what we need
and this is a very very interesting
feature in Python uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the na
a n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to is
used to denote invalid inputs or in it's
used to indicate a certain places where
say a variable that should have a number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where python expects a
number from us or from your code and it
does not get it it will throw you a n a
n value and this is usually used in
cases where you have errors in your code
so again just to check like what this
this constant like how to call it this
is how you actually do it maths.nan and
it will give you a data type called Nan
also much like the infinity cons
constant let's see what's the type of
this this constant again might look like
a string to you but of course this is
not a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for as you know factorial is
so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know
um so let's say we pass match dot
factorial for six and let's see what's
the value so this is exactly what we
expect so we expect the value of 6 times
5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that is
actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know 0 factorial is one now
let's see an error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us an error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function that
we'll talk about is the ceiling function
so the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I give you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at it now a negative number
so minus 12.3 uh an integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 is is minus 12
the smallest integer that is greater
than minus 12.3 and this should give you
12 as you can minus 12 as you can see
here a similar function is the floor
function which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than whatever value we pass
between the parenthesis so if I gave it
2.3 it should give me the value 2. again
if we pass integers it will just give us
the integer itself again it is to
reiterate this ceiling and flow
functions they give you into integer
values so the floor function will give
you the largest integer that is smaller
than what we pass over here so let's
look at 6.7 so the largest integer that
is smaller than 6.7 is 6 and as you can
see this is our answer over here uh the
next function that we will look at is
the truncate function the transcript
function is defined using this truncate
is very similar to what we have seen
this is how we Define the truncate
function uh it is very similar to the
ceiling and floor in the truncate
function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the vitamin between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seventh part and I will chop away
the 0.8 part if I gave it minus 12.3 uh
it will chop away the 0.3 part and give
me only minus 12 back so let's look at
an example 8.9 it should give me only
eight as you can see here see I did
minus 8 or minus
6.9 this will give me -6 so you can
think of truncade function as it does
the floor function for positive values
and it does the ceiling function for
negative values because it rounds down
and rounds up respectively for positive
and negative values so now let's look at
the next set of arithmetic functions
um let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parentheses I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value fifteen one fifty one
thousand two hundred similarly there is
a combination function and this is a
combinations of permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you are going
to move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in machine learning AI
you will be using these functions quite
a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the LCM of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or uh if you have python 3.9
or after that you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic uh functions let's move
on to the next section which are power
and logarithmetic logarithmic functions
so let's start off with the power
function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you can actually do a power
function in math in Python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the pow or the power
function which is this is how you do it
and if I had to do same 2 to the power 3
I would just pass 2 and 3 has arguments
like this and it should give me the
value as you can see 8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the base
python use this as well and you can do
the same thing pow 2 and 3 should give
you the value 8 again the you know you
might ask what's the difference between
these two functions well it's not much
for at least in a beginner standpoint
it's not that much uh just note that the
maths dot power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on their
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if I did
exponential of 3 this would give me e to
the power 3. so as you can see oh of
course I did not Define the module
beforehand so math.exp now when I do
this it should it will give me some
value which is basically Euler's number
or e to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of d k and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh let's write down remaining let's
assign this to a variable remaining so
the initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated it it's
something uh so this is it's basically
what this tells me is that I started off
with 100 units of some radioactive
element
um and in 10 years this is what is left
so yeah so this is how we would use say
the uh X exponential functions in a
particular example of ours so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of these algorithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in between this I would pass the
number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case it gives me some value what
if I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass a second argument in
this case I want to find the log of a to
the base 2 this should be the value 3 as
you can see over here there are two
specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2. as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is
maths dot sqrt again we pass the what we
want over here if we want the square
root of say 49 this should give me the
value 7 as you can see finally we move
on to the final set of functions that we
can do using this math module they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions
um the way we would do it is math DOT
sign in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of paper particular
angle and this angle must be passed in
radians and this is very important to
note we do not pass it in degrees but in
radians so if I say past sine of 3.14 as
we know 3.14 is an approximation of the
value by
sine Phi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be 0 so let's see we get
something close to zero again since this
is an approximation it won't give us the
exact value similarly we can use math
dot cos to find the value of a
particular angle if you want to find
yeah if you want to find the value of
the sorry the COS of a particular angle
we can use the tan function in case we
wanted to find the tan similarly we have
the next set for arc sine and the
arcosines of the certain of angles so to
use to find the arc sign for example we
would use a DOT sign I mean sorry a sign
for R cosine we would use this and for r
10 we would use this the next set would
be hyperbolic functions again hyperbolic
functions are basically the sine and the
cosine and the time calculated not
circles but on hyperbolas again the
details don't have to be you don't have
to know the details you just should you
should know that if you wanted to say
for example find out the hyperbolic sign
of an a of an angle we would use math
dot sine H and we would pass what we
wanted between this similarly if we
wanted to find the cosine it would be
coset tan it would be tan H and if we
wanted to find the inverse of the
hyperbolic inverse we what we would do
is what we would do is use a so we would
use a tan H if you wanted to find the
hyperbolic inverse of sine we would use
a sine H and similarly for cos it would
be cos a COS H in this video we will
learn about conditional statements and
we will learn about how do we create
these control structures where we have
these conditional statements we will
learn about the keywords if we use in
Python to create a conditional statement
block the if keyword the alif keyword
and the else keyword we will also learn
about indentation and its importance in
Python so let's get started so the basic
uh syntax if you will for a if statement
in Python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression uh there
is this a block of code which if you can
actually see is slightly indented to the
rest of the code and then we have the
rest of the rest of our code after that
so what we're looking at is this so this
is our if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we are
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking talking about
the if statement we have an expression
and if this expression evaluates to true
then we execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if this statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30 so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context if this is true then we can move
on to the next portion which is this but
if it is false then we will skip this so
let's see what this uh what happens over
here so since we know that 50 is indeed
greater than 30 this is a true
expression we move on to this block of
code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30 thing so
let's see if this actually gets printed
so as you can see we get this uh the
result which is this is a true statement
and we get our print statement getting
executed what if we give a false
expression over here so let's look at uh
what happens if I gave a false
expression now I'm checking if 50 is
lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed in fact my print statement is
just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so so as you
can see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining a what a
control control structure is uh in
detail control structures consists of
these uh conditionals or Loops or
iterations if you will uh so all of
these control structures involve heavy
indentation so what does an indentation
mean well what if I gave you an example
say I gave you some variable called H
and I wrote 20 over here now if I give
you an if statement saying if age is
greater than 10 now it's very important
to note that when I'm defining an if
statement I need this colon otherwise
this if statement is not defined so this
colon is important uh anyways so now I'm
checking this expression if age is
greater than 10. now what is this what
happens if H is greater than 10 now what
if I want python to do something only if
age is greater than 10 well how do I
tell python that there is a piece of
code or a section of code that I want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if I want say if I want
this line this person is an adult again
this is some random line where I'm
assuming age is pertaining to this adult
all right or this person so if I have uh
this variable age where I write this
number 20 which denotes the age of some
person and I'm doing a check if age is
greater than 10 actually let's be
specific here well the adult age for
most people is 18 in most countries so
let's see if age is greater than 18. now
if I'm doing this check I want to print
this statement only if this person is a
person's age is above 20 above 18 so how
do I tell python that I only want this
statement to be executed only during
this if this condition is met well this
is where indentation comes into play and
as you can see exactly as you can see
this part this post version of the code
is slightly indented compared to the if
statement so when this condition is met
then only do we move on to this if this
condition is not met we move on to
whatever the next section of code will
be like whatever whatever code that we
have after this if statement so let's
see so this since this condition is
actually met as you can see this print
statement is actually executed so this
is the importance of indentation now we
will see uh in as we move as we learn
more about if statements and else
statements and Alice statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
program me so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on an indentation the general consensus
is that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one of the facets
of Python Programming is the indentation
and the easy readability of it anyways
moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integers 50 I have two strings cat
and apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is in X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if so we use the L
if keyword so it so what this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our block to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is only we only Reach
This LL statement in case all of the
earlier conditions have not been met or
have come to be false and not true so
let's look at this particular code an
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and I'm my first X expression that
I'm checking is is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 elix list X well actually no
we don't have the object 60 so this part
is not executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in X well
actually it is uh the string cat is
indeed in X so we move on to this
statement block which is within the
condition that is met which is print cat
is in list X and you will see that none
of the other statement blocks will be
executed because we have met our
condition over here so if I execute this
as you can see that the print statement
cat is in list X is what is actually
executed and we do not execute this
obviously because it is false and we do
not even check or we do not even move on
to the statement because well we have a
condition mat over here so it's a one
thing that is important to note is that
we can use as many alif statements to
check for as many conditions that we we
want to check for but it's very
important that we only use and if we are
using where we only use one else
statement and only at the end of our
block okay so moving on now I'm going to
show you a very neat example about how
python actually does its uh these
condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so
um we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that I have over here is where I've
stored the string cat in X now I have
three uh I have three conditions that
I'm checking I'm checking is 50 greater
than 60. I am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and I'm checking I'm some
random expression 1 divided by zero this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is 2
false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by 0 that is an error
error statement so let's see what
happens when I do this actually as you
can see I have a statement being printed
but I have no error even though I gave
it wrong I gave an error statement in 1
divided by zero well now you might ask
why is that so well it's simply because
I have actually never reached this
condition I have not even python is not
bothered looking at this because if you
actually see there is a condition
previous to this over here which is met
and which is true so we move on to this
block we execute this block and we
forget about the rest of the code so we
don't actually get to this error
statement which is an interesting thing
and which is an example that I have
shown uh to show you that once a
condition is met in an if statement
block we do not look at any of the
further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally I
um I have one uh one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the Python's
deternary uh operator now this is
slightly different to the if statement
that we have talked about up until now
uh in the sense that it is not a control
structure so what this actually is is
more of an operator that defines some
expression so let's see what I am trying
to say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the Syntax for what
I'm trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26 now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
then an indentation within that if
statement and then
um I could have written else and then
another indentation and I would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that I have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable X and this uh what value
I'm assigning to X depends on if this
condition is true or false so as you can
see the condition says is age 18 uh
greater than 18. so if this is true then
I assign this particular string if it is
false then I go on to the else statement
and I assign this so since age is 26 is
greater than 18 I should assign the
string adult to X and as you can see if
I execute this and check what is an X
you can see adult is indeed in X so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um it's a it's probably a
more it's it's a better looking way to
perform simple else uh Sim simple if and
else statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if if Cell
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we Let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the pass statement or the pass
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true
um but I don't know what to do if this
statement was true how do I tell python
well let's just keep it a hold for now
and I might put something into this
block later in the future well I would
use the pass statement so if I had this
say this some condition again so I'm
checking age is greater than 18 but I
don't know what to do with this I would
just simply use this past statement and
this basically does nothing uh it it's a
way to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future I
might have I might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently I don't have
anything to place over here so I just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is a way where you can use a pass
statement in if and as statement or if
Finance control structures in this video
we will be I will introduce you to the
concept of iterations in Python and we
will be speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in Python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
uh executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
indefinite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
the psych NFL statements uh a set of
statements where um what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true we uh execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is indented below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like if NS hidden
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0. so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this while keyword as
you can see followed by a an expression
n lesser than or equal to 5. now what
this is is an expression which is going
to check if it's true or false is n less
than or equal to 5 and as long as this
expression is true we will continue
doing whatever is indented below this y
statement and what is below this y
statement is a print statement first of
all which says value of n is and it
basically prints a value of n in that
particular iteration and as you can see
this uh compound assignment where we add
the value of n by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does important to
note the value of n again is initialized
at 0. so this while loop will keep going
on until the value of n remains lesser
than or equal to 5. so as you can see I
have the execution of this a particular
block of code or this while loop where I
get the multiple different iterations of
this print statement that you can see
here the first iteration it says value
of n is zero then it's the value of n is
one what I'm doing is I am writing I am
assigned I'm writing uh the value of n
multiple times uh and each time the
value of n is written over here based on
what iteration it is so what is
happening actually is uh the initially
value of n is 0 and I print the
statement value of n is 0. now I add the
value of what is In N by 1 so now what
is the value of n so again we do this
check so after this first iteration we
come back or like once this whole block
of code is executed we again come back
to this expression and we again check if
the statement is true so now that the
value of n is actually 1 if this
statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is 1. now again we add
the value of n by 1 and again we go back
here once this uh this block is executed
and we check if this statement is true
again and as you can see the value of n
when it's 2 is still making sure that
this expression is true and this keeps
happening until the value of n is
greater than 5. so once the value of n
becomes 6 this condition is no longer
met and finally we do not execute the
statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
loop so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use iterables and an example of
an iterable is the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block all right so I created this list a
which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable X where I
store the integer one now I'm this while
statement now it might look confusing
now it's it says it says while a now
what is a well a is not uh your typical
expression where you're making sure if
some condition is being met or not but
this the way you read this is while a
exists so in the context of a list as
long as a which is a list contains
objects within it a is true if it does
not have any objects within it a is
false so while a basically what it means
is while a has objects within it and if
it does have objects where within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this y
statement and this why statement is a
print statement again we do like we we
have this value X where we um we're
doing this this we're printing this is
iteration number and uh we pass X so the
first iteration obviously pass X is
equal to 1 and then we add X by 1 and
then the second iteration should pass
this is iteration number two and then so
on and finally we have another statement
within this block called the a called
the pop statement where we're popping
the elements of a now as if you would
have seen the list the video on list the
pop statement removes the rightmost
value uh from a list so if I do a DOT
pop initially it will remove 5 from this
list and I will have the rest of them
again if I do pop it will remove four
from this list then you will have the
rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so I'll also print the list a it's uh
it's during each iteration let's see
what happens over here as you can see
what is happening out here is while a or
while a has elements we are going to
continue doing this y statement whatever
is within it so in the first iteration
obviously we have all of it uh and it is
iteration number one and as you can see
the list contains everything then I pop
it then iteration number two it again
has elements but it has lost its most
rightmost element and this keeps on
happening until the list finally has no
elements left and once the element or
invents a list has no elements left we
this expression while a evaluates to
false and we do not execute this anymore
and we leave the while low and again
let's check what is in a a should have
no elements as you can see it's an empty
list when I check what's in a is an
empty list and that is why while a
return near false and we did not print
any further so this is an example of
using a wire statement using lists and
of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
Loops we can have while Loops within if
and L statements and we can have FNL
statements within FNL statements so if
you think of all of these loops and we
will even speak about for Loops in the
in the in in another video for Loops
again a type of control structure so all
of these are control structures while
Loops or control structures for Loops or
control structures if and as statements
are control structures all of these are
control structures and nesting can
happen within them and it does not
matter uh which is the like the parent
of the nest and then the child or the
nest we can have a while loop within an
ifnl statement you can have for Loops
within a while loop all of this is valid
in Python and uh it's one of the one of
the great features of python that is
very flexible in this way so let's look
at an example where I have a while loop
within another while loop so I am
copying this piece of code where I have
this list one two three four five and
another list first and second now my
first while loop I print I print what is
pop from a so I take a then I pop the
zeroth index so basically from the left
hand side and I print what is that all
right and then I have another while loop
where I have this list B and I'm doing
the same thing but this while loop is
within the first while loop and let's
see what happens out here so as you can
see my first uh my first iteration of
this parent while loop causes me to pop
what is the first element which is one
then I do these while loops and this is
completely executed and only then do I
go back to this first one and then I
come back and do all of this again then
I go back to this one and then I come
back into all of this again and that's
why you can see this repetition so I
have this first iteration and then I do
uh the second while loop then I have the
second iteration and then I do the
second while loop and I keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next Topic in this
second this video would be break and
continue statements now break in
continue statements are ways to abruptly
end iterations uh in in a particular
Loop now you can use break and continue
statements not only in while loop where
you can use it and also in for Loops so
let's look at how we use it in while
loops and let's look at what we mean by
breaking continuous statements first of
all well the break statement terminates
the loop entirely so once the break
statement is found the the complete
while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continue
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current Loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the or the controlling
expression is again re-evaluated and it
is checked whether the loop will execute
again or terminate this pictorial that
you can see here actually emphasizes or
it shows the difference between break
and continue so I have this while loop
and I have an expression all right I
have a bunch of statements and I have a
break command over here and I have a
continue command over here so if I
encounter the break command it will not
execute any of this in fact it will not
execute this wire statement at all and
it will move on to the next piece of
code that we have but a continuous
statement if a continuous statement is
encountered in a while loop will not
completely break away but it will not uh
it will not execute the the rest of the
statements in that iteration only these
two but it will go back here it will
check this expression again and again we
will do this all over again so this is
this small uh difference between the
break and continue statements but both
are used to abruptly end an iteration in
a loop so let's look at an example of
how we use the break statement so I will
use this example where I have again I
have initialized some controlling
variable n to 0 my first Loop will check
whether n is less than equal to 5 if
this is true then I will print this
statement then I will what I'm doing
over here is I am incrementing it by one
now in my previous my earlier example
using a similar uh using the similar
example I had no like this this part was
not there so what you got was I was
printing the value of n so it was
printing as like value of n is 1 I mean
0 and then one and then 2 and then three
four and five but over here I've
included a small I've nested an if
statement and within that I put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 I move on to this and I
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once so when
I have executed this I don't get the
whole value of n is 0 and then one and
then two three four five I I stop at one
and that is because once n is equal to 2
I actually do not execute this while
loop again I do not go back and execute
print value of n is 2 now in fact I
break from this whole while group and my
while loop terminal is right then and
there and that's why you only get these
two iterations value of n is zero and
then value of n is one okay so now I'm
going to show you a neat example of what
happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but I have added one more statement
where I print hello at each iteration so
let's see what happens when I do this as
you can see it will print hello after
each of whatever I was doing already now
let's introduce our break statement
first of all so when I do break well
let's go back to this if statement if is
if we check this condition then we break
let's see what happens now as you can
see something interesting has happened
where we have this first iteration
completely being executed but the second
iteration kind of stops where there's no
hello and that is because we have broken
from this while loop before the second
iterations hello was printed let's see
the difference between a break and
continue now so now I have this
continuous statement and instead of a
break let's see what happens here as you
can see it seems familiar to our first
example where we do not have any break
or continue but there is a small
difference that I want you to catch and
that is very important about this
continue uh statement so as you can see
the first iteration has value of n is 0
and then hello and value of n is 1 but
there is no hello and this is because
this is because once this condition is
actually met we do not move on to this
statement but we go back to this
expression and we will evaluate this
expression and then once we evaluate
this expression again and it's found to
be correct we do everything the same
again when we print hello but except for
that one step where this if statement
was met and we did continue and this
following statement was not executed and
that happens only for one iteration and
that is when n is equal to equal to 2
and as you can see that is what happens
over here in one of the iterations we
may say hello and that is the difference
of the continue statement between uh
there is a difference of the continuous
statement with the break statement this
video will be an extension into that
topic where we will be looking at three
examples where we are using while Loops
along with other stuff like say if and
else statements so our first example
will be where we calculate the factorial
of a number in this example as you can
see here we are first going to ask the
user to enter a particular number for us
now this number is supposed to be an
integer once we have this integer we
store it to a variable called number now
we have this you can say this variable
called fac which stores 1 and you we
will see how we are using it later now
we know that the factorial of 0 is 1
that's how it's just defined so we have
an if statement checking whether our
entered number is 0 and if it is 0 we
say that the result is 1 or the
factorial is one however if we enter a
number that is greater than 0 we must
calculate the factor oil for this number
and that is what we are going to do in
this else statement block over here now
in this else statement block we have a
while loop in this while loop the
condition is checking while number is
greater than or equal to 1. so as long
as this condition is true everything
within that while loop will be executed
so as long as number is greater than
equal to 1 we are going to execute these
two lines now what do these two lines do
let us see so the first line takes the
variable fac where we had the number one
stored and we are going to store FEC
times number into it number being the
number that we have inputted so in case
for example we start we entered 8 then
what this will do this line will do is 1
into 8 and it will store that back into
fac now once that is done we move on to
the next line where we are decrementing
the number variable by one so if we have
stored 8 or we have entered 8 into our
input it will become 7. now as we know 7
is still greater than or equal to 1 so
this condition is still being met and
then we do this process again where we
are going to multiply fac this time fac
stores the value 8 and we multiply it
times the new number which is 7 now so
we do 8 into 7 and then again we
decrement this uh also once we do 8 into
7 we store it back into fac and we keep
doing this where we keep multiplying 8
times 7 and then we decrement the number
variable uh by one and then we check
this condition again so what ends up
happening is we are going to keep doing
8 into 7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3
into 2 into 1 and once we are at 1 again
when we do this document operation the
number variable we store the value of 0
and then this condition will no longer
be met so number will be 0 and this
condition will be false and we can move
out of this while low then finally we
store the result into a variable called
result which stores the result of 8 into
7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2
into 1 this is of course if we did enter
8 when we were asked to give an input so
let's see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about eight all right now that
I have entered 8 as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
8 is 4 0 3 2 0 which is correct and you
can check this for yourself where it
will show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many Fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user it
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an INT into a variable count
now in this if a statement the first if
statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
FIB next if our entered integer is 1 we
just store the value 1 in this array
called FIB if our enter number is 2 we
store 1 and 1 in the array FIB all of
these are different sets of Fibonacci
sequences this obviously an empty an
empty array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is 2 we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now the actual calculations happen when
we say we want a Fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the FIB
variable with the first two Fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we're going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable I which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we're
going to check whether that is lesser
than count minus 1 count being the
number that we have been asked to input
if the statement is true and as long as
the statement is true we will be
executing this statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the array FIB now what this
expression is is basically it's going to
keep adding so each subsequent numbers
and we are going to store each
subsequent numbers back into the array
Fib so in this case if you see the
fourth the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first portion of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the 0th position of the array
fib and both of these values since they
are 1 and 1 when we add them we get 2
and we append that to Fib so now our FIB
will look like 1 comma 1 comma two then
we increment this by 1 and what we do is
we do the same process again so in the
next step what will be what we would do
is we would do 2 plus 1 so we would get
three now this would keep going on until
this condition is met or basically until
uh the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many Fibonacci numbers I
would like to generate and I will say I
want the first let's say six Fibonacci
numbers so I execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is 1 and 1 and then 2
which is basically one plus one and then
three which is 1 plus 2 and then 5 which
is 2 plus 3 8 which is three plus five
so if we wanted more numbers we would
just enter over here like say if you
wanted the first 10 numbers it would
give us the first 10 numbers in the
sequence as you can see here now in our
next example what we are going to do is
we are going to write a program which
takes two digits that represent the
dimensions of an array so for example if
we want a three by three array we will
enter three comma 3 and we are going to
generate a two dimensional array in
which each of the elements of the array
are basically the row times the column
position of that particular element and
what I mean by this is say we have a
position I comma J on the array the
value of the element at that position
would be I times J so for example if I'm
looking at something at the third row
and the fifth column or say the third
row and the third column for example the
value of the element would be 3 times 3
and if I'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column I am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using Code
so if you look to the right over here I
have a piece of code where I'm going to
uh in where it asks me to input two
numbers two integers to represent the
dimensions of my uh example my sample
array now once we have done this we are
going to store these um these dimensions
in the inputs in in a variable called
input string so obviously when we enter
say 5 comma 5 that will be stored as an
INT in this particular string or this
variable what we want is we want five
say we entered five comma five we want
five as a separate integer and the other
five as another separate integer and
that is what we do in this particular
statement where we're going to split up
our input string based on the comma
separator and we're going to store the
first part of that string into the zero
width position of Dimensions which is an
array and the next dimension in the
first position in this particular array
now we are going to store the number of
rows as row number and that is the
zeroth position of this array and we're
going to store the equal number of
columns as the first position of
Dimensions or whatever we've mentioned
in the input so now we we have this our
results array called multi list which is
basically what what our final array is
going to look like and we are going to
store into multi-list and in this
example we will be using for Loops to do
this or to create this particular array
so as you can see here our first uh we
have initialized our multi list saying
that um we're going to have only zeros
in our sample array so initial really
once we have initialized this array all
multi lists will contain is a say for
example we have inputted a five by five
array it will have basically a 5x5 array
with all elements as zero and that's
what this line does once we have done
this we are going to move on to the for
Loop portion where we are actually going
to create our array that we want so as
you can see we are our first for Loop is
going to say four row in range row
number so obviously a range will
generate a an iterator which can be
iterated over and since it says range
row number and say our the number of
rows that we entered were five what it's
going to do is it's going to create an
iterator containing the value 0 1 2 3
and 4. so for row and range it will
basically basically row will take the
value 0 1 2 3 and 4. and a similar thing
is going to happen in this nested for
Loop which is within this where we're
going to again uh create a an iterator
using this range function and for the
column number once we have this we're
going to do the simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we're going to
store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for Loops we are going to first go
by each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now I'm going to say
I want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 Matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when I give this as uh so what I'm
saying is I want two rows and four
columns now as you can see here it might
not be very clear to you right now but
what you can see here is this is the
first row and this is the second row and
each row contains four columns so these
are the this is the my final array that
I get so what you can see here is this
is the zeroth position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row First
Column first row second column and since
python is zero based so this is actually
the zeroth row and this is the first row
so as you can see uh this this value
basically is zero times one this value
is zero times two zero times three zero
times four and over here it is one time
zero one times one one times two one
times three so similarly if I did for
example a five by five Matrix what you
will get is five rows now five rows and
five columns and for example like this
particular value is uh one two three or
zero one two three so zero one two three
and the First Column so this is three
times one
um if I took this value this is like the
fourth row for example fourth row times
the um zero one two three third column
so this would be four times three which
is twelve so and each value of this has
been generated in the similar process so
this is an example of how we can use for
Loops
um for a particular exercise that I have
shown you right now in this video we
will be covering the topic of definite
iterations using for Loops in Python so
starting off we know that there are two
types of iterations in programming a
definite and indefinite we have already
covered indefinite iterations in the
form of while Loops definite iterations
on the other hand are done using the
keyword for and the basic syntax or the
standard Syntax for a basic for Loop in
Python is as you can see over here we
have this four keyword we have some
variable we have the in keyword and we
have this iterable and we of course
Define this control structure with the
colon and then indented we have this
statement block so once this for Loop
has started we execute all of these
statements within the statement block as
part of the for Loop iteration so yeah
let's uh now let's to understand like
how for loops work uh exactly let's look
at the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a stepwise manner all right so
we in Python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some object that
uh it's it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects we can create an iterator out
of it uh how do we do that is we use the
iter function so for example if I passed
this list a if I pass this list a
through the iter function and I store it
in some variable iter underscore a and I
see what is item underscore a it is
actually a list iterator at some random
memory location which we don't really
care about similarly if I gave a tuple
and I did the same thing I will create a
tuple iterator and in the left if you
can see over here I've done the exact
same functions with sets and
dictionaries as well so I'm creating
iterators out of these iterables so as
to speak uh now what is an iterator well
an iterator is an object that yields
values successively so if my list
contained five values or five objects an
iterator of this list will yield these
values one after the other and that is
kind of how or that is the basis for
which we do we create Loops let's see
what we exactly mean using this uh using
another function that we call the next
function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since I've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see I've created this list
iterator item underscore a now with this
item underscore a what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
I will keep yielding or keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when I do next iter when I do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when I do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if I did it again it gives me third now
if I kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now I get fourth now I get
fifth now a natural question is now that
I've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if I perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens I get a uh an error or and this
error is the stop iteration function
error which basically is telling me look
you have exhausted all of the objects
that were initially present in this list
a and you cannot you cannot keep doing
the next next function anymore you
cannot keep going further so yeah so
this is what the next function does when
it comes to the concept of iterators all
right so now we've learned two things
what is an iterator and what is the how
do we create an iterator out of
different collections of objects like a
list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
uh move or let's come back to our for
Loop that we started off this video with
so our for loop again let's consider our
for Loop over here
as you can see some for loop with the
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now I'm
going to do for X in a print X and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when I have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so I have first of all let's look
at this for loop I in this for loop I
Define a new variable X and then I say
for X in a print X and what's happening
well in each iteration I am printing
whatever the value of x is at present so
in the first iteration it is the first
object one in the second iteration it is
the second object two then three four
five and then finally uh on its own like
uh this for Loop knows that okay now
once I have exhausted all of the objects
within my iterator I can stop doing this
for Loop and I can move on with the rest
of the code all right so think of it
like a three-step process a for Loop in
Python the first step is it calls an
iter function to obtain an iterator for
whatever we pass over here this iterable
second step it calls the next function
repeatedly in each iteration all right
to keep getting the next item from the
iterator so it gets one then it calls
next then it gets two then it calls next
and it gets three and then four and then
five and so on and then finally the
third step is the termination step is
when after we do the final next where we
get this error as you can see the stop
iteration error or exception finally
this tells the for Loop function or the
for Loop that okay we have reached the
end of our definite iteration or the end
of our definite for Loop and this is
where we must terminate our Loop and
then continue with the rest of the code
all right so this is how a for Loop
Works in Python now it's very important
to note that whatever we have discussed
when it came to while Loops such as
nesting of while loops and nesting of
other control structures is also
applicable in the case of for Loops so
if I had a for loop with in another for
Loop that is perfectly fine if I had a
while within a for Loop that is
perfectly fine so all of these are valid
statement blocks that we can do and
again for Loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of indentation when it comes to
writing our statement blocks within a
for Loop okay so now I'm going to speak
about in specific I'm going to speak
about the this something called the
range function that is uh quite you
could say it's used definitely it's used
in other areas of programming but it's
widely used in Python uh I mean I mean
the for Loop in Python uh what I mean by
this is that um Range this range
function is very important for the for
Loop and we will see why okay so let's
look at one of the examples of using the
range function so what does the range
function do is if I give range 5 let's
see what it does it gives me range 0 to
5. what this basically tells me is that
this will create an iterator that
contains uh integers from 0 to 5 so it
will contain the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5
and we can use this as an iterator so
let's let's look at this uh I have Range
Five let's store this in X okay now
let's do a type just to see what happens
when we do Type X it should give me the
type of range as you can see and this is
a type of an iterator in Python now
let's see what happens when I do for I
in X print I okay let's see what happens
as you can see it prints the number 0 1
2 3 4. an important caveat when it comes
to the range function is when we say
range 5 it creates an iterator from 0 to
5 but it contains the objects 0 1 2 3
and 4 only it does not contain the
object 5 itself okay this is something
that is very important to so once again
I created I use this range function to
create an iterator from if iterator 5
objects from 0 to 4 0 1 2 3 and 4. I use
that in my for Loop and that's what that
is what you are seeing here now let's
use this range function in the context
of something else for example let's see
so I had my earlier list a right look at
my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like I can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for Loop is used is widely used in
Python Programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and AI I cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of for Loop
expression so you have four let's say I
in range Len a let's see what's going on
here first I create first I do length of
a that gives me 5 then into range of 5
that creates an iterator between 0 and 4
right when you do Range Five it gives
you an iterator of zero one two three
and four as we saw earlier and this is
what we're doing over here we have
created an iterator out of the length of
a list now when I do print I it should
give me again one two three four zero
one two three four of course so as you
can see here it will give me zero one
two three four and this is a very neat
way of using the range function on top
of the length of a particular collection
of objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so I I would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course
um there are the you can use break and
continue statements as you have in the
case of while Loops uh exactly this it
works exactly the same in the case of
for Loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for Loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
breaking continue statements in for
Loops finally I would like to show you
something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or or as an
iterable when it comes to for Loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so I created this
dictionary a all right so I have
dictionary a uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass it through the iter
function as you can see and now I'm
going to just for the sake of showing
you it will show I'll show you that it
is actually an iterator of type of a
specific Direct Key iterator type all
right so now let's uh let's do something
on this so as you can see in the
dictionary I have the key first that has
the value one I have the key second that
has the value 2 I have the key third
that has a value three and then fourth
for four fifth for five now a good
question would be when I do iteration or
when I do a for loop on top of this a
well what is it going to pick up is it
going to pick up first uh is it going to
pick up the keys like these or is it
going to pick up the values or is it
going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value uh let's see what actually happens
let's do 4 I in iter underscore a print
I let's see what what is The iterations
Happening upon using this so as you can
see we're using the keys so by default
when we do this when we perform when we
create an iterator out of a dictionary
we use only the keys as our iterator
elements or at iterator values but of
course like if you wanted to use values
all you would have to do is pass a DOT
values over here and if you remember
from a dictionary video this uh a DOT
values gives us a list of or it it gives
us the essentially a list of the values
in our dictionary so when we pass this
to the iterator uh iter function and we
create an iterator out of it let's see
what happens over here now let's see
what is ETA underscore a you can
actually see it's now the dict value
iterator at a particular memory location
in so it's not the Dig key as we saw
earlier it's a direct value iterator so
now that we have this by dictionary
value iterator now let's print what are
our iterator elements and as you can see
now we are printing values and not the
keys so this is how to this this is
basically two different ways of
iterating through a dictionary one
through keys and one through values in
this video we will be doing a small
exercise on if statements now in the
previous video you might have already
seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we are checking if a
variable X is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement as we
move to the statement log now our
variable X has the value 5. now since X
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something where we are checking multiple
statements we use the L if statement in
such a case so now in this block we are
checking in one of the one of the
conditions we're checking is if x is
equal to 5 or if x is greater than 5 and
then finally if both of these conditions
are not met we say else and we print
whatever or we do whatever is in this
particular statement block which is a
simple print statement so as you can see
X is indeed get is equal to 5 so this is
the block that will get executed as you
can see here now another example our
nestative statements so nested FL
statements are if else statements within
if else statements so let's look at an
example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh now we
have an integer or a float in this case
4.0 stored in Orange price now our first
statement is checking whether orange
quality the variable orange quality is
it equal to the string fresh now within
that if the statement or if this
condition is met we do another check
whereby checking what is the price is it
lesser than 5 if it is V to this block
else we execute this block finally if
our initial statement our initial
condition is not met we move on to this
else block now when I execute this what
should happen is I will enter this block
because this is true and finally I will
enter this block because this condition
is also true so I should have this
printed I will buy five dozens as you
can see here now let's move on to our
main exercise for this video so this was
all just the revision now we're going to
use some or all of these Concepts in a
sample project or a sample exercise to
for your further practice so in this
exercise what we're going to do is we're
going to request the user to enter a
number between 1 and 20 and our our code
is going to check whether this number
entered is an even number or an odd
number so as you can see there are two
sets of checks that we're going to do in
this code the first check is going to be
whether the number that is entered is
between 1 and 20 or not and if it is not
we have to say it's an invalid number
but if it is entered between 1 and 20 we
have to move on to the further checks
which is whether it is an even or an odd
number so let's see how we do that so in
this piece of code what we start with is
a print statement saying please enter a
number between 1 and 20 and then we add
an input command this input command will
open a box where we can enter whatever
number that we want to enter now we use
this int keyword to make sure that
whatever we have entered into the input
box is stored as a int data type in the
enter num variable once we do that our
first if statement is going to check
whether the entered number is greater
than or equal to 1 or less than equal to
20. sorry and less than equal to 20. so
both of these conditions have to be met
if this condition is true then we have a
valid input and this statement is
printed that we have entered a valid
number and then we move on to the rest
of the statement block within this if
statement which is another set of if and
else if statements if our number is not
between 120 we move to this block and
this block prints that we have entered
in invalid number now once we have say
entered a valid number we move on to
this block this is an if else if alif
statement block now what this block is
checking is whether the entered number
is an even number or not now as we know
an even number is divisible by 2 only
the remainder 0 when divided by 2. so
this is what this check is doing if this
check is true that means our number is
even and we get printed that our number
is even the other other check or the
other uh if statement is checking
whether it's an odd number and that
means when we divide by 2 we should get
the remainder 1 as you can see here and
we get printed your number is odd so
let's execute this and see what happens
when we enter a number now it's asking
me to enter a number let's say I enter
17.
now that I've entered 17 as you can see
it's a valid number that I have entered
and the code is telling me that my
number is indeed odd let's look at some
other what if I entered something else
here let's say if I enter 16 now since
it's an even number as you can see 16 is
also a valid number as it's between 1
and 20 and my number is even and the
code checks for that let's see if I what
happens when I enter an invalid number
let's say 25 an hour into 25 as you can
see it says I have entered invalid
number and in this case what has
happened is this condition itself is not
met and I have moved on to this
statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when I enter nine
the first check that happens of course
is this check whether it's a valid
number or not and since it is between 1
and 20 we move on to this block and in
this block it's checking whether our
numbers divisible by 2 or not and since
it is not it will remain it will leave a
remainder 1 and we execute this block it
says our print our number is Odd as you
can see here in this video we are going
to learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we are handling large and different
types of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image Files video files Etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like XML
CSS HTML files and so on now there are
four main operations that we can do 2 on
file in Python on files they are open
read write and close
um there are certain other operations as
well though like rename delete so some
of the most basic operation that we can
do is obviously creating and opening a
file and the syntax is as you can see
here where we store where we use the
open command and we give a file name and
we give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write-only mode which is done by letter
W and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by R plus and we're going to see
them as we encounter them now the it is
important to note that what I just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do for binary files we are
going to do this file handling then we
would be using the letter B in front of
whatever we were using in the case of
text files so if we were doing a
read-only mode for opening a binary file
um we would be using RV and if we were
doing read and write mode a read or
write only mode for a binary file we
would be using RB plus so basically just
adding the b in the case of binary files
let's look at a basic example when we
want to open a particular file we are
going to open like in this example I'm
going to open some file called
firehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and I'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if I wanted to do it
for the binary file since I'm using a
binary file I will use the letter B as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
optional number of characters we can use
the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters denoted by n over here
um and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of where I'm
going to print something called so I'm
going to take this and I'm going to do a
print on top of this so I have done
first I've opened it and I've stored it
in my file and then I'm going to do a uh
a method or a function called read and
I'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that I have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if I wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when I do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off you know from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how python handles files so if
I wanted to again take the cursor back
in such an example I will have to open
this again and then I use this read
command once again to get back to where
I started from as you can see here now
another command that we can use is the
read line command so let's uh once again
open this over here and now we're going
to use the read line command and over
here so what readline command is going
to do is going to each time we use this
command it's going to go one by one and
read each particular line from this file
so in first case it will take artificial
intelligence then data science big data
and so on so as you can see if I execute
this it first takes artificial
intelligence now if I did this command
again
it will say data science next time if I
do it it should say big data as you can
see here okay so this is the read line
command now within the redline command
also we can enter uh characters and that
will tell us basically
um that we want these number of
characters from the next line so if I
want the first six characters of the
next line uh I will say six I've learned
to six here and it will give me the
first six characters of this particular
line which is the next line that is to
come as you can see here now another way
in which we can print whatever is there
in our file line by line is by using a
for Loop so again I'm going to open this
file I'm going to store it here now I'm
going to use a for Loop saying that well
uh for a line in my file and what this
does is basically at each each iteration
it's going to take each line and store
it in this variable that we enter over
here which is called line itself and
we're going to print that at the end of
the loop what we'll have is all of the
lines have been printed one by one and
another thing that we can do right now
is um save we want to read a a
particular line see I wanted you to read
the fifth line of my file I can use this
technique where um I just say okay I'm
going to store 5 in this variable called
line number and I have this another
variable called current line which I'm
going to initialize with one and I'm
gonna any I'm gonna what I'm going to do
is I'm going to do the same Loop where
I'm going to say four line in my line
but I'm gonna add a condition saying
that only if current line when it's
equal to line number am I going to print
the line and then I'm going to break out
of this whole thing and at the end of
each Loop I'm going to say current line
is going to be incremented by one until
basically these two variables are equal
so when I do this I get my result which
is uh machine learning which is the
fifth line of um my which is the fifth
line of whatever file I had now we're
gonna move on to the topic of image file
handling so we we saw how we handled and
we we saw certain operations around text
files and text files are obviously
something that we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's look at
certain examples and certain use cases
around image file handling so my first
step is going to be importing a bunch of
modules and packages now the details of
these modules and these packages are not
important as of right now because they
will be covered in a future video but
just keep a note of some of these
packages such as um they say numpy and
image the image package so once I've
done this let's move on to my example so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
store certain file locations in two
variables so it's basically two strings
I've attached the uh this prefix R to
say that this is a read-only uh sort of
a prefix so the next topic that we're
going to be handling is image file
handling now we have already seen many
examples pertaining to text files so
text files are obviously something that
we're going to be using a lot but image
file handling is something very
important as well and we're going to see
certain operations that we can do around
image file handling so starting off I'm
going to import a bunch of packages and
modules uh what these packages exactly
are and what these modules exactly are
are right now not of that important of
not are not that important to you right
now but it's something that will be
covered in a future or in future videos
uh it's important to just keep note of
what these are such as numpy and image
so once I've done that what I'm going to
store is I'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and I've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once I've done
that I am going to use the image from
the image package I'm going to say open
and I'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and I'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file file
opening now once we've done this we can
access certain properties of this image
using say format which tells us the
format of the file it attributes the it
identifies the source of an image and if
the image will not read from a file it
is set to none we can also see the size
of the file using the size attribute and
we can see the mode which basically
defines the number and names of the
bands in the image and also contains a
pixel type and depth certain common
modes are like L for luminescence RGB
for true color images and CMYK for
pre-press images so let's look at them
so when I access this you can see my
first file is of jpeg of this size and
an RGB format image and my second image
is another jpeg slightly bigger image
and again RGB now we can also of course
display these images and to do that we
can use the PLT again PLT is the is
supposed to stand for matplotlib DOT Pi
plot it's a particular for a particular
package that again you don't need to
know the details of right now but this
is how we would do this so I'm going to
use a bunch of commands and methods such
as figure and subplot and then I am sure
so once I have done this as you can see
both of my images with this being im1
this being im2 have been produced on the
screen as you can see I can also use
display this display function followed
by the name of the file and this will
simply display my image as you can see
here now I can obviously save a
particular image using the save function
which is as simple as just doing this so
I'm going to save the image as I am
underscore save.jpg over here now if I
wanted to crop an image I can do that as
well so I initially I stored the
dimensions that I want cropped in the
form of a tuple as you can see here and
I'm going to pass that Tuple to the crop
function and I'm going to apply that on
top of im1 and I'm going to store that
to region once I've done that as you can
see so basically what I've done is I've
cropped this image based on whatever
I've passed here and I've stored it into
region and now if I wanted to see what
was um actually in that crop I can just
do the IM show function and I'm going to
pass the particular cropped image which
is denoted by region as you can see here
and you can see my cropped image is
basically a certain a left portion of
this whole image has been cropped out
and I have produced it over here now I
can also use the copy function using
it's a simple basically copy basically
you use the copy function and it copies
an image onto another variable that you
have assigned and when I use the IM show
function I am going to show you the
copied image which is basically the same
now we can do the transpose operation as
well so let's see some of the let's see
what we have done here so in this
transpose opposite operation so in this
uh basically I've done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once I've done with all
of these multiple operations I am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever I have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling uh I have shown you two
slightly more comprehensive examples on
text files and even certain examples on
image files however we can use file
handling in different libraries
pertaining to file handling for audio
files and even for like stuff like PDF
files and this is like this is just only
the beginning and I'm sure you will
encounter a lot of different use cases
different examples as you continue
learning
um Python Programming this video is
going to be the first of a part of a
series on object oriented programming so
to start off with let's try to
understand and get an introduction into
what is object oriented programming well
as the name suggests object oriented
programming is about creating objects an
object is a group of interrelated
variables and functions variables can be
referred to as the properties of the
object whereas the functions can be
referred to as the behavior of an object
so if we were to treat say for example a
car as an object its properties would be
its color its model its price and its
brand whereas Its Behavior or functions
for that matter would be like
accelerating gear change braking
similarly if I give you an example of a
dog as an object we could consider the
properties of the dog as its weight or
its name its breed its color whereas its
functions could be say barking playing
eating walking Etc objects provide a
better and a clear structure for a
program now let's move on to what is a
class and an instance now a class is
like a blueprint or a template of
certain functions and entities whereas
an instance is a particular realization
of a class classes are used to create
user-defined data structures and Define
certain functions called Methods within
the class whereas instances are
realizations of these classes and when
we are speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty form or a
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own a unique
set of information that is one way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and in instance now for our first
example on classes I will be taking you
through a class where I've defined based
on the circle object so this class is
going to define basically information
about your general circles such as this
radius and its area so let's go through
it now obviously to define a class we
need a keyword well in the case of
classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here A bunch of Dev
keywords followed by something that you
might not be familiar with and I will
try to get you through this so if you
see here you have a def keyword followed
by init and this init is prefixed by a
double underscore and it's suffix by
double underscore and you can see the
same thing for Str and repr well this
double underscore is called it under and
any method these are of course methods
this is a method this is a method this
is a method this is a method now any
method that is prefixed and suffixed by
double underscores are called Dunder
methods these Dunder methods are or can
be thought of like predefined or
built-in methods for any class that you
define so these we have like three
Dunder methods over here and we have one
user defined method that we will get to
so this first method that you see here
is the init method or the initialization
method and this is invoked or called
whenever we create an instance of this
class Circle and what we do here is
basically we pass when we create this
instant Circle we are what what happens
is that we are we get an option to pass
an a value for a what what is this uh
keyword or variable radius so if I pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where um I will be passing a
value and that value is basically stored
as the radius and by default the radius
that will be passed whenever we create
an instance for this class is one the
Str method is basically used to return a
descriptive string for the the instance
of class our API is not something that
you have to bother with right now and
now get area is something that you
should follow because if you see here I
have not used any double underscores so
this is a user user defined method user
defined methods are some method that we
Define and these are like tasks that we
Define on our own so in my user defined
method called get area I will be
returning the area of this circle based
on the radius that I pass to it now if
you notice here before every in every
method I have this self keyword before
any other attribute so like this has
self this has self even the get area
herself now what this means self is like
an optional keyword that is used to
improve readability of a program first
of all and it's also the function of the
self keyword is basic quickly telling
python that well any of the methods that
we are invoking in this class or the
instance of this class has to refer to
attributes and variables within that
instance of that class so if I'm going
to use get area function I am going to
get values and attribute values and
variable values based on only the
current instance of that particular
class self is obviously optional we
don't really need it but basically the
first attribute of any method is is
basically the is basically what the
method is is the instance that the
method is invoked upon so if I say self
I am telling this particular function
that okay all the value that you're
going to get for performing whatever
task you want is going to be found in
that particular instance where you have
been invoked itself now don't worry if
all this is very confusing if this might
be in the beginning but just try to
understand that this is something that
we do for good practice and you will
understand when when to yourself or when
not to yourself as you learn about
objective oriented programming so if you
see here my get AR function is supposed
to return the value radius times radius
self dot radius is basically telling um
whatever value I've passed for radius
for that particular instance you can
read this as radius times radius times
pi as well so obviously this is pi R
square which is the area of a particular
circle now let me show you an example
where I am going to perform some of
these functions so if you see this first
line I have created an instance of the
class Circle where I've passed 2.1 for
the radius of the circle so now the
value of the variable radius in this
particular instance is going to be
stored as 2.1 and this particular
instance is going to be stored in the
variable C1 now the print C1 function
invokes the Str
self-defined or predefined function now
if you remember Str was it's basically
used to return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we Define on
our own in our example Str will return
the uh the string saying this is a
circle with radius of and then it will
return the radius that we passed so in
this case it should say this is the
circle of radius 2.1 as you can see over
here so if I execute this you can notice
this line This is a circle with radius
2.1 and this is invoked by the print
function the print basically invokes the
dunder Str function which does all of
this now in the next line we say print
C1 dot get area so this is going to
print the value of the what what gets
returned when we invoke the method get
area for this particular instance C1 so
obviously in this particular instance
our radius is 2.1 so the get area
function should do pi times 2.1 square
and the value is as you can see here is
some 13.85 so that is the area that we
got now if we want to print a particular
radius we just say print C1 dot radius
so this will print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance C1 now you might
notice me using a DOT whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well any time that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name C1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say C1 dot get area if you
want to find out what is there in the
radius uh key radius variable of a
particular instance we say C1 dot radius
now before we move on let's talk about
some of the naming conventions class
names are initial capitalized so if our
class name is for example
um like for example if it's camel case
well each word that is part of this
class has its first letter capitalized
variables and Method names are in lower
class so if my class was called Circle
we say class class circle with C being
in capital now moving on let's talk
about how we initialize or Define
instance variables now instance
variables are declared within the init
method if you remember from the earlier
example of circle init is a Dunder
method it's followed and it's preceded
by double underscore as you can see here
now if you see in this particular case I
have again used the self keyword and as
I mentioned earlier the self keyword is
the first parameter of all member
methods
um and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new Circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
if the init function basically
initializes each and every new instance
of um whatever of our class so we can
give in at any number of parameters but
the first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the ins
instances automatically passed to the
self parameter in init so that new
attributes can be defined on the object
inside the init method the self.radius
basically means that we want the value
of radius based on the current instance
itself so as you can see radius defines
an instance variable radius and we're
going to use the particular instance and
its value of 4 radius in our variable
radius now instance uh the inner I mean
the init function is not a Constructor
but it is an initializer to create
instance variables the init function
also will never return a value and it is
optional and can be omitted if there are
no instance variables now let's move on
to class variables so now as we
mentioned earlier all the attributes
that are created inside the init
function are instance specific
attributes and the instance attributes
are obviously specific to a particular
instance of the class for example all
dog objects now if we have a class
called dog then all dog objects have a
name and age but the values for the name
and age will vary depending on which dog
we are talking talking about or
basically which instance of the dog are
we talking about now class attributes
are attributes that have the same value
for all class instances and we define a
class attribute by assigning a value
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called Circle and we have this
initializer again where we have class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init init function or the
initializer function if you see here we
have another variable called shape
object which stores the string Circle
and this variable is going to be the
same and constant for every instance of
the class Circle and unlike the variable
radius we will not have different values
depending on a particular instance okay
now let's talk talk about instantiating
an object and let's see what happens
when we create two different instances
of the same class as you can see here
I've created an instance C1 for class
Circle and I'm going to check its ID
well if you see the ID is something like
this now if I create it another instance
over here called C2 and if I check its
ID well it's something different now so
if you see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on the
introduction into oop let's talk about
class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the at class method operator or
decorator as you can see here it accepts
a class as its first argument so in this
case I am going to say I'm going to
define a class called my class I'm gonna
use this at class method decorator say
that whatever follows here is going to
be a class method and I've defined a
class method called hello that takes in
a that uses against self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever I have passed to it in the
form of hello from self.name now what
this this is going to do is basically
it's going to give out a string saying
hello from name of is called the string
name my class with a comma and then
whatever we passed initially which was
Rakesh next is then instance methods and
these are the most common types of
methods these are invoked by an instance
object so we have to create an instance
to actually use an instance method and
it takes the instance or the keyword
itself as its first argument so if I say
class dot class if I define a class my
class in this example and I'm going to
Define another function called hello as
you can see I have not used any
decorator like at class method so this
is going to be an instance method and
it's going to be invoked by the
particular instance so in this case it's
going to print hello from and it's going
to basically say the name of the class
again so I create my instance called my
instance one and it's an instance of
this class and then I'm gonna invoke the
instance method by using this dot dot
operator and the instance name and the
result will be basically this string
over here as you can see now finally we
have another type of method called the
static method which is declared using
the add static method decorator so a
static method does not know its class
and it's just attached to the class for
convenience it does not depend on the
state of the object and could be from a
separate function of a module a static
method can be invoked via a class object
or an instance object so if you look at
this example over here I have defined a
static method I've defined hello and it
basically says print hello world so it's
going to basically just print this so if
you can see here I created my instance
and I'm going to say dot hello it should
basically print print hello world that's
all in this video we will continue know
that discussion on oop with inheritance
inheritance is used to describe the
relationship between two classes wherein
one class takes the methods and
properties from another class in this
relationship we have something called
the base class or the parent class from
which we will derive all our sum of the
properties and methods and the class
which actually derives these properties
and methods is known as the derived
class so you can think of the derived
class as a specialized version of a base
class to explain what inheritance is in
a basic way I will show you an example
where I'm creating a cylinder class
which is going to be a subclass of the
circle class that you might have
encountered in the earlier video on op
so what we're going to do is create a
cylinder class that is a subclass circle
where we're going to get the attributes
radius and get area from Circle class
and we're going to add the attributes
height and get volume to the cylinder so
right off the start you can see we have
our class Circle that you might have
seen in the earlier video so this class
Circle has the familiar initialization
where we are supposed to enter a value
for a radius that gets stored in self
dot radius now we also have a
description string which basically is a
Dunder method that returns a string when
we invoke the print command on a
particular instance and we have the get
area method as well now if we move on to
the cylinder class you can see that I'm
defining this class with the class
keyword with the cylinder name but you
can see that I have added a parenthesis
and within it I have mentioned the name
of the superclass that I want the
cylinder class to be a subclass of so
this is how we actually Define a
subclass in the most basic way you enter
the name that you want and you enter the
name of the super class that you want
the subclass to be if a subclass of in
parenthesis right after the name now
next if you move on to the dunder
initialization
um the initialization is very familiar
familiar except now we have another
attribute for height which has a default
default value of 1 just like the radius
so this basically means that we have an
option of entering two different
attributes for our cylinder instances
now if you see here there's a line which
says super dot in it now this is like um
this is a command which we use to invoke
the super classes initializer so anytime
we create an instance for cylinder we
also want an initialization for the
circle method as well as a part of our
cylinder instance next you can see that
much like how we store itself I mean the
radius attribute in self dot radius
we're also storing the height attribute
in self dot height now even this
cylinder class has an Str method to
return a particular string if we use
this print function and finally we get
on to a more a new method that we have
defined only for the cylinder class
called get volume now if you see the get
volume it returns as basically the
volume of the cylinder that is being
described in the particular instance for
which we enter the height and the radius
so if you can see here what we've
basically added extra is an a height
attribute and another method called get
volume and the other parts of the circle
super class such as radius and get area
are also going to be a part of cylinder
even though you do not explicitly see
them anywhere here and we will see how
in uh in the form of an example that's
coming up so let me just execute these
classes now that that's done I'm going
to create an instance for cylinder I'm
going to store it in cy1 and I'm going
to pass 1.1 for the radius and 2.2 for
the height and once that is done let's
just print to invoke the HDR method and
as you can see the Str method basically
tells us the information that is a
cylinder with radius 1.1 and height 2.2
so now let's print what is the value we
get when we use the get area method now
it's important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle super class and we
can see that we can actually access
methods that are part of the superclass
simply by accessing any other method so
if you use the dot get area you can see
that we get a value for the area of the
cylinder so this basic this area is
basically the area of the circle face of
the cylinder uh the top or the Bottom
now let's use now let's invoke uh the
subclass specific method which is the
get volume method in a similar manner as
you can see just by doing invoking this
method we get the volume as well now if
we want to see what is the radius and
the height we can just do a simple print
statement followed by cy1 dot radius
cyman dot height and it gives us both of
these values as you can see here now
over here what I'm going to do is create
another instance of cylinder but I'm not
going to pass anything for radius or
height so basically it's going to take
the default values for radiation height
which was 1 and 1 respectively so once I
print
um this is this statement is basically
going to print the SDR method or
whatever we stored in the Str which is
basically the disc description of the
object followed by what is its radius
and height this method will give us the
area and this method will give us the
volume so once I execute this as you can
see here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what I'm going to show you is uh
now I'm going to go back and I am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the superclass of course and
I'm gonna give it and since the
superclass has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so I pass 3.3 and I'm going
to print what what happens when I just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was a part of
the HDR method after that I'm going to
print is instance this is basically a
check on whether C1 is an instance of
this class Circle and X I'm going to
check if C1 is an instance of its
subclass cylinder now when I execute
this you can see that well this is what
we uh this is the Str method that gets
printed but if you see here um you can
see that it says C1 is indeed a an
instance of circle when it says true
over here but when we look at the next
line is C1 an instance of cylinder it
says false and this is obviously because
um a superclass object is never an
instance of a subclass object whereas
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
Python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in Python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and uh Hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one Base Class and
one derived class from That Base Class
so this is a simple single inheritance
and in this example you can see I have a
class called country where I have a
method that I've defined called show
country which is basically going to say
print this is India it's basically going
to print this every time we invoke this
show country method then we have a class
called state which derives from the
super classical country where we have a
method called show state which is going
to say print this is state every time so
you can see I created an instance of the
class State and I'm through that
instance I can access the super class
and the subclass methods over here next
we have the multi-level uh sorry
multiple inheritance and this is when a
derived class contains more than one
Base Class so let's look at an example
to understand this so if you can see
here I have a class called student with
the two methods defined called method
one and Method two in method one we can
pass two attributes Sno or I think is
this this is supposed to be like an ID I
guess like SN number and we have S name
so this is basically two attributes we
can pass that are probably descriptors
for a student and in the next method you
have basically two print statements
which Says student number and then they
will print the student number and it
will also print the student name next we
have a class called marks this is also
so um so these these two classes are
basically what our super classes are
going to be and we're going to derive a
third class from these two so this
second class is a class called Marx and
we have two uh methods again one method
is called set marks which has
um the option of putting in two
attributes M1 and M2 both are
representative of the two marks and we
store them in self dot Mark 1 self.mark2
the second method is put marks which is
going to print the marks namely mark one
and then it's going to tell us how much
marks are there in the first subject for
example and another print statement
doing the same thing for the second
subject number two finally we have a
third class called a result which
derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis I've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result I have two methods specific
to this derived class called calc
wherein I'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of um uh the the
total marks which is basically the
addition of Mark 1 plus Mark II and I'm
then I'm going to have another method
called put total which is going to print
me what is the total so if you can see
here I have created an instance of this
derived class called a result I am
storing it in R then I'm going to access
method one which is obviously a method
from the first superclass called student
and I'm going to store okay so this is
name is I guess lucky and he has 60
marks secondly then I'm going to do our
set marks which is the method from the
second Super class which is going to set
the marks uh respectively so you have
lucky student and his ID is 60 and he
has got 50 and 60 marks respectively in
say the first two subjects and finally
I'm going to access the derived class
method called calc so this is going to
do the sum finally I'm going to also do
our method two which is I'm going to
print our student number and his student
name next we're going to have put much
which is going to tell us the what are
the individual marks for Mark 1 and Mark
2 and then finally we're going to print
the total marks with the put total so
once I execute this you can see here it
says student number 60 student name
lucky Marks One is 50 as I had written
here marks 260 as I passed here and then
total is 110 which is basically 50 plus
60. now the next type of inheritance is
called multi-level inheritance now
multi-level inheritance can be assumed
as where you take a super class let's
call it a and you derive a Class B from
net class A now what if we derived a
Class C from B and we kept doing this so
until say a Class E now each of these
steps is in its own an inheritance but
this whole relationship can be described
as a multi-level inheritance so let's
take an example again so I've put this
this time I've defined a class called
student where I have defined two methods
called set stud and put stud or you can
call it set student and put student in
my first method I have two options of
adding two attributes again this is the
story number this is the student name in
my second method I am going to print
what is the student number and what is
the student name finally uh so sorry
next we have another class called marks
which derives from the first class
called student this has two methods
called set marks where I'm going to
again get the option of adding two
integers for M1 and M2 which is going to
represent Mark 1 and Mark 2 and finally
I have put marks the method which is
going to print Mark funner Mark II
um finally I have another class called
result and this if you see this derives
from marks now if you see this
relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and
even as a part of this third class we
have its own methods called calc and put
total calc will calculate the total as
we had seen earlier and put total will
basically print the total and we're
going to do a a similar operation we're
going to create an instance of this
third class result and store it in R
then we're going to do basically we're
going to set the student details uh his
uh student number and his name we're
going to give him his marks 50 and 60.
we're going to calculate what are the
total we're going to say okay now put
the details of what is the student's
number and name we're going to also
store enter I mean display his marks my
Quantum Mark II and finally we're going
to display the total marks so let's
execute this and if you see it's
basically the similar operation that we
did earlier but the only difference is
in the earlier example I was uh our
third class result was derived from Marx
and student together so this was an
example of multiple inheritance whereas
in this example the result class derives
from marks and marks itself derives from
students so this is an example of
multi-level inheritance finally we have
um sorry not finally penultimately we
have as our fourth example of
inheritance called hierarchical
inheritance apart in my Ms presentation
it's hierarchical inheritance so in this
case a base class basically will contain
more than one derived class so let's say
a look at an example of what we mean
here so I have a class called one where
I have defined a method called display
where what I'm going to do is I'm going
to store set.x is equal to 1000 and self
dot Y is equal to 2000 then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1 and I'm going to say after that
I'm going to print another statement
saying value of x is a self.x which is
going to be 1000 uh then I'm going to
have another print statement saying
value of y is self.y which is going to
be 2000. finally um I mean next I have
another class called 2 this this is
going to derive from class 1 as you can
see here and in this class 2 I have
defined another method called add and in
this method add what I'm going to do is
I'm going to first print a statement
saying this is the method in class 2 and
then I'm going to actually print the
result of X Plus Y which is 1000 plus
two thousand finally I have another
class called three and this is also
deriving from one so if you notice we
have one parent class called one and
from this one uh parent class we're
going to derive two different subclasses
called two and three so this is an
example of hierarchical inheritance now
in this uh class three what I've done is
I've defined a multiplication method
what I'm going to do is print first of
all I'm going to print this when I
invoke this method that this is the
method in class three finally I'm going
to say uh I'm going to print the result
of x times Y which is 1000 times 2000 so
if you see I am going to create an
instance of 2 and I am going to create
an instance of three and I'm going to
store them in T1 and D2 now since uh T2
I mean T1 is an instance of 2 so I can
access its methods add and I can access
this methods display so I'm going to use
d1.display and even in 2 uh T2 I mean
since it's a class uh it's an instance
of class 3 and this also derives from
class 1 I can also access its method
display but now I cannot access add but
I can access multiply so if you see here
I access add through T1 instance since
add is a part of Class 2 whereas
multiply is a uh is a method in class
three so I access it in its respective
instance which is D2 so if you see here
now once I execute this what you will
get is basically
um the results so first of all it will
basically display the method from class
1 which is the display method it will
display the values of X and Y and since
I've done this twice from two different
instances it will basically show a
repetition over here finally I've done
the addition and since this is a method
in class 2 it is going to say as much
that is the method in class 2 and then
it's going to say X Plus Y is 3000 and
now multiply is a method in the third
class so it's going to say this is a
method in class 3 and it's going to tell
me what is the multiplication result
finally we have what is called Hybrid
inheritance and this is a combination of
multiple plus multi-level inheritance
that you saw earlier so let's again
understand this through this example so
we have a class called student where we
have have a method called set student
again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so we have a method in class
marks called set marks where we can pass
two attributes for Mach 1 and Mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for Marks One and
marks two we have a class called
practical this practical is basically a
another Super class if you see here
since this does not derive from anything
it is super class on its own and what it
does is it it has two methods get
practical and we can pass an attribute
for P1 here and we store that in self.p1
and then we have an attribute for foot
practical which will print us the
Practical marks whatever we passed for
this attribute in P1 finally if you see
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marks itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derived from marks
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call Hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to do a total of the marks in
this case Mach 1 plus Mark 2 plus the
Practical Mark P1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we're going to
create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student class set student
method so we're going to set student
here we're going to say 60 is a student
ID and name is Ash then we have set
marks which is again the the second
level parent which is a student class
where we set the marks finally we access
this get practical now if you notice get
practical is part of the Practical uh
super class so in this we store the
third subject or the the Practical marks
100 then we calculate the total and we
put first the student details then we
put the individual marks then we put the
Practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted
um is shown over here in this video we
will continue our discussion on object
oriented programming with the topic of
polymorphism now the term polymorphism
in oop refers the ability of an object
to adapt the code to the type of data it
is processing polymorphism is one of the
key concepts of python and it is also a
built-in feature of python an example to
get us started on polymorphism would be
how we use the plus operator we use the
plus operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for stuff like string
concatenations or joining tool lists
together this example where we're able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what I mean I
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where I'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
I do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when I use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
Python and programming to separate uh
strings and when I use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms one string containing both of
these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in Python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in Python is some thing that we
use a lot and over multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for we get a
different value or a different sort of
information from the length function now
if you see here from this diagram when
we use the length function on a string
it gives us the length of the string
when we use the length function on a
list it gives us the number of items
whereas if we use the length function on
a dictionary it gives us the number of
keys so this is well another example of
how we have polymorphism in a function
now what we are going to do is look at
the different techniques through which
we can enable polymorphisms in our code
our first example that we are going to
look at is through method overloading
now method overloading in its
traditional sense where we can have a
method with the same name more than one
method with the same name in the same
class is not exactly possible in Python
so if we have multiple methods with the
same name in a class in Python which may
differ in in types and number of
arguments events are not allowed and not
supported in Python in fact if we did
something like this where we created a
method with a different uh with
different say types and number and
arguments but having the same name in
the same class then what python will do
is it will only recognize the the last
defined method and it will not recognize
any of the earlier methods with the same
name but we can simulate polymorphism
through method over overloading by using
default arguments in a method now for
example what I'm going to show you here
is an example where I have a method
called sum Now by default it has three
attributes that you can pass through
this method a does not have a default
value B does not have a default value
but if you notice C has a default value
of 0. so this is a simple example where
I'm going to show you that the sum
method is going to be used in two
different cases in one case we are going
to Simply add two-way digits uh I mean
two numbers and in another case we are
going to use the sum method to add three
different numbers so we have this class
overload demo within it a method sum and
I have three attributes A and B are uh I
have are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas C
has a default value of 0. so if you see
here in my first case I have I first of
all created a an instance called over uh
an instance called OD for the class
overload demo and I have what I'm going
to do is I'm going to store the value of
the sum of 7 and 8 in the variable sum
now if you see here I have not passed a
third argument so what this method is
going to do is it's going to take the
value of C as 0 by default so it's
basically going to do uh 7 plus 8 and
it's going to give us the sum for 7 plus
8 and in the next instance I'm going to
give three arguments seven eight and
nine so now c will be replaced by 9
instead of 0 and then I'm going to get
the sum of 7 8 and 9. so in this this is
a not a very used and are not a very
commonly used thing but it's basically a
method just to show you that we can
actually simulate method overloading in
Python by using default arguments so
I've basically shown you how the same
how the same method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but you'll basically notice
that by having this third attribute C I
have a default value of 0 I have induced
some form of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already in one of its super classes now
if there is a method in a super class
the method having the same name and same
number of arguments in a child class uh
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chart class will be executed executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overridden method is called uh is called
based on the object type which is an
example of polymorphism so let's look at
an example to understand this so we have
a class called person and we have
defined what we're going to define the
initializer is two attributes which we
have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in self.name
and self.h now we have a user defined
method called display data where we are
going to print if this display data has
been called through the parent called
person
um if it's going to be called through
the parent class object then we are
going to print in parent class display
method and when we're going to print the
name and age that we have entered now we
have another class called employee which
is is going to be a derived class one
person so it's going to
um so it's also going to have an
initializer and this Constructor will
basically what what this initializer
will have is it will have an uh
Constructor for the super class where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the super
class but we're also going to store
another attribute called ID in self dot
employee ID and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same name method from
person but now if you see in display
data I have every I have all the same
almost the same information I'm going to
print the name I'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
I'm going to say if I'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then I'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically I'm invoking this method from
the child class object and I'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
I'm printing before I'm also going to
print the employee ID so if you see here
I have created an object called person
which is an object of the class person
with the information of name John and
age 40. and then I'm going to display
this now next I'm going to create an
object called amp which is the child
class employee object which is going to
now have the same information of John
for the name and age 40 but now is going
to have an employee ID and then I'm
going to store this uh in amp and I'm
going to display the data for this child
class object and we will see the
difference in how the display data is
differing from the earlier earlier case
so when I execute this you see the in
the first case it says in parent class
display data method so this display data
has been called through the parent class
object and I'm only going to show the
information of name and age whereas when
I invoke this method from the employee
class object it's going to say it's
going to specifically say that it's a in
child class display method and then I'm
going to say the name age and also the
employee ID over here so this is the
difference between how displayed data
has been used in its parent and its
child class and this is basically the
example of method overriding now our
next example of polymorphism is going to
be through operator overloading and
operator overloading is the ability to
overload the operator to provide extra
functionality in additional to its real
or core operation and operator
overloading is also an example of
polymorphism as the same operator can
perform different actions the earlier
example of where we use the plus
operator for different operations is an
example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when this
operator overloading required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what I'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where I'm
going to store two attributes X and Y in
sub.x and Y and instep.x and self dot y
now I'm going to create one object
called P1 where I'm going to create
point uh one and two so you can think of
this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another Point
called uh x coordinate three x one and
four I'm gonna call that P2 now I want
to print P1 plus P2 all right now if I
try to execute this you will notice an
error it says unsupported operand types
for plus point and point this basically
means that plus does not know what to do
when it's given an object of this type
it has no idea what to do whereas what
we wanted to do is add the the the x
coordinate from this point and the x
coordinate from this point so we wanted
to do one plus three and we also wanted
to do this y coordinate plus this y
coordinate or 2 plus 4 and then we want
to print basically like something like 4
comma 6 or the addition of the two
points uh or the the vector addition of
these two points so this is what we want
this plus operator to do but the python
does not have any inbuilt feature for
the plus operator and we are going to
have to basically do some Opera greater
overloading to create a polymorphism on
this so let's see how we can do that so
to do that first of all we have to
understand that all operators in Python
have internally defined methods to
provide functionality for these
operators the operator or the special
method to provide functionality for the
plus operator in Python is the add
method and whenever the plus operator is
used we are basically internal link
internally invoking the add method so
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for The
Operators are part of a big a bigger
class of methods known as magic methods
and these magic methods are
automatically invoked whenever it's
corresponding operators are used so we
want to change the or the operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method magic methods are also are
basically what we saw earlier in the in
the form of Dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore score a prefixed and
suffix to it so similarly to how we
defined an init of an init method or an
HDR method we are going to also invoke
the add method using the same double
underscore before and after its name so
now let's see how we're going to do this
so if you see this class I have now my
class point and I have the same
initializer when I'm going to store X
and Y now I am going to Define on uh
these this add magic method I am going
to override the the normal functionality
of plus and I'm going to give it a very
specific function where I'm going to say
um for two two different objects you're
going to add its uh the first part the
first part or its so called x coordinate
with the other x coordinate and it the y
coordinate with the other y coordinate
and you need to return return this to me
in the form of a similar object so now
when I pass one and two and three and
four it should return me four and six as
you can see here I have basically done
what I wanted to do by operator
overloading I have changed or I have
over loaded this add this plus operator
using this add magic method and I have
created a new functionality for this add
function for these two points one and
two three and four now I'm able to add
one comma 2 3 comma 4 in the way I want
it to so now that you saw how we did our
operator overloading I'm just going to
show you a list of similar magic methods
for different operators that we are
familiar with so the plus operator
already we've seen has the add method
then we have the minus operator with the
sub method and similarly we have for all
of these operations such as
multiplication division we have its
respective magic methods these magic
methods are again prefixed with two
underscores and suffix with two
underscores and they are basically they
are also called uh done does in Python
so this is how we would do operator
overloading in Python for whatever
operator we want similarly we can do
this for like comparison operators and
for unary operators as well so look at
this example now where I'm going to
overload the multiplication or the as
tricks operator so I have again defined
a point I mean a class called point I'm
going to Define an initializer but I'm
going to store some attribute X in cell
dot X now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to overload the multiplication
operator where I'm going to basically
allow the uh this Asterix operator to
multiply two objects uh from like for
example 12 and 5. usually I can just do
a normal 12 times 5 but in this case my
object is slightly different my 12 is
being passed through an object of a
class called point and 5 as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when I want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we Define
um or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do I'm using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective class instances so it's able
to say okay so I want this attribute
from this particular instance V1 12 and
I'm going to multiply it with the
attribute 5 from instance P2 whenever I
say P1 times P2 or P1 as 6 P2 so when I
executed it will give me 12 times 5.
similarly I can also do this for the
greater than operator over here so I
have a class called person where I'm
going to Define an initializer where I'm
going to pass name and salary and store
them in sub.name server.s salary the GT
method is basically the greater than
method magic method and it's going to uh
we're going to use this to overload the
greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator I am
able to basically say object 1 greater
than object 2 and I'm basically able to
check through this and if object 1 is
greater than object 2 it will basically
tell us if it is true or false or
basically whatever like we want to know
so this is the the print statement will
check for object1 DOT name and it will
say earns more than objective.name if in
case object that one is indeed greater
than objective so when I execute this
you can see here my first information
says John has is earning 4500 some units
Natasha is earning 6000 of some units so
it will say uh John earns more than
Natasha well it's false because object
one is not greater than object two so uh
since 4500 is not actually greater than
6000 and this is the check that I'm
doing by overloading the GT operator
over here where I'm so where I'm
returning the Boolean value of uh what
is greater self. salary or other dot
salary self being the first object in
any comparison so in the if I'm
basically any comparison if I'm doing
say if I'm doing 5 greater than 5
greater than 6 so what the GT will do is
this will be the self object and this
will be the other object so this is what
I'm doing over here I'm checking self
dot salary with other dot salary in in
the form of these objects and it's
basically the same same way that we we
are able to do five plus five through
these class instance objects that you
saw earlier or 12 times 5 that you saw
earlier so this is all examples of
operator overloading in Python in this
video we will be taking a brief
introduction into what is a function so
a function in Python is a group of
related statements that performs a
specific task or tasks now functions
help break our program into smaller and
modular pieces of code and it's very
good and very convenient to use
functions to make our code organized and
manageable especially as our overall
program grows larger it also helps us to
avoid repetition and makes the code
reusable so let's look at the basic way
of defining a function so this is a
basic function that I am calling Fun
underscore name all right now the rest
of the function or whatever the task is
going to be performed by this function
will be written over here within indent
of course as a standard when it comes to
python so I'm going to Define this one
something in triple double quotes so
don't worry about what this is right now
this is a Docs string don't worry about
what this means and I'll explain it to
you just in a short bit all right now
now the rest of the statement the rest
of it uh will obviously be what this
function will do let's include a simple
print statement all right let's uh it's
done here and let's call this so of
course now once you've defined the state
function to call the function you just
have to use its name like this this is
how you call a function so as you can
see when I call this function it should
print the statement hello now let's go
let's uh look at some of the uh like
what happened over here so we've used
the keyword def to define a function we
give it a unique name which makes it uh
which with which we uniquely identify
this function
um and also once we've done this we
um we can give it we can give this
function a particular header it's called
a doc string so what this doc string is
basically something that we include in
triple quotes over here just after the
dev keyword and this is like a brief we
can use this to give a brief and give
brief information into what our function
is doing so we can say this is this
function performs addition this performs
um subtraction or whatever like some
basic information as to what our
function does so we can use a doc string
for that of course this is an optional
thing this does not have to be we don't
have to include this as well all right
but for the sake of this let's just keep
it here after that of course rest of the
function uh will contain whatever tasks
we want to do with it and that will be
indented
um finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is at any point you find the return
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so now
let's see
um now there's also one more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you've noticed
over here within these parentheses I did
not include anything this is like an
empty pattern this is opening and
closing what is if I said a if I
included some A and B over here so what
this means is whenever I call this
function I need to pass two parameters A
and B these can be like strings or
numbers or whatever
um but now it becomes almost mandatory
that I pass these two things for my
function to uh to work so let's define a
function when I'm going to add a and b
so inside of this print statement let's
do this I create a variable C and in
that I'm storing a plus b all right and
then I return C so you can use a return
and you can you you can return certain
like variables along with the return
statement so I'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
or return an output called C which is
the addition of A and B now how do we
use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this I'm going
to add but I'm going to include
parameters so I'm saying Pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
B all right what will have happen now is
addition will take place and we will get
return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see two plus
three and I already got the data the
addition of two plus three and it
returned me five so yeah this was like a
basic uh usage of a function and
parameters so of course uh we can if you
want to know like what a what the doc
string of a particular function does or
says uh you can use this uh particular
you can use this like statement so let's
say for so uh it's very important to
like just keep a note in your uh while
you're going through this or while
you're learning that uh whenever we use
some sort of a function which has double
underscore right this is like a built-in
a built-in command provided by python
um within the python Library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so I want to check
what is the doc string and this is how I
do it so let's do print let's print what
is the doc string over here this is a
doc string so this is a basic basically
what I wrote over here I can change this
to this like this does addition for
example all right now this will say this
does addition when I execute this line
so this is the way to check what is a
dog string anyways so now that you have
seen a basic uh basic function two basic
functions that I defined for you and how
we use them what a parameter is let's
look at another concept that we call
scope and lifetime of variables so scope
of variable is the portion of the
program where the variable is recognized
all right now a parameter and a variable
that are defined inside a function are
not visible from outside the function
this is a very key thing so if we Define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak
um these variables and these parameters
uh have what we call as local scope
since they are only recognized Within in
a particular function now the lifetime
of a variable is the period throughout
which the variable exists in the memory
itself and it's very important to note
that lifetime of variables that are
defined inside a function
um are as long as the function executes
once we return from a function uh
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so when we use a function it
will not remember the values of a
variable from a a previous iteration of
a function call so let's try to
understand this example or this concept
using certain examples so out here I
have defined a function where I am going
to create a variable my underscore VAR
my variable and I am going to store the
value 10 in this and then I'm going to
print so whenever I call this function I
will always create this variable I will
store 10 and I will print the value of
this all right now what I'm going to do
is I'm not only going to create this my
are inside this function I'm also going
to create a variable outside so you see
there now you might be confused as to
okay how is the behavior going to be
because outside the function I have
created my wire with a value 20 but
inside the function I will always Define
my virus 10 okay now I'm going to print
so my first what I'm going to first do
is I'm going to execute this function
that I created initially where I store
the value of 10 in my bar and then I'm
going to pray and print the value of my
wire that was present outside the
function let's see what happens you can
see two different things happening so
when I execute this function it prints
the value inside the function as 10 but
when I print the next line which says
um okay now get the value of my wire
um it actually prints a value of 20 and
this is a very key concept because
What's Happening Here is when I
initially call my function within this
function it creates a variable called my
wire and it prints the value as 10 and
the moment my function has been executed
it destroys this variable and and the
variable which contained the value 10 is
of course now destroyed and all we have
is the my wire that contains 20 from the
outside and when we print that we get
the suspective value as 20. so you can
also think of it like this the my wire
that is present inside this function is
different to the my word that we create
outside so the scope of the my wire
within this function is local only to
this function and once the function is
executed that variable is destroyed all
right now let's look at a another case
or the other side of this case where um
say we're dealing with variables that
have a global scope how do we deal with
them so let's create a variable called
my where all right and I say I stored
100 in this all right now if I Define a
function I've stored my where let's say
I Define a function define underscore
say again same name where what I'm going
to do in this is I am going to print the
value of whatever is there in my where
Okay so let's do print and
value of variable is value stored in
variable is okay let's uh my where so
let's see what happens when we do this
let's call this function on underscore
name see what happens here so as you can
see the value I stored a value of 100 in
Y where and I've called it inside the
function and this is because since I've
defined it outside I can use it inside
as well now what if I try to change the
value of this variable inside the
function though so let's see
if I did this and now if I try to print
let's see do is this Allowed no it's not
allowed in fact I get an error it says
local variable my wire reference before
assignment
um and without going too much into
detail what it's saying is that the
variable inside over here is still local
to this function and I have not defined
this my where as a global variable so I
cannot make changes to it within this
function right now and uh to change that
I can use the global keyword what if I
did Global over here so if I did Global
and now if I said okay Global myware and
I declare this variable as a global
variable now if I do this now if I do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when I'm trying to do this
you see I get the value 101 it's exactly
what I wanted and that is because I've
defined my variable to be a global
variable within this function so I can
in fact make changes to it within this
function so this is how we use the
global keyword and Global variable uh
also just to make a quick note there are
three types of functions uh the three
types of categories in which we can
divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
functions that is the ones which we
Define ourselves and the third type is
called Anonymous functions they're also
known as Lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in Python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say
um if I defined a function where
underscore sorry fun underscore name and
I'm saying a comma B right but what if
the user has not like save I I want a
default value of a and b each time when
I use this function so in the case where
if say I don't pass a value for A and B
like this will always be used so I can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
B is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function I will say C is
equal to a plus b and then return C so I
do this and if I say fun underscore name
and in case I don't pass any arguments
here let's see what happens by default I
get the answer 5 because by default a is
2 and B is 3 but this is not fixed and I
can always change this by passing my own
values here 5 and 6 and in this case I
should get 11 as you can see here now
the next type is required arguments and
when we are defining a required argument
we just simply do not use the equal to
sign for the parameters over here and
this basically it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if I try
to pass like this I won't get a oops
Yeah I won't get a default value then
that's because
um that's because well there is no
default value and it needs an AM B so I
have to capacity 3 and say 4. now it
should give me 7 as you can see the next
type of argument that we'll be talking
about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what I'm doing in this
particular example is I'm defining a
function called my sum where I'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
I'm doing something out here and what
this does is
um it will take the values of a
particular like collection of objects
and that's called my integers and each
value I'm going to keep adding it to
each other and I'm going to result a
particular sum I'm just going to resolve
the sum of whatever is there so in this
case what happens is I'm creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then I'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me 6. now the problem in
this case is that each time when I'm
going to perform this function I have to
create a separate list where I'm going
to store these objects but what if I
didn't know I do not know like what
exactly I'm going to pass here what if I
don't know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case I can use a
variable variable key variable number of
arguments so it's it's like a variable
keyword argument so what we use here is
um a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so I say Define
my under underscore name and I use an
Asterix now I give it any name this can
be adds this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisks here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now if we're supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever tasks we want so let's
just uh since I've already created one
here let's see how I'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see I'm doing
uh I'm creating a particular variable
argument function over here and I'm
doing the same task I'm just going to
keep performing at uh I'm going to add
whatever I pass over here but now when
I'm calling this function I don't need
to create a separate list as I did over
here I'm just passing all the numbers
that I want to in the form of like it's
pretty much like a tuple so I'm just
passing these numbers here and what this
function is going to do is it's going to
create an iterable out of this and then
we're going to iterate over it as you
can see that's happening over here and I
can keep uh I don't need I I can just
keep like uh so since I've done it for
one two three and seven the summation
should be 13 in this case I can add
another number here just explicitly just
like this and you can see the value will
change and that's because this is a
variable uh this is a variable argument
uh method of creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh argument so let's
look at what is the keyword argument now
so I have defined a function here called
the concatenate function and let's see
what I'm going to do with this so in
this I have passed a keyword argument
I've said that okay this is going to be
a keyword argument function and what I'm
going to do in this is I'm going to
create a blank string and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add or I'm going
to concatenate certain strings that I'm
going to pass to this function so I in
this example I have passed Python and is
and Google and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what I'm going to
do in this function is I'm going to join
them together
um and I'm going to create one whole
string out of it let's see what's the
result python is cool so this is so of
course like uh if I had to add some
something else like python is a cool and
say I just wanted to say hello and say
one more string I can add I can add it
just like this I don't have to like
Define a fixed number of arguments I can
pass and any number of arguments I want
and this works exactly the same as
variable in the only differences instead
of positional arguments we're using
keyword arguments over here hello by
like this it doesn't really make sense
but it's to show you as you can see so
this is how we use keyword arguments in
this video we will be learning about X
exceptions exceptions are errors that
are raised during the execution of a
program when an error occurs python
generates this exception that can be
handled which avoids our program from
caching python has many built-in
exceptions uh however we can create many
uh user-defined errors or exceptions as
well to catch whatever errors we're
looking for in our program so when an
error occurs python interpreter raises
an exception and stops the current
process and it passes it to a calling
process until the exception is handled
and if this is not handled the program
will crash some of the built-in
exceptions are like I O errors in the
case when a file cannot be opened or
import error python cannot find the
particular module being imported and
there are so many similar uh so many
exceptions that are built in Python for
the appropriate cases now before we move
on and see how we raise these exceptions
let's look at the difference between an
exception and a syntax error so for that
I will be using an example where I will
be dividing something by the number zero
of course this is not possible so let's
see how python handles this particular
problem well it raises something that it
raises what we call a zero division
error and this is an exception that is
built in in Python whenever we try to
divide something by zero now let's look
at the difference between this exception
and a syntax error so this is the same
statement except I'm going to add this
extra bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if I try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error when it says the unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma that basically makes the line
unreadable to The Interpreter in the
first place so the The Interpreter
doesn't even get to the point where it
needs to figure out uh that there is
something being divided by zero it
doesn't even get to that point because
it finds this extra bracket and it
cannot execute this line at all so that
is like the difference between an uh an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at the keyword arrays so for this
example what I will be doing is I'm
going to take this variable X all right
and I'm going to store a value 10 and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
check for a condition if x is greater
than 5 then I'm going to raise this
exception using the raise keyword like
this and in case this condition is met
if x is actually greater than 5 I want
this particular message to play out in
my uh exception so let's see what
happens when I execute this as you can
see the exception is raised because X is
indeed greater than 5 its value is 10
and the mirror message says so that X
should not exceed 5 the value of x was
10. so this is an example of how we can
raise an exception and as you can see
when a condition was met the program
comes to a halt and an exception was
raised now let's look at another type of
handling exception where we use the
assert statement so when we use the ray
base command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed Midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking
whether the system that we are working
on is actually Linux or Windows 32. so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is one of the functions and that is the
platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
Linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
error will obviously be an assertion
error because we are using the assert
keyword
so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systart platform contains win32
and not Linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for Windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is uh the example where
we use the assert statement another way
of handling exceptions is by using the
try and accept block so this is probably
one of the most common ways of handling
exceptions in Python where we use the
try keyword and an accept keyword now
within the try keyword as you can see
here we have a chunk of code which we're
going to check and if everything is fine
in the try keyword then this is perfect
so we don't need to move on to what we
call the accept part of the try and
accept block but if say there was an
error in the try block then we move on
to the accept block where we're going to
run the part of the code in the case we
find an error in the try block so first
we check the part of the code that is
under the try block and if if there is
an error we move on to the accept log
and we run that part of the code over
there and where we and in the accept
block where we that is where we handle
our whatever error that might get thrown
our way in the try block okay let's look
at an example at how to use this
technique so I have a basic function out
here all right it's uh defining a
function called Linux interaction what
this is uh basically doing is that when
I call this function I want to do an
assert check I'm going to check if Linux
is the system I'm working on and if it
is not then I want this error to be
thrown okay and um so yeah let's see
what happens in the case and if if the
search statement is actually passed then
we will move on to this statement so you
could look at it like this if whenever I
mean when I call this function it will
first check for this assert statement in
case something wrong happens and we get
an assert error then we do not move on
to this line so we only get this printed
but if this assert statement passes then
we move on to this line and we get print
doing something okay so let's see I'm
going to call this function out here
let's see what happens here as you can
see I get an assertion error because
obviously this is a Windows system and
not a Linux system and I get this
message okay now let's see what happens
when we use it in a try and accept block
all right so now I have a try block over
here in which I am going to try the same
this function Linux underscore
interaction if in case I find an error I
immediately jump from the dry block into
the accept block now you see the slight
difference in how we handle this like
what happens so as you can see when we
use the function explicitly we directly
went to what we called an assertion
error but when we use a try and accept
block we will not use the assertion
error because we are leaving the try
block immediately and we're going to go
into the accept block where the only
thing we're doing is printing the
statement as you can see we are not on
Linux found some error okay now what if
we wanted to catch the error within uh
this function itself which was the
assertion error and we can do that
explicitly like this so now what I'm
doing is I'm going to try all right and
it's going to catch an error in this
right so now in the accept block I'm
going to say the assertion error that we
found in this function in the try block
we're going to use that in our accept
block so as you can see we're going to
print that assertion error it will
basically print the statement function
can only run on Linux systems as you can
see here function can only run on net
systems function can only run on Linux
systems and the next part of the thing
was the Linux interaction function was
not executed okay so this is a a very
this is like this is a key there's a key
something very important happening here
when we use this assert statement the
whole program is actually getting
executed right but when we're using the
try and accept block we are immediately
jumping on like the moment we catch an
error we are immediately jumping onto
the accept statement and uh however and
all the handling of the exception is
done in the accept block and not in the
try block anymore so where to uh think
of it like this that the try block is
only to check if a particular piece of
code is like does it have any errors or
not and in case it does then every like
all the handling that we do is uh in the
accept block of this particular
statement now let's look at another
example in this example I'm going to try
opening a particular file now this file
does not exist so I will be I will get a
file not found error and this is a
built-in exception and I'm going to
catch that and I'm going to print that
error over here in the accept block all
right so as you can see file not found
and whatever like error I have I printed
over here all right so this is another
like this is a file not found error that
we are going to with that we we got in
our try block and we're handling it in
the accept block now let's use now let's
combine both of the examples where we
use this Linux interaction and we also
try to open a particular file and we try
to do both things in the try block and
since both of these contain errors let's
see what happens when we try to what
happens when we have like multiple
errors in a tribal talk so as you can
see in my try block I'm not only doing
this Linux interaction I'm also trying
to open a particular file that does not
exist obviously so now you might think
will I get two exceptions well let's see
what happens when we try to uh execute
this so it's important to note that in
our accept we have one except for uh
catching a file not found error and we
also haven't accept for finding um uh
the assertion error that that is part of
this Linux interaction function so so
since both of these are errorous
statements or they will throw exceptions
so now the question is will we get both
of these except blocks or we get both of
these exceptions where we can only one
of them will we get the first one so
let's see what happens so as you can see
my error statement is is very much like
the assertion error that I had that we
had done as part of this Linux
underscore interaction function function
can only run on Linux systems the Linux
function was not execute it as you can
see that that is the one that has been
caught and for some reason the file not
found error has not been caught and this
is because this is a very important
feature of the try block the moment we
find the first error in our try block we
immediately leave and we do not execute
any of the further statements and we
jump into the exceptions and we handle
it using the accept blocks so the moment
an error is found in this function we do
not execute this part of the statement
and we directly jumped into the
respective exception that was the
assertion error exception so this is a
key takeaway so some of the some of the
other key takeaways when it comes to
exceptions is a try Clause is executed
up until the point where the first
exception is encountered and in the
accept clause or the exception Handler
we determine how the program responds to
this exception we can have multiple
exceptions and we can differentiate how
the program responds to each of these
and it's also very important to not use
accept clause on its own it's very
important not to use a bare accept
Clause now finally before we come
include this topic of exceptions let's
look at the else and the finally Clause
so the else Clause is used when we want
to execute a particular piece of code in
the case where we have no exceptions or
no errors found so let's look at this
just like we had the Linux interaction
function I am going to define a win
under underscore interaction and this is
going to check whether our system is
Windows or not in case it is not then we
get this error message all right and in
case it is a Windows it is a window
system we print this in the case of when
we call this function so let's again use
our try and accept statement only in
this case we will be using an extra else
Clause so we first try this function in
case there's an error we catch it as an
assertion error and we print that error
but if there is no exception then we
move on to the else statement and we
print this so as you can see our we have
actually moved on to the else statement
and we print this line executing the
else clause and that is because we have
found no exceptions over here so again
is key to remember that the else Clause
is used whenever you want to execute a
particular statement in the case where
we do not find any exceptions in the try
block the finally Clause is used when we
want to execute something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens I mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so I have this block where
I'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that I'm doing is I'm going to
check for this Linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linear system or
not this is I'm doing the try block now
if I catch an error that I want to be I
want to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that
there is no error then I will move on to
the else statement and I will try this
particular block of my statement which
is again that when I'm trying to read a
particular file that does not exist and
it's very it's very important important
that you note that within the else block
I have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this I'm first
trying this if I have an error then I do
this and I don't execute this but if I
don't have an error then I execute this
whole statement which contains its own
try and accept block all right but
regardless of whether I get an error
here or not I will always execute this
portion of my statement or under the
finally Clause let's execute this as you
can see of course the error is raised in
this try try block so we move on to the
exception and that is what is printed
over here and after the exception is
done we move on to the finally we of
course skip this else block because the
exception was actually raised so after
that is done we move on to the finally
block where we print this particular
statement well that was it for an
introduction into exceptions in Python I
hope you learned something from this and
um of course this is just the beginning
exceptions are something that you will
be that you would probably encounter a
lot especially when you're beginning and
it's something that you will learn to
extensively work with and that will also
help you improve in your programming in
this video we will be covering the topic
of iterators now an iterator in Python
is an object that contains a countable
number of values or it's a larger object
it contains a countable number of
sub-objects an iterator is an object
that can be iterated upon and what that
means is we can Traverse from each value
and we can manipulate or perform certain
functions or operations and tasks using
each of the sub objects or values within
this larger collection called iterator
now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
Python which consists of the methods
iter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we're going to Traverse through
the objects of a list using the for Loop
so we have objects one two three four
I'm going to print each of these values
one by one as you can see here similarly
we can also do the same thing for
another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here another example of an iterable in
Python is the dictionary so let's say I
have a dictionary where I have two
values two key value pairs uh key X
which contains a value 1 and key Y which
corresponds to Value two now when I'm
going to do a for Loop through this by
default I will be traversing through the
keys X and Y as you can see over here
and of course the other types of a
triples in Python are like sets and
tuples as well all right now let's look
at what this iterating protocol is in
Python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects it contains
of objects and when we use the iter
function it creates an iterator out of
it so we can one by one we can Traverse
through each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or Traverse through each of
the sub objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or uh iterated upon so an ex
as an example I will create a list where
I will store the values some simple
values integers one two three four one
three four five okay I'm going to create
an iterator out of this where I will use
iter function and I'm going to say this
is let's say this is called my my editor
okay and I'm going to use iter function
as I had mentioned and I'm going to pass
my list in this
now if you see what is miter it should
say it should be a list iterator at a
particular memory location now let's use
the next function to keep going through
whatever is there in this so of course
the first object should be one as you
can see now when I look at the next it
should be three then I should get four
and now I should get five as I use the
next uh successively now since I've
reached the last of my objects in this
collection now the next time I use this
next function I should get a stop stop
iteration exception that is raised as
you can see here so this is the basic
iteration protocol in Python now you
might have already gone through the for
Loop video and in that I have spoken in
quite a bit of detail as to how a for
Loop performs this this iterator
protocol and how it creates an iterative
iterable object out of say a list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function and it um
breaks out of the for Loop once it
encounters the stop iteration exception
so
um for Loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now let's do a basic
comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in Python so in generator we
use a function we use like we Define it
using the def keyword and we Define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function the generator
makes use of the yield keyword whereas
the python iterator does not in
generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any triple like a list to
iterate upon we may use any number of
yield statements in generators and we do
not use yield statements in iterators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in Python
now my module in Python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a Python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now modular programming is the process
of breaking a large a large event or
task into smaller and more manageable
subtasks and we call these subtasks
basically modules now individual modules
can be grouped together like building
blocks to create a larger application
there are several advantages to
modulizing code in a large application
and we will be going through them right
now so first of all there is Simplicity
because instead of focusing on a big big
problem a big task we can break down the
problem into smaller smaller portions or
modules now maintainability of code is
much better through module because they
are designed to create these sort of
boundaries or clear demarcations between
different problem domains there is
usability reusability in the sense that
once we create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically Define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in Python that promote code
modulus modularization you might have
already come across a coordinate intro
into functions in this video we will be
going through modules and another video
we will also cover the topic of packages
to import a module we use the import
keyword and in this example what I'm
going to show you is a simple function
or a simple operation of importing the
OS module this is short for operating
system and as the name suggests we can
perform a system tasks uh through the
functions and methods that are part of
this OS module so simply executing the
statement will import this module onto
our program for us to use now if we
wanted to see all the functions that are
present in name audio what we have to do
is use the dir function so if we print
the dir OS function it will print us
basically a directory of all the
functions that are present in the OS
module as you can see here that like the
all of these are basically uh names to
different functions that are part of the
OS module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the getcwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now so if I execute this it will
tell me what is the directory that I am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir stem if you
wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the pan pieces it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temps if I were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that I am
currently working upon now a basic step
is
um creating a python module the simplest
way to create a python module is
basically creating a python script with
whatever functions and tasks that we
want and methods that we want inside uh
whatever module and saving it with a DOT
py extension
um so in in my example what I'm going to
do is I have already created a script in
notepad and I've stored it with a DOT py
extension that contains these four
functions add subtract product and
Division I have basically copied I
basically use this code and I've stored
it in a.py script and I'm going to be
using this as my uh as as a test module
for this particular example now how do
we import a module now once that I have
created a script in my example it will
be called mycalc.py uh and we've stated
stored it in our directory to import the
module all we have to do is use the
import statement so if I had to import
my calc all I have to do is say import
my underscore calc and now my calc has
been imported
um so we can use the import statement or
if we want to import something
particular from mycag we can do from my
calc import uh now we can whatever like
for example if we wanted the ad uh the
add function we can basically just say
only add or if we wanted add and
subtract we can say add and subtract for
example so this is basically by using
from we can say that we want something
from something but only parts of it we
don't want everything we can also use
from my calc import and we can say
Asterix to basically say uh import
everything that exists in my calc right
now so this is another way of importing
something from a module now to access
contents in a module we have to use the
dot operator and I will show you how
right now so what I'm going to do is in
my example I'm going to import my calc
as calc so now what this since this is
the original folder or the original
module but I'm going to give it a
shorthand name so that I can easily use
it in my code and I don't have to type
out my underscore calc every time so now
I'm going to import this as calc so
anytime I have to refer to a particular
method or function inside the script or
this module I will just use this uh this
placeholder this variable name so now I
have two variables A and B and I'm
storing 20 and 30 in them so my first
Funk what I'm going to do is basically
four operations I'm going to print the
addition of A and B then the subtraction
multiplication and the division of these
two numbers and each time to do this
operation I am going to use the add
function that is present in the my calc
module so to do that I have already
imported my characters calc all I'm
going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that
we're already familiar with so I'm going
to say character.add and then I'm going
to pass these two arguments or these two
variables to say that I want to add
these two and similarly I'm going to do
it for subtraction
um multiplication and division as you
can see these are the results of my
tasks now if I had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt uh
or Dunder methods that are already a
part of any uh python script by default
such as built-ins so if I execute this
just to show you what happens when I use
the idir function it will basically give
me all the functions that are part of
this python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting magic methods or Dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division prod and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
more detail into what happens when we do
a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as we did over here so the first
the steps that actually take place are
the interpreter executes the above
statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if The
Interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now secondly it
will list all the directories contained
in the python path environment that you
set up uh that you can set up or you can
change later on as well and this format
for python path is OS dependent of
course but you should mimic the path
environment variable that we see in
Windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search paths that is accessible in the
python variable system.path and this is
basically obtained from a module named
sys so if I import it this is and I did
sys dot path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if I am doing uh
import my import OS it's not only going
to look at the current directory that I
am working on it's also going to look at
all of these directories that have been
set up as you could say directories or
bats in the system.path in this video we
will be covering the topic of packages
now what if we developed a very large
application in Python that contains many
different modules and we have so many
different modules that have similar
names and functionalities and they're
all kept in like or dumped in the same
location that it becomes very difficult
to track these modules what if there was
a way to organize and access these in a
much simpler and more organized manner
well packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to uh let's look at certain
examples to understand what we mean so I
have a directory called PKG this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod1.py and mod 2.py and what
we're going to store in mod 1 and mod
2.py are the follows so I'm going to
define a function called Foo and I'm
going to print uh this particular
statement mod1 and then I'm gonna
basically say Foo and then I'm going to
say in class 4 I'm going to have an
empty pass command similarly I'm going
to define a function called bar in mod 2
dot py where I'm going to print this
statement so basically mod1.py has a
simple function where I'm going to print
this statement and mod 2.py has a simple
function then I'm going to print this
statement
um I'm going to store them in mod 1 and
mod 2.py respectively and these two
modules I'm going to store in the
directory tkg in my local folder now
I've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if I wanted
to access these particular modules from
the PKG folder I can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so I can say PKG dot mod1 so this will
invert in this will import the mod 1
module from PKG folder similarly I can
do the same thing for the mod 2 module
from the PKG folder in the same line so
now that it's been imported just simply
execute this and this Imports whatever
you needed now if we wanted to perform a
function that was a part of
mod1.py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly I can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module by extending the dot notation to
it in the same way now another way that
I can invoke
um I can import a package is by directly
importing the package Itself by using
import pkz and not accessing any of the
specific modules within it now let's see
what happens when we do this so just for
this example what I'm going to do is I'm
going to restart the kernel so that the
PKG modules that were already imported
get cleaned away so we see what happens
when we execute this on its own now if
you see I haven't imported this now
let's see if I can access is my mod 1
and mod 2. now if you see here it's
throwing me an error and this is because
using simply using the import command on
a particular package only Imports
um you could say the package namespace
but it does not actually import any of
the modules and files that were part of
this package so if I wanted mod 1 from
this package I would have to actually
say import pkz.mod 1 directly and I
cannot simply say import PKG and python
will not import everything that is part
of a package on its own I have to
specify it myself
specifically now I'm going to create and
I'm going to I mean I'm going to show
you another type of importing from a
package using the star operator so I
have this package PKG once again now I'm
going to store
um three I mean four different modules
within this package
mod11.py mod 222.py and I've already
done this you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
I've already created these files and
what I've done is is within mod11.py I
have defined I've passed I've written
this statement and I've stored in the
python script similarly I've created
another Python scripts script called
mod22.py and I have basically written
this in the code and I've similarly done
this for mod 333.py and I've done
another for mod 4.py now once I have
done this I've stored these Python
scripts into my uh into my package uh
PKG package so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create I'm going to
execute this command if you see this
from pkg.mod 333 import start so once I
execute this now I'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if I change
this and if I imported mod11 and if I
did the same thing you will see Foo has
now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all
functions that are part of these
different modules where I'm importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is saying from pkz dot
mod11 so it's saying that um okay look
into this directory or this uh package
and find this module and in this module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in Python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application and these modules can be
accessed using the familiar dot notation
that we have used in other examples such
as methods when we were working with
classes and objects in this video we
will be taking an introduction into the
concept of generators so python provides
a generator which is like like a
function where we can create our own
iterator in a generator function we use
the yield statement instead of the
return statement that we use for
standard functions so let's look at a
simple Generator First of all so out
here I have defined
a generator called my generator where
I'm doing like the three uh like three
functions or three tasks that I'm doing
uh first one is when I'm printing the
first item and I'm yielding a value 10
then I'm printing second item using 20
then I'm printing last item using 30. so
let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword every
time we use the next keyword we will
keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store
um the generator in my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first iteration is
performed where we get this the first
year command is done all right let's see
what happens when we do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20. let's do it for the next so
let's do it once more since there is one
more task team uh there's one more
iterable inside
you can see this now a very question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is other uh
built-in exception
um that happens when we have like
reached the last object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables are stored inside are lost and
they are destroyed unless they were
defined as Global and the function is
completely done executing and we leave
the function completely whereas when it
comes to a generator when we hit the
yield function we don't actually
completely leave this function so the
first time the yield is found we get 10
but the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next hit Triple so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in Python so to understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return commanders let's
take the same function all right
and let's put it return over here
after this particular the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to my generator
and
let's start yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first here will be standard first
item 10 the next one is again is going
to say second item and then 20 but now
if you notice there was a return I put
over here
so technically when I did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function or
this return statement so let's see what
happens if I do next again
as you see I have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than I did
before and that's because I have used
the return function and why my return
statement and what that's done is that
um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example I'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for Loop or for a for
Loop so let's take this whatever over
here and I have defined a function
called get sequence up to X and what
this will do is basically it will keep
printing the printing numbers up until
whatever we have entered in place of X
over here so if I said say sequence is
equal to Let's uh
copy this all right and say I want um I
want sequentially I want every number up
until 10 well not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if I
did this again
it should give me one
two and I can keep going
until I will stop at the value 9. as you
can see here
so 8 9 now I should get the stop
iteration error because that we have
reached the end of our iteration so this
is a way of using generator functions
for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator is
um in the case of Fibonacci numbers so
let's use it let's see how we can
generate a Fibonacci series using um
generator so I've defined a Fibonacci
function called Fibonacci where I'm
passing Max so max is basically the max
value that I want
um yeah like up until where I want the
sequence right so this is basically the
code which will give give return me the
subsequent values of my Fibonacci
Sequence so let's um pass this to fib
and say I want all the Fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so once I will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero then when
we
do this again we get 1 then we do 0 plus
1 it should be one next number should be
1 plus 1 which is 2 then we should have
two plus one three and then three plus
two five then three plus five should be
eight now eight plus five is thirteen
and since 13 is greater than what we
pass for our max value here now when we
try this we should get the stop
iteration error as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
Now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like creating a new list using a much
shorter and cleaner syntax compared to
what you might traditionally be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes creating these
new this much simpler and much easier
for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list which will contain
fruits that contain the letter a in
their name so we already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see it has
Apple little banana Cherry kiwi and
mango now we want to create a new list
which has only the fruits that have the
letter A inside them so Apple would be
one of them banana would be one of them
and mango would be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few extra lines but yeah
it does it does do what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that exists as you can
see here
so I take the same
list now this is where you need to
follow so now my new list is equal to so
I'm creating a list over here as you can
see now within this list you have this
line this is what we call a list
comprehension so as you can see it says
each fruit for each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a inside each fruit and what
this each fruit is that we're checking
each object in this list one by one so
first in the first iteration each fruit
will contain the string Apple then in
the next iteration it will contain
banana and in each each iteration we're
going to check if it contains the
character a and if it does then we store
that each fruit in the new list as you
can see here so if I execute this line
you see my my result is the same I have
my whatever I want it and this was a
much cleaner way of writing uh or
creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what I'm going to do
is I am going to iterate through a
string so I have a string it can be
anything in this case I am using a
string called human
all right so I have a string called
human right now I want to store each
character of this string into a list
that we call H underscore letters so if
I use the for Loop this is how we would
do it if I execute this as you can see
the list contains H and then u m a and
then n now what if I wanted to do the
same thing but uh by using list
comprehension so what I would do is
let's create
a list over here H underscore letters
and
um so as we know let's come so our list
comprehension will uh it's it's a it's
you just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when I check what's in h
letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see I have the output as uh what I
needed so this is a much cleaner way
let's go through some more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we've already seen
uh one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's uh look at an example where we
use the uh this comprehension with an if
statement
so what if I wanted to store say the
first 10 even numbers so this would so
this is an example that I'll be using so
in my list I want to store the first 10
even numbers so this would be a way to
do it
so I have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is X is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until 98 that
actually take it from 0 1 2 3 4 until
19. so when we do range 20 we're
creating an iterate in iterable where uh
we're going to Loop through our iterate
through the value of 0 to 19. so if I if
I do this and this what this statement
does is basically uh it checks if it's
divisible by two
so if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number and if this
condition is met if this condition is
met that means we store uh the X into
our number list so let's see what
happens when we execute this
should contain uh 0 2 4 6 until 18. so
this is the first 10 even numbers as you
can see so this is an eighth way of
using IF statement we can also use an if
else statement
so what if I I'm checking um each okay
so I'm going to create another list and
in this list I'm going to basically see
if um
each of my num numbers either even or
odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so I want it to be even
in case
the I that I'm checking I being every
number between so let's say the first 10
natural numbers as I said
let's check if um if it is divisible by
well if it is divided by 2 of course
it's going to be even right else
we say that it is odd
and then we checked for I in say the
first let's say the first 20.
okay
so now when we do this let me check oh
he check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even or is basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is uh an example
where we used the list comprehension
with if else statements so another neat
thing that we can do with the list
comprehensions is that we can use it
along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double X where we Define
this double X this double function to
take an input to take an argument X and
what we return is the square of the
argument so let's use this in uh in our
left list comprehension so what we do
over here is that we are we're checking
what we're doing is for every X bit in
range 10. so we're taking the value of 0
1 2 3 until 9 and we're passing it to
this function double X and we're going
to get the square of them and we're
going to store that in a in a list as
you can see here let's call this list X
so just call this list uh let's call it
y so now let's see what's in y and we
check it should be 0 1 4 9 and so on so
wait this let's check again does this
Square now this is actually two times so
let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see zero one four nine for
the first 10 numbers 10 natural numbers
now what I've shown you is obviously
less comprehension but we can also do
set and dictionary comprehensions in
fact set comprehensions work exactly the
same way as list comprehensions but the
only difference is the set
comprehensions will make sure that there
are no duplicates inside the set so you
can't have like duplicate items which
you can in the case of list
comprehensions so let's uh let's like
let's take a look at an example so here
in this example what we're doing is
we're going to check so we have this
string that we're storing in the
variable text and the string is
something like live finds a way so
whatever this is now what we're going to
do is we're going to
iterate through this string character by
character and we're going to check if uh
there are we're going to check for
vowels essentially so uh are going to
see if the character a e i o or U is
present in the string and if it is we
will pass it into our set now if you if
you look you will find there are
multiple eyes right and there are
multiple A's as well so if we did this
through a list comprehension each time
that we find found find a vowel it would
be added to our list but since this is a
set and sets do not allow duplicates so
you will only have one copy or one
particular object for each of the
verbals so uh of course now uh set
comprehension is defined using curly
braces so let's keep that in mind so now
if I check what's in this I will see a e
i and U even though there are multiple
A's or multiple E's or I's and U's since
this is a set we don't have duplicate
copies of any copies of any of these uh
so this was just a small example for uh
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and if
we call it discrete dictionary
comprehensions the only thing that we
have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this so let's let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except in this case we will Define
a key and that separates it from a set
comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
I'm checking I'm going through the a
list of numbers from 0 to 9 right so
what the range 10 function does and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to create a
key which is going to be like 0 1 2 3
and the value of each key would be H
squared as you can see here I'm doing I
times I or just to
make a little more clearer as you can
see I'm doing I squared over here for
every value from 0 to 9. so what I
should get is like a dictionary where
the first key is 0 and the value of that
key should be 0 as well because 0 square
is zero then for one it will be one and
then for two four and then three nine
four sixteen so let's see what happens
as you can see here this is the the
result that I wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to list comprehensions
um so it's obviously An Elegant way uh
to Define and create list based on
existing lists uh it's more Compact and
faster than normal functions and Loops
but we should also keep in mind that we
shouldn't write like very complicated uh
list comprehensions because the idea of
a list comprehension is to be user
friendly and also it's important to note
that every list comprehension can be
written in the form of a loop but uh
every Loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember in
this video we will be learning about the
concept of regular Expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example if you see this
example here you can see a symbol called
the carrot followed by P and then five
periods then an n and a dollar sign and
what this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with B ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for a five
character string that starts with a ends
with s and has three characters in
between now if we had to match this with
this string with these strings as an uh
as uh i o test strings the first one
would not match because it's a three
letter string and we're looking for a
five character string the second one
would match because it's a five
character string that ends with an s
starts with an A and has three
characters in between this will not
match because whatever pattern would do
is it would find the first s and it
would find that the string itself starts
with an A and it would say okay there
are only two characters between this
first s and this a and it would assume
that this is actually just a four
character string to actually Identify
two consecutive s's we would have to do
something special and what we would have
to do is what we will see later on so
again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a uh is
perfectly fine when we're searching for
this and it will also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in Python can be
imported using this statement import re
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do a pattern recognition
character recognitions and to identify
different sequence of characters in our
strings let's try to understand a bit
more in depth about regular Expressions
now so what you're seeing here is one
variable call pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex and
another variable that stores our test
string called abis now what we're going
to do is we're going to use the match
method of this module re and we're going
to check whether this pattern
um or whatever we are trying to search
using this reg X is in fact does it
match with our test string and what
we're trying to look for is if you see
here very similar to what I just showed
you a 5 character string that starts
with a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it induced
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if I execute
this and this is what it does
now if I change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here now let's try to
understand what exactly do we mean by uh
when we use these different cert these
special symbols like for example this
carrot or this dollar symbol
um these are by the way known as meta
characters and now we're going to look
into all the uh or most of the different
meta characters that are used in regex
so put to put it simply meta characters
are simply characters that are
interpreted in a special way by the
regex search engine now here's a list of
meta characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets squareback is
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match some combination of a b and c it
can be one a two A's Three B's four C's
we are not looking at a specific pattern
we just want to know if a b and c exists
in any form in our string so if we used
it on a the string a simply we would
find one match because the letter a is
found here AC would match twice because
we have a and C present here in this
string Hey Jude we will have no matches
because a b and c none of them are found
here and in this weird string we will
have actually one two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a a b or c
now let's use re dot match to do to
actually search for this and to uh see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string I'm going to test this
I'm going to match whether my pattern
that um a any of a b and c is it
actually found in this so let's see what
happens when I use Rd dot match for this
so the the format uh the syntax is
simply the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this as you can see it's
none even though you might be wondering
like I can see an a over here I can see
a c over here re dot match actually
gives us the result none
now
if I try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film Titanic was at least in 1998
what I'm saying here is all film Titanic
was released in 1998. now let's see if
the r match works or not
as you can see it actually does give a
return When I execute this it returns as
an object called re.match object with a
span 0 1. the span zero one is basically
telling us that we have found a match
between the zeroth and the first
character which is basically this
character a which is what it has found
and it's saying that the match is indeed
the character a uh from amongst these
options
so what this is basically telling us and
what this means actually is that the re
dot match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter A
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re dot search as you can see here
the re dot search method will actually
check the whole string and it will
return us the first instance where it
finds a match now let's see this is a
test string now and we're searching
again for AR we're searching for a b and
c any any of these in our test string
but we're going to use re.search and not
match so now if you see it returns us
when I execute this it returns us a
match object again but this time it's
saying the span of 9 and 10. now the
spine panel 9 and 10 actually exists
over here this is the ninth character
and a itself is the 10th character over
here so what this basically is telling
us that the 10th character is where we
found a match which was the letter A
which was the first instance of either A
or B or C in this whole string and this
is basically how re.search works it will
not only search the beginning of the
string but it will search the whole
string and return us the first instance
wherever we find now what if we wanted
to find out all the instances wherever a
b and c were found and not just the
first instance well in that case we
would be using the method find all over
here so when we use find all it will
actually return us each and every case
where it found a b or c and you might
not it won't tell you the exact position
but it will tell you like
um so if I execute this you can see it
gives us a a list with AAC a and a and
what this basically means is it was
looking for the characters A or B or C
and it found a first and hence this for
the first item in the list then it found
a c and then it found two is
successfully so this is exactly this is
actually how find all works where it
will actually find all the instances of
our regex pattern now that you've seen
how the square brackets work and how the
re dot search and re dot uh match and re
dot find all methods work now we're
going to go through all the other meta
characters that we saw above so the
period now period matches any single
character except the new line new line
is basically slash n or a break now if
you look at this picture what it's going
to do is
um a this expression basically saying
that uh do we have
um two characters like sets of two
characters in our string so this is a
single character string and obviously a
single character string is not a double
character string and this expression
this double dot is basically asking us
do we have two characters present in our
string so if I had to match it with this
a it will obviously be a no match
because a is one character if we checked
it with AC it is a match because A and C
are two characters a c and d will also
give us only one match because it will
find AC and then it will leave d as a
single character but when we check AC c
d and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because it will
consider a and C as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches So
Below is basically what we are doing
basically the same thing we're just
using Rd dot search for each of these
different examples so if I if you see
when I use find all on acde and when I'm
searching for a two character match you
will see that it will return me a c and
d e as you can see here and similarly
for something like this it will return
me again uh whatever like two character
patterns it finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the correct
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the uh one is checking if a is the
beginning of a string and the other one
will check if a uh
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's the only the character a
and it will match here as well because
this string starts with a but it will
not match here because this string
starts with B now if I look at this
particular expression you can see that
um this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because a does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
A because it's not followed by a b so
out here is basically us using the re
dot search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples so this is going to
check basically if so this expression
will check if the string ends with a so
this uh this string is basically the
character a so it will match this also
ends with a so it will match and this
particular string does not end with a so
it will not match and we are going to do
that using the re dot search over here
so as you can see it finds a match in
the first character itself here in this
case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns I say none another example
is of the meta characters is star so
this is the symbol for star and uh this
is what the star basically is used is
for checking if there are zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it so now if you see here what this
will check for is is there any form of M
and A
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that the N has to
follow the a in this case so let's look
at these examples and what will happen
so if I checked it with M and N this is
actually a match because n is followed
by zero occurrences of M and A which is
if it might seem a little weird but it
is technically the truth because uh the
the star symbol checks for not doesn't
check for the Existence it just checks
for with n occurs it must occur after an
A or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the N occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so M A and N is obviously fine m a uh M
Triple A N is also fine because n
follows an A and there's an M here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have M and A and we have
an N you see the N is immediately
followed by an i is n follows an I
immediately or the N is preceded by an I
immediately and this is a no match
because our the strict condition in the
search is that n must uh proceed in a if
the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the re dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the Rd dot search as you
can see here finally we have the next
meta character which is the plus symbol
yes so the plus symbol matches one or
more occurrences of the pattern left to
it now this is very similar to what we
saw earlier in terms of the star except
now in the plus the key difference is
we're looking for one or more
occurrences instead of zero or more
occurrences that we were looking for in
the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now we need what is there to the left of
the plus sign a zero uh no occurrence of
it will not be allowed or will not cause
a match so let's see now what we're
going to do here we're going to use the
same expression except we're going to
replace the star with the plus sign so
now what we're going to say is okay we
need M and A at least one occurrence
followed by an N the all of these
conditions have to be met so again if
you took the first example M and N this
time it will be a no match because there
is no occurrence of an a over here for
preceding the N so it's a no match M A
and N is a match because well this is
per this is perfectly fine M Triple A
and N is also perfectly fine but if you
look at m a i and N much like earlier
the N is uh preceded by an i and not an
A so there is no match and again woman
is perfectly fine and we basically
execute the same thing through the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the question
mark the question mark symbol matches 0
or 1 occurrences under the pattern to
the left of it so let's see what this
does so now we saw the star the star
which was zero or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it we saw the
plus which is one or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it now we
will see the question mark which is 0 or
1 only 0 or only one and not zero or
more of one or more which was the
previous cases only zero and one or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it again we're going to see the same
expression except we're going to replace
the meta character with the question
mark So now let's see what what happens
when we match so if you see here M and N
is a match because there is zero
occurrence of a and one occurrence of M
preceding n so this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
occurrence of A and M and then it's
followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a
which is followed by an N we're only
looking for 0 or 1. this again main will
be a no match for the same reasons that
we have already gone through and women
will be a match again for the same
reasons
and we read through the same things
using the search function in this piece
of code the next meta character is the
braces character now the braces
character is interesting because what
we're going to do is we're going to see
if there are so uh this is the typical
Syntax for abrasives is an uh brace
followed by some integer n comma integer
M and then close braces so what this
means is we're looking for at least n
and at most M repetitions of the pattern
left of the braces let's see through an
example if you see this expression we're
looking for at least two and at most
three occurrences of this the character
a in our test strings so let's see what
happens in the first case we have no
matches in this case because this part
of the string contains only one a and
even this part of the string only
contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three this part
will contain one match the second the
second example because the second part
of the string actually contains two is
for one two
and in the third example you can see
both the strings actually contain
matches so we get two matches because as
you can see here there's two A's here
followed by Three A's here now when we
look at this particular string let's
look at what happens now so what we're
going to find is that this thing is
perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the search
engine is going to recognize is these
first three is and it's going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and I already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a in the
search it will just look at the first
three and say okay there are uh Three
A's and my my match is fine so again
there are two matches in this case again
if you're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred in each of these
lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is 0-9 now a dash symbol is
valid in Python using regex because what
this basically tells it is that it's
looking for either 0 1 2 3 4 so on until
nine basically any of the digits you're
looking for any of the digits from 0 to
9 and we are going to check if at least
2 and at most four occurrences of digits
if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string you can see it will find one
match this basically this particular
part of the string where it says one two
three so this is uh three occurrences of
Digit so it's fine now when we look at
this whole string 12 and whatever this
is you will see this will not find a
match here this obviously will not
because these are characters but if you
look at over this part it will find
matches in the in terms of the first
four and then seven and three the next
two one and two again there are no
matches because there's only single
occurrences of digits we're looking for
at least two and at most four so if I
use a find all
you will see like whatever it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
return me one two and three as you can
see here but now if you look at this
test string it's going to return me 12
it's going to return Me 3 4 5 and 6.
it's going to return Me 3 4 1 and 2 but
not seven because we are looking for at
least two and then it's going to return
me four five six and seven followed by
eight and eight as you can see in this
list over here now if we use curly
braces with only one digit it's
basically telling the search engine that
we want exactly so many repetitions of
the preceding uh whatever expression
that we have so when we do this example
for uh for example we're basically
saying that we want X
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times in our
particular expression and then it should
be followed by an X again which will not
match in this case because there are
only two dashes and it will match in
this case because there are exactly
three dashes and it will again not not
match in this case because there are
four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object Maps followed by none
next we move on to the alternation
um the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of A and B so a should be followed
by a b and basically this pattern has to
keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here we will have
a match because we at least find an a
even though there is no B but this is
still considered as because we did find
an a at least over here we'll have three
matches because we have a followed by a
b followed by an a again
so uh if we did a regular expression for
this we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that I want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what I want is some form
of a following B following C some sort
of alternation between a b and c so this
part as you can see here is kept in a
parenthesis because I want this whole
condition to basically occur before I
find an x and z so let's look at what
happens here in the first case we don't
have a match because uh the this
basically this parenthesis condition is
not being met we x and z is preceded by
a space or basically the A and B is
preceded is followed by a space so there
is this space didn't occur we would
actually find a match as you can see in
the next example here you can see A and
B occur basically this uh initial
condition is met followed by x and z so
then this way a one match so it's fine
for us now if you look at this Society
mode a trickier one what you can see is
we have two matches in this case first
in a followed by x and z and then we
have C A and B now this is perfectly
fine because we we are looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things we're looking for
some form of alternation of these things
followed by an x and z and we can get
that over here we get B followed by an x
and z so you will get two matches in
this case now let's go through the
concept of grouping constructs now that
we've seen many meta characters you've
seen how parenthesis Works let's look at
grouping constructs so grouping
constructs break up a regex in Python
into sub expressions or groups and this
serves two purposes one is a grouping
part which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional meta characters apply to
the entire group as a unit and then
there's the capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for uh as you know a plus looks
for one or more occurrence so this will
basically check for one or more
occurrence of the the character are only
because there's no parenthesis as in
this example so this plus is next to an
r and it's going to check for basically
whether one or more occurrence of R
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put B A and R in a parenthesis
followed by plus it will actually check
for the entire string bar and it will
check one or more occurrences of bar
together so if you look at these two
examples when we use this uh on these
examples you can see that these are fine
like these matches are fine but if I
used this parenthesis then these would
be the acceptable matches and like b a
triple R would not be a match if I use
parenthesis as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parent thesis work so let's look
at some other examples so what this will
do is Foo has to be optionally followed
by bar and bar must exist over together
and um this is because we have a
question mark here this question mark
symbol tells us that it should be zero
or one occurrences
similarly this particular completed
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences or whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing is followed
by a plus so we're looking for this
whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it c o w is simply just c
o w we're looking for this pattern and
this is going to check for 0 or 1
occurrence of cow because of the
existence of the question mark for
preceded by the parenthesis
in this video we're going to continue
our discussion on regular Expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
Expressions let's continue our
discussion with special sequences now in
an earlier video on strings you might
have encountered what is an escape
sequence and how we use the backslash
character to generate these Escape
sequences and an escape sequence is
basically if you remember
something that we use to either
gives a certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call Meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital A which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string so out here if you can see we
are checking if the word d is present in
these two strings so we would get a
match in the first case over here
because this starts with the word the
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it for the same thing using the
find all function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find the in the beginning of the string
in the second case we get us empties
list because this string does not start
with the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash B small B now this is used to
match if specified characters at the
beginning or at the end of a word so
when you use backslash small B and then
you follow it up with whatever you're
looking for it would look for the that
particular those particular characters
or that pattern if it exists in the
beginning of a word in a string so if
you look at the first example it starts
with f double O and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double O so it will also
match however in this string which is
very similar to the second one we don't
have a space between a and F and it's
basically one word so this does not
start with f double O but it actually
starts with afo and it won't match as
you can see here now similarly if we
wanted to check if something exists in
the back of a string at the end of a
string we type what we want to search
for first and then we follow it with a
backslash small B and then if you see
here it will match in this first case it
will match in the second case because
this part of the string ends with f
double O but it will not match in this
case because well we remove the space so
now this whole thing becomes a uh the
string that we're looking for and it
does not end with FW anymore this is
basically us just checking in through
the find all function now the next SK
the next special sequence that we will
be looking at is the slash capital B
which is basically the opposite of what
we just saw this matches only if the
specified characters are not at the
beginning or the end of a word so if you
see here this is checking if F double O
is not at the beginning of these strings
so in this case there'll be a no match
in this case also it'll be a no match
and this third case there will be a
match similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with a particular
string we would type that whatever
pattern we're looking for followed by a
backslash capital B and then we can use
the find all function to generate us
lists wherever we find such objects find
such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small D and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and we did a search or a find all or
a match it would look for any of the
digits between 0 and 9. so a similar
thing can be done using a special
sequence backslash small D so as you can
see there will be three matches in this
case because one two and three digits
exist whereas in this case for the word
python there will be no matches so these
are certain examples where we are doing
the same thing using the backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital D and this is just
basically the opposite it matches for
any non-decimal digits it's also
equivalent to typing a carrot inside uh
square brackets with 0-9 which if you
remember from the previous video is
basically asking us to check for
anything that is not the digit 0 to 9.
so this is basically we're going to
check in these two strings if there is
no digits no non-decimal digits so if
you see here we will we will find three
matches a b and the uh double double
inverted commas and in the second string
we will find no matches because this is
fully just digits next we have backslash
small s now this matches where a string
contains any white space character so
this is equal to doing a check for all
of these so this is like backslash small
T is a check for tab space backslash
small N is a check for break line and
then backslash R backslash F backslash V
uh are their own uh checks for different
sorts of white space characters that you
can see by just looking it up honestly
but yeah so if you simply do a backslash
s it would actually be the equivalent of
searching for any of these uh White
space white space characters that we
generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string you can see
that there is one space over here so it
will match it will give us one match
because there is one white space which
is just the normal space here and in the
second example there is no match because
there is no white space here
similarly slash capital S now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash T slash n slash r
slash F slash V in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital S now we're
looking at a space b so over here if you
see it will match for all the non-spaces
so it's going to match for a and b so
we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty spring is
basically a white space character on its
own so this would be this will give us a
no match so the next special sequence
that we're going to look at is the
backslash small W uh this matches any
alphanumeric character which is the
equivalent of doing a to z in small and
then capital A to Z and 0 to 9 for and
also an underscore check in square
bracket packets it's important to note
that the underscore is considered an
alphanumic character hence why we
included over here but yeah this is this
uh backslash W uh small W which
basically checks for any alphanumeric
character and matches it in a string so
if you see in this first case
um it will find three matches at one two
and also add the letter c these others
are not alphanumeric characters whereas
in this string none of these are
alphanumic characters we will get no
match again much like the other examples
there is a capital there's a backslash
capital W which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character and it's the
equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a preceded by a carrot sign so if
you see here we have the string where we
have a bunch of characters well yeah
only one of them this uh this percentage
symbol is a non-alphanumeric character
so we will get much one match over here
but in this case in this string python
we will get no matches because they are
all alphanumeric characters which is
doing the same thing here with a bunch
of different examples using the find all
function now the backslash capital Z
matches if the specified characters are
at the end of a string now don't confuse
this with the backslash small B because
the back is a small B checks for a
string and it checks each and every word
in the string individually and checks if
so if any of the words ends with a
particular thing or or starts with a
particular thing but it checks each word
individually but in this case the
backslash capital Z will check the
string only and not each word so if you
see the difference here in an um when
you use Capital backslash capital Z it
will match in this first example but it
won't match for the next two but if you
use the backslash small B over here it
would actually match and not only in the
first example here but it will also
match in the second example because it
would check this word individually and
it will find out that yeah there is a
match here as well so it would actually
match in the second example as well in
this video we will be covering the topic
of closures now before we understand
what a closure is we have to understand
what is a nested function and non-local
variables now a function which is inside
another function is known as a nested
function nested functions are able to
access variables of the enclosing scope
so if I Define this function called
outer function where I pass some
argument called text and I store that in
a variable called text again and if I
create a function within this collinear
function and I want to print whatever
this variable is in text when I execute
this it will be able to access this
variable because it's within the
enclosing scope so if I set out a
function here this gets stored in the
variable text and then the inner
function will print that variable which
is basically the string here as you can
see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here
inner function is treated as a nested
function which uses text this this
variable text as the non-local variable
now a closure is a function object that
remembers values in enclosing Scopes
even if they are not present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment it's a
mapping basically that Associates each
free variable of the function which are
basically variables that are used
locally but are defined in enclosing
scope with the value or reference to
which the name was bound when the
closure is created a closure which is uh
which unlike a plane function allows the
function to access those captured
variables through the closures copies of
their values or references even when the
function is invoked outside the scope so
let's look at an example to emphasize on
what uh what was just said so again I've
created I've defined this function out a
function where I'm doing the same thing
now I've defined the same inner function
where I'm going to print the same thing
now it's very important that when I
return over here what I'm going to
return is inert function but it's not
going to be a function call this is
important to create our closure so we
return in our function but with without
um using the call as we do over here
now what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure where the inner function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now I'm going to store this outer
function in an object called my in a
variable called my function now when I
call this my function you can see there
there'll be two things that are
happening here so once I've defined this
and I've executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed and then I'm
storing it to this but because I've done
return inner function without
parenthesis I've created a closure
basically and this closure allows the
inner function to remember the values
that were stored in text at any point at
and at every Point even after the
execution of this fun time so when I
execute this again for the second time
over here it will remember the value
that was stored in the variable text
which is hey which was which was given
over here
that's why you see when I execute it for
the second time over here the first time
being in this line when I'm storing it
in my function when I execute in the
second time again it will give me the
result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
functional function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we Define
called add X and Y which will return X
Plus Y and the subtract function which
will subtract X and Y so now we're going
to execute these once we are going to
execute the add over here and add logger
and we're going to execute the subtract
function and we're going to store it in
sublogger so technically we have already
executed these two functions but now
since I've created an X an enclosure
basically uh if you see here this is the
enclosure that I have created now what
happens is
when I access this function from outside
its initial scope which is basically
over here this was the initial Scope
when I access it outside you will see
that it is it still has access to these
variables X and Y so if you see here I I
first of all I've allowed this uh this
the enclosing function to accept uh
arguments of any numbers so I can pass X
Y I can pass x y z also but if you see
here I only have a thing for X and Y so
when I want to access any value of X and
Y even after the execution of this code
initially I have access to these
variables X and Y and that is because
I've created a closure out of that so if
you see if I do add logger 3 and 3 over
here I'm able to get the result 6. if I
do add logger four and five I'm able to
get the result 9 similarly for
subtraction logger 10 and 5 I will get 5
here and 20 and 10 I'll get 10 here and
I can keep doing this I can keep saying
ad logger in fact if I say 4 and 7 so if
I executed this and now I'm going to say
let's say for example add logger if I
set 4 and 7 here
so this still has access to my variables
X and Y because I've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if I
did sub logger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 like 30 minus 15. so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again I have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we will
be learning about the concept of Lambda
functions now a Lambda function in
Python is an anonymous function without
a name we usually use Lambda functions
whenever we want to create a a function
type object for for a short period of
time a Lambda function is defined using
the Lambda keyword like a normal
function is defined using the def
keyword we Define a Lambda function
using the Lambda keyword also the Lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
Lambda function like a sort of a a
temporary function object that you
create whenever you want to perform a
particular task or object but you don't
want to give it a name or you don't want
to define a full full-blown function and
give it a name like that so over here
I'm going to give you an example of a
Lambda function let's say that this
Lambda function takes in let's call it X
and so you define the function let's
call it X let's call it a Lambda
function using this keyword now we want
say two parameters right
by saying say A and B or two arguments
in A and B so we're going to pass two
arguments A and B whenever we call use
this function and we're going to perform
some sort of an expression now let's
write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
you just use the colon now over here we
have our expression so let's call it a
plus b so now we've created a Lambda
function called X where uh we will pass
two arguments and the result will be the
expression a plus B A Plus A and B being
the arguments we pass
so now let's print the result of
um let's say we pass one and three so
now we should get the result 4 right
because a plus b is equal to 4 so we
passed a as 1 B is 3. now let's execute
this as you can see the result is for
similarly you can pass any number of
arguments so we want to call some
function X let's say Lambda function
maybe say um a
B and C the same and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do uh when we check the
result let's say we're doing the product
of two four and six so this should be 48
and when you execute this you get 48 as
you can see here so these are two simple
examples of a Lambda function
now I could have done this
um in a different way where I could have
defined some function X and over here I
Define that it takes in three parameters
and then you can Define
um some say return the function
basically returns you a product B
product C but many a times you don't
need to define a full function called X
you don't you don't want to assign some
function with this name you just want to
create a temporary or a short time
Anonymous function with some name just
to perform a simple expression and in
that case we can use Lambda functions uh
that's an example by the way you can use
Lambda functions in multiple places so
let's uh move on now
now uh for the sake of this video what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
how the sorted function works and we're
going to learn how the Lambda function
uses this sorted function how they work
together so this will give you a clearer
understanding of how we use the Lambda
function in our code so to start off
sorted function returns a sorted list
from the items in an interval so you can
have a bunch of for example numbers and
the sorted function by default will give
you will return you the list of numbers
in an ascending order of course you can
also using a parameter called reverse
you can you can you can return a list of
numbers in the descending order you can
also do this for Strings I mean
characters so if you give it a bunch of
characters say a e f g in the uh in the
alphabet it will give you if you use a
sorted function it will give you the
characters it will return it in an
ascending or descending order depending
on the parameter you give so basically
this uh the sorted function the syntax
is you use the keyword sorted then you
pass the iterable which is basically
some some list or some Tuple then you
give it a key so this key sometimes we
don't need to give by default if the
iterable is does not contain um
multiple uh multiple items per object
for like if it's not a tuple of multiple
objects if it's not a list of tuples for
example you don't need to give it a key
if it's a simple list of numbers you
don't necessarily need to give a key if
you want to sort it but yeah a key is
basically the parameter which we use to
tell the sorted function that we want to
sort based on something which is going
to be the key in this case finally the
third parameter is reverse which
basically just tells us that if we want
to sort in the default ascending order
or if we say reverse true then we will
sort in the descending order now let's
look at some examples so I have this
list over here
and I'm going to print this list
so this list is obviously a bunch of
vowels
e-a-u-o-i and this is not in the
ascending order of the the alphabet
right like you we know it as a e i o u
if I print the sorted form of this list
it should give me a e i o u a list with
a e i o in the ascending order
sorry yeah
so now as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um I gave it a
string a string as you know is a
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if I use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these
um individual characters like p y t h o
and n but in the order that we want it
to be in which is the ascending order of
course so if I print this you can see it
returns me the list with each character
in the order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before H that's because this is in
uppercase so what this does is first it
uh sorts all the uppercase characters
since there's only one so it just places
in the first uh object of this list and
then it sorts all the lowercase
characters that you see here so yeah
moving on now now what if we wanted to
say um sort this in descending order so
we have this list and now we want to
sort this in a descending order so in
that case we have to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true so once we do this now when we
execute this you can see we have the
return as the same list but in the
opposite order so that's how the reverse
parameter works now let's uh try to
understand how we use the key function
or the key parameter in the sorted
function now of course if you if you
want to sort something based on some key
that we want to Define we use the key
parameter so let's take an example now
so in this example what we have done is
I've defined this function called take
second so what this does is it it simply
it takes the second element of a list of
tuples so what is this list of tupus
well this is random you can see this
random this is a list of tuples so this
is one Tuple this is the next Tuple and
what I'm going to do is in this example
I'm going to create a key out of every
second element in each Tuple so I'm
going to create a key out of 20 40 10
and 13 and based on these in an
ascending order I will sort this whole
list so my what my result should be is
that since the smallest of the uh every
second object in these tuples is 10 so
this will be my first object in the my
sorted list then it should be the one
with 13 because this is the next highest
number so then this will be the next
object similarly this will be the next
object then this will be the whole next
object so you see I'm using every second
element of the Tuple as my key and for
that to create a key basically
um I'm creating this function which will
basically return every
um it will iterate through all of these
and it will return uh each of these
second elements so
um let's actually uh let's actually do
this now so what I have here is I am
going to create a sorted list which is
going to use a sorted function on this
iterable which is a bunch which is a
list of tuples it's called random now my
key is going to be take second so this
sorted function is actually very dynamic
in the sense
um I don't I don't exactly have to
create a list directly each of these
objects present in the tuples I just
have to Define if I can even pass a
function in the parameter for key and it
will apply this function on the interval
that we pass over here which is random
namely and it will use this function to
generate Keys uh generate a key out of
each second element and based on that it
will do the sorted it will perform the
sorted function so now
if I check
what's my sorted list
you will see
that as I had mentioned now it's using
the second object so the second uh each
each second object of the Tuple as the
key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we've
used a key to do the Sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple Keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this uh we have this
um some some list where a bunch of names
a bunch of tuples you can see right
tuples with three objects each within it
each first one is always always a string
denoting someone's name some students
name
um the second is the marks out of 100
and the third is their age so what we
have here is what we want to do is we
want to sort this uh these tuples uh in
the order of first marks and in case the
marks are clashing or they are the same
basically we will sort by the age so
what we want to do is we want to First
sort by these marks as you can see here
but in case the Clash for example like
say this 75 and 75 they're the same
marks in that case we want to sort it by
the age which is 12 and 20 which is
different so in this case we're going to
use two keys one the first key will be
given the highest priority and then if
there is a clash then we use the second
key so how do we do this now let's
define some function like uh how we
Define this take second function here
this will be our function that we will
pass to the key this function basically
what it does is it gives us uh who has
the highest marks now since we are
creating and since the key works in an
ascending order so um the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
gets returned right so what we're going
to do is we're going to return the error
which is basically the difference
between
um 100 which is the total marks and the
marks that student gets so this is how
we obtain a ascending order in our list
which is what we which which basically
is what we want because we want the
highest marks to be first so we do 100
minus item one item one is basically the
first object or whatever it triple we
pass in this case it would be the the
first objects of each Tuple which is the
marks secondly We performed age age is
the item two which is yeah each second
object of each Tuple now what we return
in this function is uh like this is
going to be our key now a list of errors
and there is a list of age error being
the marks error the difference between
100 and the marks you obtain so now what
it's going to do is it's going to take
the marks as the first key and the age
as the second key when we pass this to a
sorting function
so if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print if you see
we get let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is we have the highest marks
first then the second then the third but
if you see here there's a clash this guy
and this guy have the same Mark 75 so
now what you want to do is the guy who
has a younger age should be in the first
in the object so that is how this has
happened because we passed two keys
error and the age so when The Clash in
error key happened we went to the ah key
and then we did ascending order on that
and then finally the rest of the objects
that you can see here so now that we
have seen how the sorted function works
now let's look at how the Lambda
function Works using this sorted
function which was the main goal of this
video right so let's see
so now some of you might have figured
out where this Lambda function will be
used right so whenever we were using the
key in the sorted function we had to
define a function and then we would pass
that function as the key so as some of
you may have figured this out what we're
going to do using the Lambda function is
we're going to skip that process of
defining a function with a new name and
all that and we're going to pass a
Lambda function we're going to use a
Lambda function as the key so let's see
how we do it so initially what we've
done is we've created this list this
list is a list of dictionaries that you
can see so this first object is a
dictionary second object is a dictionary
each dictionary contains two keys the
name and the age and the values are
something like nandini the values for
age is like 20 20 and 19. so we have
three dictionaries in a list so what
we're going to do is we want to print
what we what we want to do with this we
want to print the these objects or these
dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20. so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied on this list so this is
awaitable now if you see here in the key
the key parameter we don't we don't
predefine a function and pass it over
here instead we use the Lambda and this
Lambda function is defined in such a way
so we say Lambda it will take one
argument I and then it will return
basically the age index for some I and
this I is we we're going to presume an i
to be some sort of an iterable which has
an index called age and which is uh
which is the case in our case right we
have a bunch of dictionaries where there
is a key in each of these dictionaries
called age so we're going to use that
and now we are going to ask like what is
I well when we use the Lambda function
in the sorted function this I will
basically be each object that we get
when we iterate upon this list so we're
going to iterate first on this so it's
going to take this dictionary and is
going to search for the age then it's
going to take this it's going to search
for the age then it's going to take this
and it's going to search for the age and
each of the time it will pull out what
is the value for each of these age
keywords or these age indexes or age
keys and out of these objects so 20 20
and 19 or these values we're going to
create a key with which we're going to
sort each object in this whole list okay
so this is how the Lambda function will
work here so let's do this so as you can
see our sorted list now contains this
object first because a 19 is small stage
and then this and this now you might see
that there are two twenties so how do we
control which one comes first well by
default it will um that it will just uh
give us the result in the way we passed
it in the original list so since nandini
came before manjit in the result also
nandini will come before majeed but what
if he wanted to sort it even more what
if we want to sort it in such a way that
first we go by age and the second key
will tell us that if there is a clash in
ages we have to go alphabetically by the
name so in this case we will create a
second key and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the Lambda will again take one parameter
which is I which is going to be each
itro which which is going to be each
object in this iterable list and we're
going to take two keys so the first key
will be the H key and the second key
will be the name so it will first sort
on age and then on name so now if you
see
um the result should be that manjit will
come before nandini even though the ages
are 20 because M comes before n in the
alphabet as you can see this is the
result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but in a descending order all we have to
do is after this key parameter we have
to give another parameter called reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
it'd be more clear
now if I execute this basically this
whole uh whatever result we get will be
backwards now
oh wait I did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we execute this you will see
nandini comes first manjit comes second
and then nickel comes third because
we've done the reverse I will use the
reverse keyword as true reverse
parameter is true in this video we will
be covering the topics of map filter and
reduce functions in Python now python
provides several functions that enable
functional approach to programming and
since functional programming is all
about Expressions some of these
expression oriented functions of python
are Lambda functions list comprehensions
map filter map filter and reduce now
we've already covered the topic of
Lambda and list comprehensions now let's
cover the topics of map filter and
reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence a
function is basically some defined some
user defined function or any function a
sequence is basically an iterable object
like a list or um a tuple for example or
a bunch of lists and tupacles as well so
let's look at an example so one of the
most common operations that we do with
something like a list is doing an
operation on each of the elements in the
list and then outputting a new list with
the the values as whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list so if what if we did the square of
all of these items in this list and we
you want to create a list based on that
so we can basically iterate through it
and we can do a square function and then
append those values to a new list called
squared and when we do this for example
over here you can see when we print
squared
we should get the list of whatever
Square values we have for the original
list but this is uh slightly a bit
tedious and what if we had a method that
or a
what if we had a a technique wherein we
could um
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of applying
whatever operations we want to do on
each element of a sequence so as this is
where the map function comes in use so
let's look at how we use the map
function over here so if you look at
this I have defined a square function so
the square function basically returns or
takes an argument X and Returns the
square of it and I have a map function
which takes the square function as one
of the arguments and the I the list or
an iterable as the second argument so
this map function creates a map object
if you see here so let's just do it one
by one so I'm creating my list and I'm
going to create my function called
Square and I'm going to
send this to the map function so I'm
sending this uh the first argument as
the function that I want to do and the
second argument as the list that I want
to apply it on now let's list out all
the items that are in this map object
so if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for Loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here I found a very neat way of
passing a function at an iterable and
using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable so as you've seen we
basically passed in a user defined
function and we applied it to each item
in the list then the map calls the
square function on each list item and
collects all the return values into a
new list and because map expects a
function to be passed in it also happens
to be one of the places where Lambda
functions are appearing a lot so let's
look at the an example where we do the
same operation using a Lambda function
so if you see here I have a Lambda
function where I am passing it as the
function argument and what this Lambda
function takes is some variable X or
some argument X it does its square and
it returns at X and this x is basically
going to come from each element that is
present in this list called items and
when we list down these you will see it
basically does the same thing for us it
creates this list with squared items now
we can also pass instead of passing an
interval itself we can actually pass a
sequence of functions and use the Lambda
function to perform a sequence of
functions on particular items so let's
look at a new example a slightly
different one so we're going to use a
numpy module for this don't worry we're
just using it to use the square root
function that is present in the numpy
power module
um we will be learning about number in a
later section so we're going to import
this first and now I'm going to Define
three functions cos Square Cube and
square root so once I've defined this
basically they are returning the square
the cube root uh the cube and the square
root of some integer X and now I'm going
to create a list of these functions that
you've just seen and we're going to use
a for Loop and we're going to iterate
through a range from 0 to 4. and we're
going to pass this
and we're going to say that we're going
to apply
some some function we want to apply some
function X and we want to return that
using this Lambda function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called f u n c s or funx and in
Fu and CS we have a bunch of functions
called Square Cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to R and R will take
the value 0 to 4 and now let's see when
we print this what values we get so if
you see here we get a list of square
root squares cubes and square roots for
integer 0 1 2 3 and 4. so this is
another way of using the map function
and Lambda functions together to apply
multiple different operations to a bunch
of iterables
now for our next example what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
function that basically what it does is
it creates the uppercase of some string
that we pass to it right so that's what
we've done here in this function called
two uppercase so if let's first Define
this function now we have a print
function basically which is going to
print each object in a particular which
is going to prevent each element of a
particular object and it's going to at
the end of it and the end of printing
we're going to give a small space for
printing a new line basically so let's
create this also this print it editor
object now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a string with the
letters a b and c to this function and
we're going to map and we're going to
apply the uppercase function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically a sequence of one
character string a one character string
B and C so we're going to so we can pass
a string as a as an iterable to the map
function because it will apply the
operations on each of these characters
so let's see what happens when we do the
uppercase function uh we apply the upper
uppercase function using the map using
mapping to this string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with a capital a capital B and capital c
as we had expected because we have
applied the list function to the map
object now in The Next Step what we're
going to do is we're going to do a very
similar thing we're just going to
instead of Simply mapping and creating a
list out of it we're going to store the
map object in a variable called map
iterator we're going to print what type
of object it is and then we're going to
print out each of the elements using the
print iterator function that we defined
here so let's do this now if you see the
class the type of object is of class map
and the objects elements inside the
object are a b and c Moving On Let's uh
let's look at now an example where we're
going to pass multiple arguments so
instead of one iterable we're going to
pass multiple iterables now and we're
going to apply some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created Tool uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here
um yeah so if you see here I have a list
any typical and I'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that I have defined a Lambda
function as the operation that I'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments X and Y and it Returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get X and Y from so the X it gets
from this uh this sequence which is a
list and it takes y from this sequence
which is a tuple so what it's going to
do is going to take X as 1 and then Y is
5 in the first step and it's going to
return the product as five and then the
next step is going to take 2 as X and
then y as 6 and it's going to return the
product of that and we're going to get
12 and so on we're going to get 21 and
then 32.
um when we read it and this is these
values are going to be stored in the map
iterator which is a map type object and
when we use the print data function it's
basically going to print out whatever
results we got through this mapping so
let's execute this and as you can see
this is the result we got 5 12 21 and 32
which is what we wanted so the next part
the next function that we're going to
discuss is the filter function now now
if filter function is basically again it
takes two two arguments a function and a
sequence and a function basically tests
if each element of a sequence is true or
not now a sequence the sequence so this
filter function will basically take two
arguments so one is the function and
this function is basically going to test
if each element of a sequence is true or
not and it's going to take another
argument called sequence and this
argument sequence is the list or the
Tuple or basically any sequence and or
iterable that needs to be filtered and
it can be as I mentioned it can be sets
less tuples or containers of more
iterators and what this function will
return is an iterator that is already
filtered um so let's look at an example
now so we have this list R which you
generated which is basically numbers
from -5 to 4. so if I create this list
here you can see it will create a list
of minus five to four now if I wanted to
extract only the values that are lesser
than 0 well I can use a for Loop and use
a if condition to check this right so if
I did this over here you can see it
gives me it returns me some list called
result which contains only the values
lesser than zero which is basically
check through this condition what if
there was a
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we defined a function
where we are going to do the test or we
are going to create the condition and
we're going to pass this to a particular
function and then apply that particular
operation on every object of some
sequence well just like mapping we have
a filter function to do this and in this
example what we're going to use is the
Lambda function which takes an argument
X and it checks for some condition X
lesser than 0 and where it's going to
get the X from if some sequence R which
which in our case is the numbers from
minus five to four and the filter will
basically create a filter object type
which contains only the objects from r
that meet this condition that is X is
lesser than 0 and when we use the list
operation on top of it it you will see
it creates it results in a list with the
values that have met my condition so for
a second example what we're going to do
is we're going to create a list which
contains a bunch of letters and we're
going to only extract the vowels from
these bunch of letters so let's look at
what we have here we have some letters d
a t j k o p l and we only want the
vowels from this so we want to filter
only the vowels so we can use that using
the filter function by first of all
defining a function that returns true if
a check is met that um
one of uh the letter matches one of
these letters in this list called
letters and if it doesn't it returns
false so this is an urban condition that
we've created once we create this
condition uh this function that checks
this we can pass this function and the
sequence into the filter function and
then we can list out whatever we get so
you can see our filtered list contains
only a and o which is basically the only
vowels that are present in our original
list
finally we have the reduce function this
reduce function is basically a func
tools it's in the func tools module of
python 3.0 and what the reduce function
does is it applies a function of two
arguments cumulatively to the elements
of an iterable and it optionally it
starts with an initial argument and it
returns a single result so let's first
import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some list called numbers right
what if we wanted to get the sum of each
element in this list well we can iterate
over it and store it in some variable
called total in each step right
um this is what we would typically
typically do and in this step what you
can see is the loop basically iterates
over every valuable in numbers and
accumulates them in total the final
result is the sum of all the values
which is the value of 10 over here in
this example the variable total is what
we call an accumulator and we can apply
the reduce function to do the same task
so how do we do it let's first of all
create a function called my ad where
we're going to take two variables uh two
arguments and we're going to return the
sum of it okay so let's define this
function and now we have we have a list
called numbers right which contains one
two three and four now let's do reduce
my add to numbers
now when I do this when I use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad it will take
basically each and every element uh in a
sequence so it will take one and two
then add them together and then it will
create basically what it will do is it
will take one and two add them together
then we'll have three so it'll take
three and then the next element which is
3 again so it will create the sum which
is 6 and then it will take 6 and then it
will take the value 4 and it will give
us the result 10. so this is how the
reduce function would work so this is
how it will give us the result of 10. as
you can see here I've simply used I've
passed this function where I've defined
that I want two argument to be passed to
a function and then the return should be
basically the sum and then a past a
whole list of like four numbers and I've
used a reduced function to basically do
this process for four numbers in a
step-by-step manner by taking two at a
time subsequently and my result is as
you can see is correct as you can see
here
so let's use the Lambda function now to
do the same topic just do the same task
so what I'm doing now is I'm going to
define a Lambda function and that's the
function I'm going to pass to this
reduce so when I pass this Lambda
function which basically takes two two
arguments X and Y and it's going to
return the sum of that as X Plus y now
where it's going to get X and Y from is
in a very in a very neat manner so it
will take first the first two elements
one and two it will then do the sum and
we get three then it will take the same
three and then take the next object
which is three again and then give us 6
then it will take six and then the next
element which is 4 and then give us 10
and then the reduce function will output
the the single result which is 10 to us
as you can see here
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project side type of scenario which
is basically going to be a problem case
for you and it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky but
what we're going to do is we're going to
tackle a particular problem and we're
going to what I'm going to do is also
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is we have this
program that we have to write where we
compute the frequency of words that
exist in some input okay the program
should output after sorting the key
alphanumerically now this input can be
and it's basically a block of text right
so in our example we have for example if
this was our input right what we want to
see is an output which is basically
saying that the word python has appeared
say well in this example it's appeared
five times and then the word read has
appeared one time and so on and so forth
like for each of these words we want to
see um how many times have they appeared
in this project particular block of text
so let's look at a particular example
now where we have done this so let's um
let's see here
so first of all I'm going to create a
dictionary so why am I creating a
dictionary is because I'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in a block
of text as the value to that key so um
I'm going to use a sample string which
is basically this long string that you
can see here which is stored in line so
this large chunk of text is what we're
going to be analyzing so how are we
going to do this it's pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we are going
to do here is we want to
um check word by word first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is before I encountered it for
the first time then we need to store a
new key in our dictionary called
frequent table or frequency table and if
it has already if there is a key already
with that particular name then we just
want to increment the count or the value
by one so let's see how we do this over
here so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
uh what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string uh using the split function
what this will do is it will split up
the string at every white space so it
will take this as one part I'll take
this part as another part it will create
an iterable with each word as the um
each iterable object in that container
so it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then what we're
going to do is we're just going to
increase the count of the value of that
key by one but if it does not exist then
we're going to actually create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value
initialize its value to 1 button so let
me execute this
now if we want to once you've done this
we can sort it by the count of the words
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a another Tuple called sorted
tuples where we're going to use the
Lambda function out here to sort the
dictionary in terms of its values so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the key the key being the Lambda
item item with index one index one is
basically the value so a particular key
has a value so the word python appears
so many times the word say scientist
appears so many times so we're going to
check which words have the highest
number of occurrences and we're going to
sort it in a descending order so that
that is basically what the reverse is
equal to True does so when we're going
to sort this when we are going to use
the sorted function when we say reverse
true it tells the sortic function to
sort this dictionary this dictionary
frequency table uh in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our uh sorted Tuple so
that's what we do in this slide and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears 510 and so on and so forth so
we've created a sorted Tuple where the
first object of the Tuple we've created
a list of sorted tuples where the first
object of the two each Tuple is the
unique word the second one is the number
of times it has appeared in this
particular example or this particular
string so yeah this was the first basic
project that we have tackled in this you
might have seen some examples of how we
do list operations and how we use the
Lambda function in sorting the
dictionary by the values of the key in
this video we will continue with what we
started in in terms of our project
number one what we're going to do is
we're going to tackle another slightly
complicated
um
a question or a situation we're going to
try to arrive at a solution so in this
what we have is some sort of a robot a
moving robot which moves on a Cartesian
plane a two coordinate plane
um is going to move in terms of up down
left and right okay and each each time
it moves up or down or left or right it
takes a certain number of steps in that
direction
um integral steps of course so what we
need to do is from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we are going to take as 0 comma 0 in
this example we're going to make it move
to a particular location with the
commands up down left and right followed
by certain steps and we're going to ask
what we're going to do is we're going to
calculate the distance between these two
points
um and we're going to calculate
different types of distances so you
might be introduced to New Concepts
um you know a distance Concepts in this
video as well so what we're going to be
using for distance calculation is the
minkowski district and that is we're
going to take so the minkowski distance
between two variables is basically the
absolute difference between these two
variables so these two points and we
take it to the power of something so if
we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with in terms the
quadratic main cause citizens with
basically P2 so we are going to do x i
minus y i absolute difference to the
power 2 and then we're going to take the
second root of it after summing each and
every point so when we take p is equal
to 2 we we say the minkowski distance
behaves like the euclidean distance so
this is probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done basic
uh Cartesian geometry when you are asked
to find the distance between two points
on a plane
um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the absolute distances between
each point no roots no power is nothing
basically p is equal to one and because
that demand hat in distance so we're
going to take p is equal to 1 to 1 3 in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points based on
these
measures so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the eagle in
resistance basically the estimate of the
value between these two points if um
since this is a two coordinate system
whereas the Manhattan distance would be
the absolute distance in terms of if we
go up and then we go right between these
two like save this first and this was
another point so yeah let's move on to
the problem in this particular example
we are going to start from the starting
position 0 and 0 on a on a graph and we
are going to give the commands of up
five down three left three and right two
so first of all what we want to do is we
initialize the starting position as 0
and 0 and we also just for the sake of
this example we initialize the end
position as 0 and 0. so what we're going
to do first of all is let's execute this
much now we have this list list of
tuples
um it's we're going to call this actions
and this is the actions that we're
performing so the this the each Tuple
contains an action and the number of
steps in that direction so it contains
four actions up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps right by
two steps so now we're going to iterate
over this each Tuple and we're going to
get the direction first of all in this
line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell
um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is stored
in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up by a
particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the the y-axis so we're going to change
end position and the first index which
is basically this part of the end
position coordinate point so we're going
to say if it's moving by up then we're
going to uh update by adding uh the
y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction is down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if we're moving left it's
a negative uh it's a decrement and if
you're moving right it's an increment so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid
actions that we can pass is um up down
left and right otherwise we we just skip
that particular action so this is what
the this particular Loop will do it will
update our final position
so once we've done this if we if I
execute this what will get stored in the
end position is basically my end
position so now that I have my starting
position and my end position
um just to show you what the end
Position will look like right now let's
just do this so if you see here after
I've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
um my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be 0 and 0. it
is 0 and 0. so now we're going to find
the distance between 0 and 0 and -1 and
2. so we're going to first of all create
a function called minkowski distance
which which does the basic function of
just calculate the uh the difference
between the what do you say the end
position x coordinate and the N position
y coordinate times or to the power of a
root and we're basically going to do
this operation that you saw here we're
going to do this and um we're going to
use this root variable to specify it to
like P is equal to one two or three like
what P value we want to take for this
minkowski distance so once we've done
this what this function will do is
basically store uh this much and it will
wait for us to uh it will basically wait
for us to give us a root so when we give
root 1 it will create these it will
check the distance between the end and
starting points
um with the p-value of one if you gave
it 2 it will calculate euclidean
distance with p-value 2 similarly for 3
and we can calculate for any Roots so
we're going to calculate for one two and
three roads and we're going to see what
values we get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 I print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 it's
something root 3 is something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the uh the cubic
menkowski distance with basically the
with root 3 is 1.91 so you see these
three different uh distance measures for
the same distance between two coins so
in this video you basically so in this
basically by doing this activity you
might must have you will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
and perform these distance calculations
which you'll find pretty handy in many
activities related to data science and
machine learning in this video we will
be continuing tackling different
problems and problem cases in terms of a
project called project three where we're
going to be using regular Expressions to
validate whether certain passwords that
have been entered do they match certain
criterias or not so let's look into our
particular question we have a website
that requires users to input username
and password to register now we have to
write a program to check the validity of
passwords input by the users now the
criterias that the passwords have to
follow are that there is at least one
letter between a and z and one number
between 0 and 9. the third criteria is
that uh there's at least one letter
between capital A and capital c so this
first and third Point basically is
saying that there should be one
lowercase letter and there should be one
uppercase letter now there should be at
least one character from dollar sign
hash or the add simple it should have a
minimum length of 6 and the maximum
length of 12. so when we whatever
passwords we enter into our example they
must be comma separated so if we're
going to have an input they're going to
ask us for an input where we're going to
have to input the different passwords in
a comma separated way so let's look
let's look at how do we tackle this so
for my example I'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all and
now let's import the re this import re
is basically the regular expression
module now in this step is going to ask
us to input the passwords as you can see
here so I will just Ctrl V so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these uh by the
comma and it will store them in a list
so it will take this as one password
this has another password this has
another password and this has another
password once I press enter
now if I want to check what's in list I
mean what's in items what I can do is
just check over here what's the items
it's a list of whatever passwords I had
entered uh each object is separately
treated now in this list now I'm going
to create a an empty list called value
first of all once I've done that I'm
going to move on to the next step
so once I've created my list called
value what I'm going to do is now I'm
going to search and I'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have initially so if you see here
what I'm going to do is first iterate by
each item in this to check for each
password now my first check will be a
basic check for the length of the
password if it's lesser than 6 or
greater than 12 then our basically our
password is illegal so we can't be using
this and we will just continue and we
won't check for anything else but if it
is within 6 and 12 the length 6 and 12
then we can continue with our check so
we can do we'll do an else statement for
pass which basically moves on to this
next block
now once you've done this what we will
do is this this first statement what
this is going to do is it's going to do
an re.search and re.search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of um
a letter occurring between
um A and Z so this re dot search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this does us is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between uh A and Z in terms of
small letters so if this condition is
not met then again we continue and we
leave this particular search because one
of our criterias is not met all right
but if it is met then this if not
statement will not uh like we won't
enter this block and we can move on to
the next check so now now we move to L
if not now again we're using if not
statement so this is basically checking
for uh a negative case so anytime one of
these cases have been met it basically
means that our password has been invalid
because these conditions are not being
met so when we're trying to eliminate
all conditions all of these conditions
so that we get a valid password so again
we move on to the next statement which
is basically going to do the search for
numbers
once again if we find a case a password
without any numbers we continue and we
don't
um check this password no more because
we already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for these particular
symbols the dollar the hash and the at
one of these three symbols uh we're
going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password
um that's an illegal password and we're
not going to continue checking for those
cases
so um so this is basically all our cases
lowercase letters numbers capital
letters b is one of these three symbols
and the existence of a white space so
once you've done all these checks if
none of these have been passed we move
on to this else statement where we just
pass and what we can do is we append the
value P to the uh the list call Value so
basically what happens is
um just to go through it again if this
condition is not met and this condition
is not met this is not met this is not
met this is not met and this is also not
met then we're fine so basically as long
as we have small letters as long as we
have a number as long as we have a
capital letter as long as we have one of
these three symbols and as long as we
don't have any uh White space characters
we can append e to this otherwise it
would continue and it will break out of
this for Loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks any time this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this
whole for Loop and we don't append t to
the value but uh if you actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh P to value now finally what we
are going to do is uh we are going to
print out all the valid passwords so
just by a quick look you can see here
this is a valid password right so let's
execute this and let's see uh what we
get if you see here we only get one
valid password and let's look at why
some of these do not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the add sign in this case we
have two white spaces one over here and
one over here so this is an illegal
password similarly in this case also we
have an illegal password because it
begins with a space in this case it's
the same thing we begin with the space
and also it does not have any of those
symbols that we were looking for the
dollar or the hash or the ad so again so
these three are illegal passwords and
they do not get appended to Value
however this does get appended to Value
and that's why we get the result for
only one password which is the only
legal password welcome to web scraping
with python my name is Richard kirschner
with the simply learned team certainly
there are many reasons to be able to go
online and scrape different websites
they range everything from pulling out
different links to pulling data off of
website it's a data scientist you might
need to get some information off a
website that doesn't have a direct API
to pull that information and in Python
we have a wonderful tool when you talk
Python and you talk web scraping we're
talking beautiful suit which is a
package you add into your python that
you're running and we can come over here
to the website
www.crumi.com software beautiful soup
you can actually read a little bit about
it currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for you can always do
what I do which just go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want IDE I'm going to use Jupiter lab
which is built on Jupiter notebook
through Anaconda so when I open up my
anaconda Navigator you'll see that I
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pie
charm or something like that we don't
need to do this and Jupiter lab is
Jupiter notebook with added tabs and
some added features it's basically in
beta testing so it's got a few little
glitches when you're saving things and
moving between projects but for the most
part it's a great upgrade to the jupyter
notebook and you can use them together
so you don't have to I mean it's built
on jupyter notebooks anything you do in
Jupiter notebook you can open up in
Jupiter lab and the first thing we need
to do is we need to go ahead in this
case I'm going under my environments
since it partitions the environments out
and I'm going to open up a terminal when
we have to install some packages in here
to work with now there's a lot of
choices on this I because of the
Simplicity we'll be using conda install
now you can use pip install for the same
thing and we're going to install our
beautiful soup 4. you have to type out
the whole thing beautiful soup four and
you can use a pip install if you're
using a different environment and I am
using python version
3.6 although according to beautiful soup
they also work on three seven all the
way from two seven through all of 3x now
according to the beautiful suit website
the beautiful soup 4 works on anything
you can install anything from python 2 7
all the way through any of the Python 3
versions this just happens to be
python36 because they do it there's a
lot of other packages that don't work on
three seven yet and we'll go ahead and
run this install on here and let it go
through its environmental setup and of
course with conduct it goes in there and
finds all the dependencies PIP doesn't
do as much as far as finding
dependencies but you know exactly what's
on there with Pip so if you're doing a
huge distribution you probably want to
use your pip install so you can track
what's going on there with the conda I
like to just let it take over since this
isn't a major distributed package going
out another quick note between pip and
conda is that if you start on a project
in one of these environments and you're
using pip in there stick with Pip if
you're using conda stick with conda they
track the packages and you can run into
some issues where they're not tracking
the same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply install pandas and let's just
install a couple more packages in this
case let's get our install our map plot
library because we're going to plot at
the end since we're going to be
collecting data and for this project
that will be all the packages we'll need
so we can go ahead and close out of our
installer or whatever setup you have and
we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our Jupiter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now if
you're coming from Jupiter notebooks the
first time in lab we can go ahead and
just create our first notebook python3
you can also do it under a file launcher
and you'll see new notebook it
automatically opens up and we can just
click right on there it'll pop open on
the left and I'll right click this and
we'll rename this we'll rename it just
beautiful and it is a
ipinb file on there so I should look for
new here because that's the Jupiter
notebook file this is a new one now I
have multiple tabs and in the past I
usually hid this on the other computer
all my notes for the lesson today but
this is my notes going down and we'll go
ahead and just start going through this
and see what it looks like to do a data
pull from front to end and see how that
works as a data scientist pulling that
information in from the website and the
first thing I want to do is I want to go
ahead and close the side window that way
it looks get the nice full screen and we
can also up the size a little bit one of
the wonderful things about working in a
browser window just do that control plus
thing the packages we talked about is
pandas so we imported our pandas if you
haven't already that's our data frame if
you haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of the time to go
through there and understand pandas
because it's such a powerful tool this
basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame our numpy is our
number array so it kind of works with
pandas very closely as far as
manipulating data in arrays map we want
to go ahead and bring that in our PLT so
that we can plot the data at the end and
this line right here that says matplot
Library inline is for the Jupiter
notebook specifically it tells it to
print that on this page a lot of the
newer versions don't actually require to
have that line they'll still print it on
the page we should still include that if
you're in the Jupiter lab setup and then
we have our URL Library dot request
we're going to import URL open for
opening up the website and then we have
our bs4 that's your beautiful soup 4
we're going to import beautiful suit and
then our last one is our re that is for
manipulating our regular expression so
when you get to that part of importing
our data we have to do a lot of
reformatting so it's something we can
use and the re is one of those tools
we'll go ahead and run this and just
bring all that in so this is all
imported all these packages are now into
our web scraping program we're going to
run now if we're going to dive in and
pull data we should have a nice website
to pull from and let's go ahead and
we'll use the uppertiming.com results
for the 2018 Martin Luther King race and
if we take this you can actually just
take this where did we get this from
well you can go in here and find the
website you're going to scrape from and
you'll see right here it says you just
copy that link right in there that HTTP
and this is a website that we're looking
at you can see right here all the
information that we're looking at let's
say we wonder to run some statistics on
this it sure would be nice to be able to
pull it off of here and if they don't
have a direct API that means we need to
pull it from their website some of these
will have a download although if you've
ever done a we have a download click and
maybe you're paging through 100 websites
in one case I was pulling all the
different United States bills that are
passed to track who voted on them for a
project and you can imagine that there's
you know hundreds and hundreds of those
thousands of these documents that they
voted on who voted on and it goes to the
Senate goes back to the Congress so I
opened up a website pull all the links
off of there that matched a certain
criteria and we'll look at that in just
a minute how we go through the HTML and
then I had to reformat them or I could
hand download each one one at a time
which would just be a nightmare so it's
nice to automate it in this case we're
going to be pulling up this chart we
want to figure out how to pull this
chart off of this website and so we go
back into our Jupiter notebook I've got
my URL just um our name for it and it's
just a string that's all this is nothing
fancy there you'll notice that on the
slashes we now have forward forward
slash you can do a single forward and
HTTP is a double forward this is just
how you have to switch it to match setup
in there and then it's going to go ahead
and use the HTML equals URL open URL and
that's from our URL Library request so
it's opening a link to that website or
at least pointing to it and if we run
this this just sets it up so this is all
set up and then once we've done our
setup let's go ahead and create an
object called soup this will be and if
you remember up here here's our
beautiful soup that we imported from the
bs4 and this is the package that we're
working with and so we're going to do
our beautiful soup on here and on this
we need to go ahead and send it our HTML
so it knows what it's opening and then
the second part is we have to tell it
how the format is coming in and the most
common one for your HTML polls is an L
XML setup and so almost all of them
you'll end up using the lxml there's a
few other options and because this is so
common in the newer versions a lot of
times they just leave it out just
because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that and on the newer
versions uh they actually default it to
the XML setup and the HTML we'll just
leave it out and call it HTML so it's
just going to pull from this URL and
when we run that on here we've now
created an object soup that has pulled
the website into it so soup contains the
information along with information on
that website and what's going on so
let's just go over what we did real
quick before we start digging into the
actual suit before we start scooping out
stuff we imported our different modules
that we're going to use with our package
specifically the beautiful soup we did
install the beautiful soup remember
correctly you have to call it beautiful
soup four specifically so it knows what
you're bringing in and this line right
here is very key from bs4 because that's
how it installs the module we're
importing our beautiful soup and then we
found our URL in this case we're going
to go pull information from The Martin
Luther King dream run and then we set
our HTML to our URL open URL and you can
see right here we imported that so
here's our url.request import URL open
so we're requesting a connection and
once we send that connection into the
beautiful soup it creates an object
called suit and then this one of course
we chose soup just because it goes with
beautiful soup I guess we could have
chosen beautiful and now we can start
extracting information from our website
because we've pulled it down onto our
computer under soup and we can start by
looking at the title of the website soup
dot title and if we print title dot text
you'll see this a lot in beautiful soup
because title contains all kinds of
information and if we want just the text
from that title you add the dot text on
the end and you can see right here we
have our 2018 MLK dream Run 5K race
results if you look at the tab that's
the actual title up here 2018 MLK dream
Run 5K race that's what the title is on
the website and then you might be
curious what's in title what's the whole
title that it's storing up there well
let's go ahead and print it out here's
print title and print title.txt and when
we run that you can see it has the HTML
tags title on it and then the forward
slash title to end it and so we're
really just pulling off this piece of
the HTML code and then we look at the
text inside that particular part of the
HTML and earlier I mentioned links what
if you want to get all the links off
this page oh that would be fun uh we
could do soup Dot and we'll do find
underscore all put this in bracket and
then quotation marks we're going to put
a a is the key find and you'll start
seeing a div and all the different
options you have for finding these
entities in a website and then let's go
ahead and just print our links and you
can see here that it now shows all the
different links in here that are marked
by eggs we did a find all a and then we
can also because this is a little bit
hard to pull off the H reference so we
can also add in our find all fine tune
that in this case the H reference equals
true we'll actually filter that out and
then finally we might do a four link in
links and we can simply do something
like this for each link we want to
actually find the H reference because we
know there's an age reference in it and
if I run this you can see it just comes
through and prints them out one at a
time some of these are really useful so
you might be looking for something that
has https in it and you know that's a
link running to something else or you
might be looking for the mail to tags
you know that's all the mail addresses
but either way you can easily find all
the links in your HTML document that
you're paging through and of course any
packages that have evolved over time you
can also do link dot get H reference
which should do the same thing as our
other format and you can see it
certainly does we get the same printout
up here in this particular case we
really want to get the data off the page
so let's go ahead and do that let's see
what that looks like and in data let's
call it all rows there we go equals and
then we have our soup dot find
underscore all there's our brackets and
then if we're looking for each row in a
database you'll remember your HTML code
we're looking for the tag TR so we want
to find all TR and we can take this
let's go and just take all our rows and
do a print all rows and about this time
you're going to guess that we're going
to get a huge amount of information just
dumped onto our page and sure enough we
do if you look at this it just kind of
goes on forever but this is an array
each row is considered an array so
because of that we can do something
simply as putting brackets and just
print the first let's do the first five
rows so from beginning to five and you
can see here's our first five rows on
here I sometimes like to just do let's
just do row zero and we see that row 0
is finishers finishers 191 and just out
of curiosity which if that's zero what's
Row one male okay so we're starting to
see titles going across here so if we
come up here and we do rows we did what
up to 10. let's just take a look and see
what 10 does again and just take a look
at that information that comes across
Place bib name gender age city state
chip chip paste gender and so on so it
comes all the way down here we kind of
have an ending right here and then we
have one and then we actually looks like
we start to have information so we have
our one our one 1191 Max Randolph that
must be the name male 29 and so on you
start seeing how the information starts
getting displayed going down so the next
thing we want to do with this I'll go
back up here and just edit the space
we're in so it starts to make a little
bit more sense keep it all together and
so we want to do for each row in all
rows we're looking at what information
are we looking at well we have our th up
here that's the header our TD down here
which looks like the individual
information and we really are looking
for the actual data so we're looking for
our TD tags in the rows and we can do
that because when remember when it
stores the row it also stores the tags
underneath that so all rows have all the
different tags in it and you can see
right here as you print each one of
those out and so we look at each row we
can create another variable and we'll
call it row list and we'll set this
equal to in this case row because we've
already pulled all the rows out of soup
so now we want to find for each row and
in there we want to find our TD and if
we go ahead and just print I'm going to
do it if you notice I changed the indent
so I'm just going to print row list what
this does is the last value to go into
row list our last row is going to print
now and of course make sure you have an
underscore instead of a period when
you're typing so row dot find underscore
all TD and if we print the last row you
can see I have all the data coming
across here we have our 191 our 1216
Zuma Oak choa I hope I said that right
female I believe that's age 40 and so on
and then we can take our row list and
there's a lot of things we can do with
the row list but we'll do for let's do
object or let's just just do cell in row
list and so we're going to look at each
cell because this is if you look at this
they have commas separated between the
different objects and then we're going
to go ahead and print cell dot text
let's just take a look and see what that
looks like and we can see here for each
row we get 191 there's our 191 there's
our 12 16 12 16 our individual who's in
the race and so forth all the way down
for those different settings and let's
go ahead and create a new variable up
here we'll call this all let's just call
it data we'll keep it simple so here's
our data and then we have our row we
take our row we break it up into
individual cells so we'll call this data
row we'll set this empty to an empty row
and we're going to take our cells to
have this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is I want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so I'm going to add the e row is going
to be a row of the different text on
here and then once I create each row I
want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were working with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our data on the page but you can see
here we throw the date on the page and
we get finishers 199 male 78 female 113
1 and so on and if you look at this this
is the headers on the file we have
finishers uh male females just like some
general statistics on the first one and
then we have actually
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actually the
actual information we're looking for so
we have 1 1191 Max Randolph Mill 29
Washington DC runtime one of 78 and so
on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that a number of different
ways to do that one of them is just to
do we're going to set we do data two on
we should get rid of everything we we
want to keep Randolph so make sure
Randolph is in there oh we lost Randolph
let's try one on there we go there's Max
Randolph on there so we can just simply
do redo our data on here and we can do
data probably want to do it in all rows
from one on but I'm just going to do my
data equals data one on down here and
there's reasons to split it this way in
data science sometimes you don't want to
touch the original data in case you need
it in case we do need the first row so
we'll put it down here and maybe we'll
just call this titles titles equals data
of zero and so we could do something
here where we print we'll print up our
titles and we'll print our data in this
case instead of one on let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
I was expecting a little bit more up
there and we have our last couple people
and they look like the data on these
looks just fine on here turns out this
is just some generic statistics up here
so we'll get rid of titles completely
doesn't really do us any good but we
know that data comes in here and we can
look at our data and look at the very
end of the data too the minus 2 to the
end and we can see it pulls the data in
pretty good we don't have anything too
funky in here we're looking at it looks
pretty clean now you got to be a little
careful because at some point we might
have to come back here and clean up the
data if we get an error for running data
analysis we might find out there's some
unusual characters or something is
missed set in the data itself and you
also notice that everything is a string
so when we're bringing it in we might
have to do some conversions to test it
out and convert them to whatever kind of
data format we're working with so at
this time we want to go ahead and bring
in our pandas and let's go ahead and
call this idea for data frame we'll set
it equal to and if you remember
correctly we imported pandas as PD and
that's standard you'll see that in most
code examples where they call it the
import pandas is PD and it is capital D
capital F for data frame and we're just
going to bring in our data that's what
we
and let's take this and we'll print now
when you're working with data frames
you're usually talking large amounts of
data and so you almost never want to
print the whole data frame out we're
going to go ahead and do that anyway
just so we can see what that looks like
and you can see in here brings in our
data frame coming in here and we just
have a mess of information this is our
data let's go ahead and print DF and see
what that looks like in the data frame
and this is nice because it organizes it
into a very easy to read table and we
have they set the label 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
and so on and then we have each row we
have Mel 78 none none going across when
we get all the way down here we'll see
Max Randall about number three and the
first thing this does is this Flags me
that I brought in a bunch of information
up here that we really didn't want uh
it's from three on that we want and we
can clean this up in one of two ways we
can try to clean it up under the data or
we can clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this
um I want to go ahead and just change it
up here in the actual data pull in we
don't need that information so I'll
rerun it reload our data from for on and
then when I run this we see we have Max
Randolph is right at the top of the list
like he should be and we have all the
data going down now with the data frame
remember I said we don't usually print
the whole data frame we'll go ahead and
do df.head and this prints the first
five rows and you can see that we have
13 columns here's Max Randall all the
way to Theo kinman and I use the also
print DF tell and the reason I like to
do these particular two setups I'm going
to change it just to two rows because
you can do that you can put as many rows
as you want is this good look at the
first part and the end because those are
usually where you have extra data
brought in something's messed up and you
can also see that we have 190 rows in
here and it comes in with our Zuma
Alicia and they're both on here on the
list so now we have a nice data frame
columns and rows we can easily look at
it we can see the setup on here and we
can look at the names and everything now
at some point you might be looking at
these individual columns and find
different information that needs to be
re-edited if you can you try to do it
with the whole column under pandas you
can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row you could look at individual
cells maybe find a marker in that cell
that's something specific like remove
all colons or semicolons or something in
there are brackets so there's a lot of
options in there but you'll find that
this one actually comes in pretty clean
on here all the way down and the next
thing we really want to do is we want to
look at the headers I don't know about
you but does it make any sense to me
when I have column one I don't know what
1191 is or 1080 need name Kaiser Runner
I'm guessing that's column two is names
third one it looks like male or female
probably age but I don't want to guess I
want this to bring in my column so I
know exactly what I'm looking at so how
can we make beautiful soup do that for
us well let's take our column headers
and we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all and then we're
going to look for our headers our th
files and since we're in Jupiter lab in
this case Jupiter notebook I can just
type out column headers if it's a last
variable I have listed it will
automatically print it just kind of a
shorthand and we can see right here we
have place I'm guessing that's bib name
gender age city state chip time chip
pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there I shouldn't have to
type them all in and we'll go ahead and
do it before we'll go ahead and do a
header list equals our empty array and
then we can do for a column in column
headers and we can take our header list
and just a pin and what do we want we
want the text from the column so we'll
just do column dot text and then if we
come down here and we print our header
list let's see what that looks like if
we did it right we should get a nice
list of all the different column
headings we want so we have placebib
name and so on and then pandas just
because pandas is so cool simply do DF
columns equals our header from our
header list we can simply said DF
columns set to DF headers and then if I
print df.head we'll take a look at that
and we'll see right here it has nicely
placed our values on here Place bib name
gender age and so on so very quickly
we've created this nice data frame we
have the data displayed in nice rows and
columns and easy to read and then as a
data scientist the first thing we want
to know is the info what is in these
columns and rows and headers and you see
right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
I want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object I usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just run that you see
it's 191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries
this is more like a we look at a numpy
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if I put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells Jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different IDE you'd want to go
ahead and use the print statement on
here and then one of the things you'd
want to also go through we'll create a
second one df2 equals DF dot drop in a
now the axis is automatically equal to
zero so a lot of times you'll see
something like axes equals zero comma
How equals any axis equals zero is
default that means we're looking at
going down the rows you could look at
the column going across let's remove the
how index that's just going to confuse
you the axis is is whether you're going
down the columns or if you're looking at
a row by row by row by row or you could
be looking at it by column by column by
column this would drop any column in
would drop off the N A in any column and
how equals and we want any I always
confuse all in any because they both
start with a all means that all of them
have to be non-value where any means
that any of them can be there to drop it
so this would drop any column with a
null value in it but we want zero and
it'll drop any value with an null value
and then because 0 is always the default
we'll just leave it out and then as
curious as to what the shape is now did
we lose anything was there any null
values in our df2 that we dropped from
the DF and we'll go ahead and run that
and we see 191 and 14. so we didn't
really drop anything but it's always
good to check there's other ways you can
also do are there let's see any Nas you
can detect n a's in here no values
infinite values that's another one you
got to watch out for we're working with
data that we're going to do something
with here in a minute so you got to be a
little careful also in the convergence
are you going to convert something where
people typed in weird characters to
describe of the data a certain way so
now we've got to this point where we
have all our different columns we have
our different data and at this point
maybe you're asking or maybe the
shareholder the company is asking hey
can we look at the based on the chip
time here's our chip time can we plot
that versus gender how does gender
versus chip time compare and so we can
do that we can take that and the first
thing we look at is we say hey well chip
time came in as a string and that's
going to be an issue now there's a
number of ways you can change this one
of them is we could go all the way back
up here where we created the data and
find a way to tag it and say Hey
whenever this cell text maybe instead of
appending this I notice that anytime
there's two colons in it that's probably
a time signature and let's convert all
the time signatures to date time filled
or whatever A lot of times you don't get
that you don't get that option and
that's always a question in bringing in
data whether you convert the data coming
in at the beginning or do you wait till
you have it open it up and then come
convert it when you go to use it we're
going to go ahead and convert it after
we got it into our data frame so we have
our df2 here we've dropped all of our
Nas we dropped our we have a shape in
fact let's do this since there's no
difference between DF and df2 well we'll
just go ahead and use df2 so let's go
ahead and take our df2 and we want to
take those that specific field and
convert it into some kind of numerical
value we can use and let's add another
column A lot of times this is something
you want to do is where you want to go
ahead and keep all the original columns
and just add a new column in there and
this new column is going to be based on
the if we remember correctly we had chip
type that's what we're going to look at
okay we want chip time versus gender if
we go into our pandas we find out we
have pandas 2 Delta and this is actually
time Delta and then we just want to take
our df2 and we're going to use the chip
time column so this is going to say hey
let's look at let's convert everything
in Di have to chip time into a Time
Delta format that's the data type we're
going to put it as let me go ahead and
just run this and if we go in here and
we do info df2 and we'll keep our we're
going to look at this particular column
but we want to keep it as a data frame
so this is a list of all the columns we
want to look at we'll just dot info on
here and run that and we do an info on
that you can see it's now a Time Delta
64 nanoseconds well we really don't want
nanoseconds we actually probably want to
do it in minutes so let's take a look at
that and let's take this whole thing TF2
let's just set the df2 we have our df2
this is a column we're working with here
and we can use the as type property in
pandas and so we can set this equal to
df2 we'll take our same column in here
and we'll set it as type time Delta
second so it's still a Delta time here
so if I run this you'll see that it
still comes up as where is it oh it
turns it into a float so we're now at a
float 64 so it's the number of seconds
in that Delta time and then finally we
want to go ahead and turn that from
seconds to say minutes and you know
there's 60 seconds in minutes and so now
we divide by 60 we still have a float we
have our info it shows us it's a float
and then we can go ahead and just do a
print df2 and let's just keep it small
we don't want to look at all our data we
just want to do the head of it and we
run this and you can see right here
where we go to it'll be the last one
here's our chip time in minutes and a
lot of times just to make life easy for
viewing since we're only looking at this
particular element we can do chip time
in minutes and now we just see that oops
we take off we'll go ahead and take off
our info done with that and we'll run
this and see we have our minutes 16.8
minutes 17.51 minutes and so on it's a
float number now keep in mind this is
0.8 that's not a 16 minutes and 80
Seconds that can always throw you if
you're going through so many numbers you
forget so important to remember that and
we're also going to look at the other
one we're looking at is what gender you
want to look at gender to chip time in
minutes and so we can see here under the
head we get mail mail and a number of
different setups and this switch this to
tell real quick and just look at the end
of it and here we have female female
male female female so we have two
different genders and we have our chip
time in minutes and if you remember we
brought in our PLT if you haven't used
the plot Library the matplot library you
have a drawing place you're putting
stuff on so we have our PLT we're going
to do a bar graph and we just want to
Simply use our df2 gender in df2 chip
time in minutes so that's going to plot
the two bars and to make it pretty we'll
go ahead and give it the X label gender
the Y labeled chip time minutes and that
simply is I remember it always plots X
and it plots Y and we have our gender
our chip time give it a nice title a
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female and if we go ahead and
run this with the correct titles in here
and everything matches uh you'll get a
nice graph we can see here the
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be Slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
uh there's a number of studies that show
that women tend to have as far as doing
cross-country there's a lot of women who
have a longer endurance than men so it's
not too surprising but we can see here
the average chip time around 70 and for
women over a hundred minutes and then
another really cool thing we can do is
we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is and we're
going to include NP number the numpy
number and if we run that you'll see
here it comes up it says chip time in
minutes count it gives you the average
or the means standard deviation the
minimum the maximum all the different
descriptive information you're going to
want from your data set on there and
just because there's all kinds of fun
ways let's do a box plot to display your
information we can do a box plot where
the column equals chip time in minutes
and let's go ahead and run that keep
mistyping my chip time in minutes you
can see it puts out a nice box plot
showing you the information we have our
different values and floaters this is
always interesting because this is a
nice way of seeing where we have these
floaters one up here and there's two up
above and of course you're they're a
nice spread on the box plot and we can
also modify this a little bit and we can
add in buy equals gender and then we'll
give it a we'll just give it a blank
title I don't know why we're giving it
blank title uh we'll just add a y plot y
label on there for runtime and if we run
this you can see here box plot grouped
by gender chip time in minutes and now
we have our female and male two
different areas and you can see how they
vary you have your two different uh your
outlier up here and you can also see how
there's an overlap between the two
different values so if I was looking at
this I'd be like wow you know I really
could not draw a conclusive thing on
this saying that Women's Run time was
more in general because they overlapped
too much that would be one of the
conclusions I'd have to come up with
done here and then we get to maybe the
partners come in from the company and
say hey we'd like to know the age versus
chip time in minutes that'd be something
worth knowing on the statistics on this
and the first thought is we can simply
plot it and we can do this we can
actually plot the scatter plot chip time
versus a df2 of H those are X Y
coordinates but if you remember from df2
we did the info let's go way back up
here we're looking at a data object as
far as our chip time on this and our age
now we converted the chip time but we
also need to convert the age and if we
do it right here we just plot it and
it'll actually let us plot it it
shouldn't it should give us an error but
it does let us plot it you'll see the
Ages come up a mess over here because
they're convert turning it to weird
float numbers and all kinds of things so
what we want to do is we want to take
our age and we'll just call this H
underscore I so we're going to take our
age and we're going to create another
column for df2 age underscore I and the
I is just going to stand for integers
our own choice of values there is a
number of ways to do this but we're
going to do pandas to Merrick is the
best way in pandas and the reason we're
doing this is that numeric creates a
float value so right off the bat we want
all our stuff converted converts it to
the least common denominator so if
they're all integers already you'll get
integers as you can see from here it's
doing some kind of conversion that
converts it to a float value the other
thing that numeric does is if there is a
null value or they put in like a blank
line or a dash to represent no
information it'll convert it to a null
so it goes from like a string to a null
versus just having some kind of made up
number that python somehow created for
the graph we have below and then we want
to add our df2a page because that's what
we're converting to numeric and then we
want to coerce it and there's a couple
different options on this like you can
have it where it just doesn't process it
in pandas but coerce means that if it
gets a weird value that is a null value
now and since we're dealing with errors
this is what happens when you get an
error converting it we want to coerce it
there we go and put the end bracket on
there and then finally we want to go and
round this off so I'll put brackets
around all the way around it and this
rounds off everything in this series so
we've done here is I've taken df2h which
is a d-type object which in this case is
mostly strings with a couple of blank
ones in there and we're going to convert
it to a numeric which will automatically
go to float and then we're going to take
wherever there's an error wherever it
says hey this doesn't convert and
usually that's a blank screen like I
said I've worked with so many databases
where they someone puts down none
someone types in space sometimes in a
dash to mean none and you get this
really weird conversion coming up this
covers all of that in pandas so it's
really a nice way of just coercing it
and saying hey if we don't have a number
in there let's make it a null value and
then we're going to round it off and
then finally let's go ahead and take our
df2 here's our df2 and let's drop those
null values drop in a and we want how
how equals any so that means if there's
any null values in the data set now you
can be this might get you in trouble
because you might have no values in a
different column and so you might lose
data that way at this point we could
also do like certain parts of like Drop
just certain columns with null values
there's all kinds of other options in
here but we're just going to do how
we're going to just drop any and we want
to do it in line equals true so that
means it's going to reassign it to df2
so df2 now has rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
I and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors and we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure that data
by deleting out the rows because that's
what this does it automatically does
axis0 which is your rows axis one is
your columns by doing this it I'm going
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
rolls and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 70. so
we have our chip time set and then our
age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show for
display and for the the and you can
easily show that to your shareholders or
whatever group you're working on it
makes it really nice and quick easy
display in this session we will discuss
the top tips and tricks in Python that
you can use to solve your problems first
let's understand what python really is
so python is a high level open source
programming language developed in 1989
by Guido van Rossum
it has simple easy to use syntax
python can run on different platforms
such as Windows Linux and Unix
it has a large collection of libraries
and can be integrated with other
programming languages such as c c plus
and Java
companies use Python for web development
software development statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
python tips and tricks will help you
optimize the code and reduce your time
and effort while writing codes for
solving problems
these tips and tricks are usually short
Snippets of python code with simple
illustrations to tell you how you can
perform a complex task easily
it can also serve as examples that allow
you to dive deep into understanding and
exploring how each concept works and
where it can be used
so in this video we'll be covering the
tips and tricks based on python lists
tuples sets and dictionaries we'll also
see how to effectively use loops
iterators and collections in Python
so let me take you to my jupyter
notebook where I'll show you the
different tips and tricks
so here is my jupyter notebook
so let's begin with our first trick
if you want to initialize a list or a
tuple filled with repetitive strings or
numbers written in the form of a string
we can do that using the multiplication
operator
so let me show you
so first I'll declare a list suppose a
is equal to within square brackets I'll
declare a string suppose India
and now if I use the multiplication
operator and suppose I say 10
then I'll print a
so this will print India 10 times if I
hit shift enter it will run that cell
you can see we have printed India 10
times
similarly
let's add another element to our list
or another item to our list
say India and then we have
France
I'll use the multiplication operator and
apply 10
so let me print my list again
for hit shift enter you can see India
and France have been printed 10 times
also
you can use
an integer as a string
and print as many times as you want
suppose I am printing 20 five times
I'll use the print statement
you can see we have printed 25 times
but if I pass an integer as my first
operand
it will result in the product of the two
numbers so for example if I use c equal
to
20 into 5
and if I print C
it will give me the product of 20 and 5
that is 100.
next let's see how you can reverse the
elements in a list for that we'll use
the list slicing method
let me first show you how you can
reverse a string
I'll declare my list as list 1 is equal
to
and inside this list I'll
pass in a few country names such as
India then we have
USA
let's say we have France
and then
Germany
and finally we have Spain now if you
want to reverse the order of this list
you can use the slicing method inside
the print statement so I'll write
print
and I'll pass in my list that is list
one
and I'll use
double colon
followed by
-1 so this will read my list from the
end
so if I hit shift enter you can see we
have reversed
our original list so now this pane comes
first then Germany France USA and India
likewise you can also reverse
a list of numbers
so
let's reverse a list of numbers
suppose this time I'll use list 2 is
equal to
I'll pass in few integers say 100 200
300 and 400.
now if I
print
my list
to
using colon colon -1 it will reverse
list two
you can see we have reboost our original
list 2 so now 400 comes first then 300
200 and 100.
now let me tell you how you can print
the elements in a list in any order that
you prefer suppose I have a list that
has values like 1 comma two three and
four
then I'll print this list
after that
I'll use four variables
such as e comma B comma C comma d
and assign it to our list
after that let me go ahead and print
any order that I want for example I'll
use B comma e comma D comma C
and hit shift enter you can see we have
printed our list in the order that we
wanted
so basically what this cell does is
we have assigned the value 1 from list
to a 2 to B 3 to C and 4 to D and we are
printing in an order b a d c
so this is the result you can see
now suppose you want to print in some
other order like
say I want C first
then I want B
a and then d
so this is the output
up next
we will discuss list comprehensions in
Python so list comprehension is an
effective way to define and create new
lists based on existing lists
so suppose you want to extract and
separate all the letters from the word
simply learn and add letters as items of
a list ideally you would use a for Loop
to do this task
so let's see how you can perform this
task using a for Loop I'll assign an
empty list say letters
is equal to
I'll use square brackets to assign my
empty list
then
and declare a for Loop so suppose for I
in
I'll pass in my string that is simply
learn
and
I'll append the letters
using the append function
now let me go ahead and
print the letters
if I hit shift enter you can see
this will print all individual letters
present in the word simply learn
but the same job
you can do it easily with the help of
list comprehensions
so let me show you how to do that
first I'll declare a variable say
letters
is equal to inside square brackets I'll
write I for
I in my string
simply learn
then I'll just
print the letters
you can see we have extracted all the
letters from the word simply learn
so this is how we use list comprehension
now similarly
if you were to find the square of
numbers you would like to create a user
defined function or use a for Loop to do
it so let me show you how you can
proceed
so
we were to define a function so first
I'll import
the math module present in Python
and then let's see I am defining a
function called Square
and I'll pass in a parameter as a
then I'll write e is equal to
I'll use the power function so I'll
first give in my module name that is
math and use the power function that is
pow
and I'll pass in my parameter that is a
and since we want to find the square
I'll give in 2
and I'll return my parameter that is a
if I hit shift enter now we have
successfully run our user defined
function now let me call that function
if I write
square of a
does given me 1 by default
now suppose I want to find the square
of integer 5
you can see it has given us the square
of 5 that is 25
now to find the square of a number you
can also create an empty list and use a
for Loop to iterate through a sequence
of numbers and append the square of
numbers to that empty list
so let me show you how you can do with
this process suppose I
declare an empty list called squares
I'll pass in my empty list
and then I'll use a for Loop say for
example for
I in
range
I'll give 10 as my range
and then
I'll append my Square value so I'll
pass in my empty list that is squares
Dot
append
so I'll use Quest dot append
and pass I into I
and then
I'll just
call my empty list squares if I hit
shift enter you can see
from 0 to 9 that is a range of 10 values
it has printed all the squares of those
integers
now these two methods that we just
discussed need at least three to four
lines of code but by using a list
comprehension you can find the square of
numbers in just a single line of code
so let's use a list comprehension to
find square of five whole numbers
between 0 and 20 having an interval of 4
so I'll use
squares
is equal to
I'll say X
double multiplication operator
into 2 for
X in
say range
I'll pass in my range that is from 0 to
with an interval of 4.
now I'll
print squares
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
printed the square of values so first
the number is 0 so 0 square is 0 then
the number was 4 so 4 square is 16 8
square is 64. then 12 square is 144 and
then 16 square is 256.
moving ahead in the next trick
I'll show you how you can keep track of
the index positions and the items in a
list
so for that we will use the enumerate
function to print the item values along
with the index positions
so let's see I have a list
that has items
say
294 I'm taking random integers
450 and say 243
and now if I
use a print statement suppose
I'll write using the
enumerate function
then I'll use a for Loop say for example
for
index comma
element
in
enumerate
I'll pass in my
list that is list underscore items
after that
I'll use a print statement
I'll pass in index
and then I'll give
a list and that will have my
index
followed by
the value
I'll use another comma and pass in the
element
now if I hit shift enter you can see we
have printed the index position as well
as the item value so at index 0 we have
310 at index 1 we have 294 similarly for
index 2 and 3
now moving ahead
let us understand how we can convert two
less into a dictionary so a dictionary
as you must be aware comes with a key
value pair
you can use the dictionary method and
pass the zip function with our list as
parameters
so let me Define our two lists say item
number and names
so I'll use item number
and give him some random whole numbers
and let's say 321
and I'll use my second list
that is names and let's say this list
has
some string values like phone
next is laptop
and then we have say tablet
now
I'll
assign a variable say item
dictionary
is equal to I'll use the dict function
and then pass in zip
and I'll pass in my parameters item
number and names
finally I'll print
my newly created dictionary that is item
dictionary
now let me run it
so you can see we have a dictionary
created out of the list
so our keys are 102 410 and 321 and the
item values are phone laptop and tablet
now you can check that in the following
way so I'll
pass in my dictionary
and then I'll use the keys function to
get the keys from the dictionary so you
see we have all the keys printed
similarly if you want to print the
values from the dictionary
I'll use the values function
so that will print all the values you
can see we have phone laptop and tablet
now we look at how you can find the
common elements in two lists
so let me declare my first list as list
underscore e that will be equal to
Davis
then let's say we have Karen
then we have John
you have Frank next and then let's see
we have another person say steep
and let me declare my list B so list
underscore B
is equal to I'll take Karen
next we have Davis
then suppose we have Jack
up next we have
George
and then say we have Steve again
now to find the common elements I'll use
variable let's say common
and I'll again
use a list comprehension say a for
a in
list a
then use for
B in
list B
then I'll use an if Clause so if E
equals to equals to B
then
I'll
print the common variable
if I run this you can see we have the
common elements printed from both the
list A and B so Dave is caring and Steve
are present in both list A and B
next let's see how you can remove the
duplicate items in a list such problems
you would often come across while doing
data analytics so the idea is very
simple just need to convert the items in
a list into a set
so that will remove all the duplicate
items in a list
so suppose I have a list of numbers
let me take random whole numbers 20 22
4 so 26
then we have 28 repeated twice
and then again suppose we have 20
and we have 22
and let's see we have 30.
now
let me go ahead and print my list
so I'll say original list
equals to
and then I'll pass in my list that is
list numbers
after that
I'll convert my list that is list
numbers
into a set
so I'll first use the list function and
then inside of that I'll pass in my set
function and then declare
my list
that is list numbers
finally I'll
print my new list
so I'll type list after
removing duplicates
that will be equal to
I'll give a comma and then pass in my
variable
that is list numbers
if I run it
you can see our original list has all
the elements that has duplicate values
and the final list the output you can
see we have only the unit elements
printed
moving on
now let's have a look at how you can
merge two dictionaries
so there are two methods to do this
before that let's see how the code would
have looked like had you merged the
dictionaries using python 2 version or
Python 3.4 version and below
so let's see I have two dictionaries say
team a
I'll use curly braces to declare my
dictionary
I'll give my key as 1 and I'll take
Davis
I'll give my second key
and see I have Andrew in my team
and then let's say I have my
third key and let's see I have Karen
similarly let me declare my
Team B dictionary
I'll take
the next key as four
and the next person would be
say John
and then
I'll use my fifth key
we have Angela
and let's see I have my final member in
the team the sixth member
who is Suzanne
now
if you do it in Python 2 or Python 3.4
version and below I have to define a
function so let me say Define
merge underscore teams which will be my
function name
and I'll pass in two parameters say dict
one
and dict
2.
then I have dict three
indict three
I'll use the
copy method so I'll
use dict
one
dot copy
then
let me go ahead and
use my dict three
Dot
update
I'll pass in my dick to
and then
see I'll return
my dict
three
finally
I'll print it so I'll use
merge underscore teams
then pass in my two parameters as team a
comma
TMP
if I run it oops there is a mistake I
have made so this should be dipped to
actually
so let me run it once again you can see
we have merged both our dictionaries
now you can see it has around six to
seven lines of code or even more
now if you want to do this task using
python 3.5 version and above you can use
the update method so let's see how we
can do
I have CE
is equal to
I'll pass in my dictionary
as
e has value of 1
say B has a value of
let's say B also has a value of 1
and my
second dictionary would have
key B again
and it has a value of 2
and Key C
will have a value of 1.
now if I write e Dot
update B
and if I print a let me run it you can
see we have merged
both the dictionaries here
now there's one more method which you
can use let me show you
so I'll copy paste
my teammate and Team B again
and then
let's say I'll declare
another variable called final team
that will be equal to
I'll use curly braces and then say
I'll give two star and then team a
comma
two stars again
and then Team B
then I'll print my
final team if I run it you can see we
have merged both our team A and B and
this is our final team that has
six elements
now before moving to the next trick if
you have enjoyed watching this video so
far then please consider subscribing to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update
also if you want to get the source file
I am using in this live session then
please mention your email IDs in the
chat section we'll share the source code
with you over email
now let's move on
similar to a list comprehension you can
also create a dictionary comprehension
let me show you the trick
suppose I want to find the square of
numbers so I'll pass in my variable that
is square
and I'll use my dictionary comprehension
say x comma X
star star 2 this will find the square of
a number
for X in range
C5 so I want the square of the first
five numbers
then let me just call it
you can see it has printed
a dictionary that has the square of
numbers from 0 to 4 that is five numbers
so 0 square is 0 1 square is 1 2 square
is 4 3 square is 9 and 4 square is 16.
now let's see the trick to check if all
the elements in a sequence are true or
false based on a condition
you can do this with the help of all
function all function in Python returns
true if all the items in an iterable are
true otherwise it returns false
so I'll directly use my all function so
I'll say all
now let's see I'll use a variable e
percentage 2 if it's equal to equal to 0
and I'll say for a
in
range
between 0 to 10 with an interval of 2
if I run it
it gives me true
because I have defined my range from 0
to 10 and an interval of 2 so the
numbers will range from 0
2 4 6 8 and so on
so all these numbers are divisible by 2
and the remainder is 0 so it gives us
true
now if I change the third parameter in
my range function see I'll make it 3.
and I run it it gives me false
up next we look at a common programming
question that you often get to see in
any interview or programming test that
is swapping two numbers
let's see the trick to swap two numbers
in a single line of code
so I'll
declare two numbers c x and y
let's say we have xs10 and by s20
I'll use a print statement
say it before
swap
give a comma and I'll declare my
variables X comma y
now to swap to variables I can simply
use x comma y equal to
y comma X
and then I'll again use a print
statement C
after swap
and I'll write X
equal to
say
X
and
y
will have the variable
if I run it
you see before swap X had 10 and 20 and
after swap you can see we have X as 20
and Y as 10. so we have swapped the
values of the two variables successfully
now moving on
the next trick I am going to show is how
you can concatenate a list containing
strings so we'll use the join function
for this
let's say I have a list characters
and it has a list of strings
say p comma y
comma t
comma h
comma o
and we have the final string that is n
now if you were to concatenate all the
list elements
I'll declare a variable called word and
double quotation marks
and then I'll use the dot operator and
join function
I'll pass in my list that is
character
then I'll
print my variable word
below you can see the resultant output
so we have successfully combined or
concatenated each element or item in the
list character so we have python printed
now let me show you how you can find the
most frequently occurring values in a
list
so
I'll declare a list called test and
suppose it has some random whole number
C1 comma 2 comma 3
four
two comma 2 then we have 3 comma 1 comma
four comma 4 comma four
I'll use
print statement
and pass in my Max function
then I'll convert the list into
a set
give a comma and then I'll use key is
equal to
test dot count
so what it basically does is it will
first count
the number of times each element is
occurring and then
find the maximum value out of it
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
given me 4 which means
the item 4 has occurred the most number
of times in my list you can see we have
four four times
moving forward the next step is how you
can use the if else statement using
ternary operators
ternary operators are commonly known as
conditional expressions in Python these
operators evaluate something based on a
condition being true or false
so I have my two variables a comma B
and it has values
10 and 20 respectively
now if I
use a print statement say both a
and B
are
equal
if
a equals to equals to B
else
a
is
greater than b
if
a greater than
B
else
is
greater
than e
so first I am evaluating this condition
if a
is equal to equal to B then we'll print
both A and B are equal
else if a is greater than b we'll print
a is greater than b
if both the conditions are false we'll
print B is greater than a
so let me run this
we have the output B is greater than a
because
our B value is 20 and a is 10 so B is
greater than a
now let me create a numpy array and find
the cumulative sum in a sequence of
numbers for this you can use the come
sum function
first I have to import my numpy library
so I'll write import
numpy as NP
then
I'll declare a variable
say res which is for result
I'll use a list function
and then
passing my come sum function
and let's say I'll give a range of 10.
finally I'll print the result
if I run this
you can see we have calculated the
cumulative sum of the numbers ranging
from 0 to 9
so the first element is 0 then the next
element is 1 so 0 plus 1 is 1. the next
element is 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3 then 3
plus 3 is 6 6 plus 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is
15 and so on
let's Now understand how you can use
iter tools in Python either tool is a
module in Python that implements a
number of iterator building blocks it
provides several functions that work on
iterators to produce complex iterators
we will see an example to find the list
of matches to be played between the
teams in a league here we consider each
team will play against all the other
teams in the league
so to use the iter tools I'll first
import it so I'll write import
iter tools
and then let me go ahead and declare a
list see
football
underscore clubs
let me take
a few Club names see Manchester United
then we have
Real Madrid
I'm taking the top clubs from Europe
foreign
followed by
Chelsea
then we have say Liverpool
and finally we have
Barcelona
then
I'll use my list function and
use another function that is present
inside the iter tools library that is
combination
so it will give me all the possible
combinations
I'll pass in my
list
name that is football underscore clubs
and I'll give another parameter that is
r equal to 2
if I run it
you have all the matches that would be
played in the sleeve
as I mentioned each team will play
against all the other teams
now we will see the trick to print the
total permutations in a given set of
numbers using the iter tool and its
functions
now to do this I'll use a for Loop so
I'll use for
p in
either tools
Dot I'll use permutations function
so
permutations
and then let's see I'll pass in my list
that has values 1 comma 2 comma 3 and 4
I'll print it
I'll use print
then I'll use the
join function
convert it into a string
four
X in p
if I run it you can see below we have
all the permutations listed
up next let me tell you how you can
print all the false values present in a
list now to do this we can use the
filter false function present in the
iter tools module
so I'll use list
and then
use my iter tools
Dot
filter false function
I'll pass in
Bool as my
data type
let's say we have a list containing none
then we have false
we have one comma 0 comma 10.
if I run it
it will print all the false values
present in the list so we have none
false and zero
so if you have liked watching this video
so far then please subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
stay updated with all the trending
Technologies also if you want to get the
source file that I am using in this live
session then please mention your email
IDs in the chat section our team will
share the source code with you over
email
again if you have any questions related
to the tips and tricks we have discussed
so far then please put your queries in
the chat section our team will answer it
in the chat
up next let me show you the trick to
perform certain mathematical operations
inside a list containing pairs of tuples
first we look at how to add elements in
a list of tuples
so for that I'll import my iter tools
you can skip this step because we have
already imported a writer tools module
and then I'll import operator
we have
a list of tuples say A2 comma 5
then we have 10 comma 4
we have another pairs as 60 comma 3.
now I'll use
list function and inside of it I'll use
my iter tools module
so I'll write iter tools Dot
star map function
and
I'll use my operator
add
comma
I'll pass in my list that is a
now if I run it
we have the addition of the pills of
tuples present in the list so first pair
is 2 comma five so the addition
is 7 then 10 plus 4 is 14 and 60 plus 3
is 63.
similarly you can also multiply the
pairs of tuples in a list I just copy
paste this code and here instead of ADD
I'll use
mul to multiply
if I run it
we have the output below
so 2 into 5 is 10 then the product of 10
and 4 is 40 and 60 and 3 is 180.
now let us explore a bit about the
collections module in Python so the
collections module implements
specialized container data types
containing alternatives to Python's
general purpose built-in containers such
as list Tuple dictionaries and set
I'll show you how to change the order of
the keys inserted in a dictionary using
the ordered dict function
so first I need to import the ordered
dict function from the collections
module
so I'll write from
collections
import
ordered
dict function
then
I'll say d is equal to
ordered
Dot
I'll use the from keys
and let's see
I have my key as e b c d e
then I'll
use another function called move
to
end
and let's say I want to move my key B to
the end
then
I'll use inverted commas
and pass in my join function
and inside that I'll say d dot
keys
if I run it
you can see we have shifted the key B to
the end
now if you want to move the key B to the
beginning
you can do something like this so let me
copy the last two lines of code from the
above cell
I'll paste it
now here I can give another
parameter that is last
and I'll see
false
if I run this
you can see we have the key B in the
beginning now
now the final trick I am going to show
you is how to perform mathematical
operations using a Lambda function in
Python
so Lambda is an anonymous function that
does not have a name
it can have any number of arguments but
only one expression
the expression is evaluated and the
result is returned
so let's see how to add and subtract
numbers in one line of code using the
Lambda function
so first I'll declare a variable say
function
is equal to
and I'll assign a dictionary
I'll pass in my
sum and then
use the Lambda function
I'll pass in variables X comma y
and I'll add X Plus y
similarly
I'll now
subtract
I'll use the Lambda function again
pass in my variables X comma y
and I'll write x minus y
now
let me run it
so if you want to find the sum of two
numbers
so I have to call this first so I'll use
funk
and using square brackets I'll give my
sum
and then pass in my value say 10 comma 3
this will add 10 plus 3 and return the
result as 13. similarly
if you want to subtract two numbers
I'll just write subtract here instead of
sum
and it will return the result that is 10
minus 3 that which is 7.
I think with that we have covered all
the important tips and tricks that you
should know in Python welcome to python
interview questions certainly the
questions we're going to ask in here are
very general with a few specifics
towards data science since that's the
main direction that Python's going in
and you'd want to expand your questions
for your interview depending on the
domain that you're using the python in
specifically let's dive in and get
started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy.deep
copy creates a deep copy shallow copy
creates a different object and populates
it with the references of the child
objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change the channel one
and object one it will also make that
change in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in Python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
Works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python Global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in Python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so when you
look at the architecture you can see
here we have a nice model drawn out
where the user initiates the Django
which initiates the URL which initiates
the view what they're going to view and
you have your model and your template so
the model of data whatever data model
you're pulling goes into the template
and then goes back up the pipeline to
the user and the important thing to note
is there's a template the front end of
the web page this is what they're going
to see there's a model the back end
where the data is stored so you can keep
the template and the looks and
everything looks the same but you can
swap out the underlying formation that
goes into that template then you have
your view which interacts with the model
and template and Maps it to the URL and
then the Django serves the page to the
user so your Django grabs it and says
okay thank you for the URL and here you
go user what advantage does numpy array
have over a nested list so numpy is a
module you import almost always see
numpy import numpy as NP numpy is
written in C such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this makes number
arrays much faster than lists I would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our Jupiter notebook any IDE
will work if you're going to do a set of
these of interview questions taking a
quick look at code is always important
we have our import and of b as NP we'll
go ahead and import time here's our list
list sub for Iron Range of 100 and what
we're doing is we're going to time it so
we're going to create a list then we're
going to create a numpy zeros array and
you can see here look how quick you can
create this numpy zeros array here we
are appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer I believe it's either
floater integer on this I'd have to
actually do a type and then so if we
take in and we create a tl1 time equals
time and then we do for I and range of
100 for J and range of 100 L of I J
equals L of i j plus five so we're just
doing a simple calculation on our array
and sub arrays this is an array of rays
and we'll do the same thing with tl2 tl2
time dot time tl1 so here we have our
final time on that and then we'll do
this with an array array op and this is
what I really love a equals a plus 10
and then you can just print it right out
so you can see right here with the numpy
array I'm doing the same thing if I run
this our time is significantly different
here we have 0.09 and 0.003 so you can
see that the time drops significantly
when you're running this on a numpy
array versus a list array also important
to note these times aren't going to be
they'll change each time I run it
depending on what I have running in the
background so there we go number five
what is pickling and unpickling Macy's
how many M's I pickle and unpickle
something converting a python object
hierarchy to a byte stream is called
pickling pickling is also referred to as
serialization unpickling converting a
byte stream to a python object hierarchy
is also called unpickling and pickling
is also referred to as deserialization
so if you just created a neural network
model you can now save that model to
your hard drive pickle it and then you
can unpickle it to bring it back into
another software program or to use at a
later time how is memory managed in
Python number six python has a private
Heap space where it stores all the
objects the python memory manager
manages various aspects of this Heap
like sharing caching segmentation and
allocation the user has no control over
the Heap only the python interpreter has
the access you have a nice little
diagram here here's your program there's
your interpreter we have our Heap memory
management on the garbage collector
going off of there number seven are
arguments in Python pass by value or by
reference arguments are passed in Python
by reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of zero equals three
L equals one two three four function L
print L and you're going to get three
two three four because we passed l in
there so it's a pointer here we have def
function l l equals three two three four
L equals one two three four function of
L print L because in this function I
have assigned instead of operating on a
piece of L the list I've consigned a
whole new value to that list or L it
then at that points will create a new
object so if I make changes to the
object it's going to change it in the
outside the definition if I use a
variable and I ass cited a completely
new value like L equals three two three
four that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight How
would would you Generate random numbers
in Python to generate not random numbers
in Python you must first import the
random module the random function
generates a random float value between 0
and 1. the random range function
generates a random number within a given
range and you can see here one is the
lower end times the upper end and step
two so it'd be one three five and so on
as far as the options in the random
generation number nine what does the
double forward slash operator do in
Python the forward slash operator
performs Division and Returns the
quotient in float for example five over
two returns 2.5 to do a double forward
slash operator on the other hand Returns
the quotient in integer for example 5
double slash returns two five divided by
two and you drop the point five number
ten what does the is operator do the is
operator compares the ID of the two
objects and you can see in here where
list one equals brackets around one two
three list one equals list two equals
true and you have the double equals in
Python of course and you can do list one
is list two where list two equals one
two three is false this two is not the
brackets one two three it equals it but
it's not the brackets and if we do list
three equals list one then list one is
list three equals true number eleven
what is the purpose of pass statement
the past statement is used when there's
a syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learned we've added two
spaces in it for I and variable so it
goes through each eye if I equals space
do nothing else print I and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out Simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need to play placeholder for
that first logical set or that first
area you can also do a function like
this you could do function whatever your
def function name brackets colon pass so
it goes into the function and does
nothing but it's a placeholder number 12
how will you check all the characters in
a string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in The
String are alpha numeric and so you can
see here A B C D one two three is all
number output equals true and the second
line a b c d the at symbol one two three
the pound symbol is all new output
equals false so really just want to know
about is all new all numerical
alphanumerical number 12. how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go if you know
is all number which returns that the
characters in The String are
alphanumeric one can also use rejects
instead and so we have Boolean re man
much what's important about this is to
note your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase to dash to Z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the ABCD one two three and
so we can do an re dot match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we'll get an output true
and if not an output false number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in Python there's lists tuples
and strings python equation makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your Tuple is the curve brackets
designates it and again just add them
together here same thing with strings we
have simply learn S1 plus S2 equals
simply learn number 14 how will you
remove all leading white space in a
string python provides the inbuilt
function L strip to remove all leading
access from a string and you can see
here space space python dot L strip
leading strip Python and you can also do
strip which releases leading and ending
of course there's also the ending set
number 15 how will you replace all
occurrences of a substring with a new
string the replace function can be used
with strings for replacing a substring
with a given string syntax string dot
replace old comma new comma count
replace returns a new string without
modifying the original string hey John
how are you John question mark replace
John with capital j o h n one and then
you can see right here hey John how are
you and since we designated with the one
just says we're only going to replace
one of these 6 16 what is the difference
between Del and remove brackets on lists
Del for delete Dell removes all elements
of a list within a given range syntax
Dell list start to end remove remove
brackets removes the first occurrence of
a particular character syntax list
remove element and we see a nice example
over here if we delete the list one to
three it will delete the first in this
case b one two it doesn't do three
remember that one two so it will delete
B and C and you end up with a d where if
we do remove B from the list and we have
an a b b d it's only going to remove the
first B number 17 how to display the
contents of text file in reverse order
open the file using the open function
store the contents of the file into a
list reverse the contents of the list
run a for Loop to iterate through the
list number 18. differential between
append and extend append adds an element
to the end of the list you can see right
here we have a list one two three four
and we have pinned four and we end up
with an output one two three four and
extend adds an element from an interval
to the end of the list and we have here
list equals one two three list dot
extend four five six output is one two
three four five six so if you want to
append an array to the end of another
array you want to use the extend number
19. what's the output of the below code
justify your answer this is a great
interview question because these are the
kind of things that come up when you're
proofing code def add to list value and
list so we have value in and a list in
or List equals an empty in this case an
empty list list data pin value return
list list one equals add to list one
list two equals add to list one two
three empty bracket list three equals
add to list a and then we want to print
them list one equals and you can see the
formatting we have a placeholder list
one list two and list three so when it
prints list one we to get 1 comma a and
what you want to notice here is that
list one and list three are equal why
are they equal well when we passed the
information to the add to list we passed
value without passing the list equals
brackets without passing a second value
what this means is that list as we have
it if you don't have a list it'll start
off with empty list which we append the
1 2 the second one list two we appended
a value to an empty list so we're only
going to be one two three it doesn't
matter what the list was before we've
already assigned an empty list and then
list three here's the tricky one we're
adding a to the list but because we
didn't designate the list list is a
shared value in other words it doesn't
reset it and we end up with list one
equals list three one comma a default
list is created only once during the
function and not during its call number
20 what is the difference between a list
and a tuple lists are mutable while
tuples are immutable and you can see an
example down here where I have list
equals one two three square brackets
denote it's a list list of two equals
four and I print it out I now have one
two four if I do the same thing with the
Tuple I get an error because you can't
change the Tuple one two three into one
two four you have to completely reassign
Tuple to a new value what is Doc string
in Python doc strings are used in
providing documentation to various
python modules classes functions and
methods and so you can see here we have
def for a function add a b and this is a
doc string we have the triple brackets
on there you can add carriage return in
that so that you can go multiple lines
and it says this function adds two
numbers and then sum a b returns some
and so we have down here two different
ways of accessing this function output
accessing docstring method one this
function adds two numbers accessing
dockstring method two help on function
add in model main this function adds two
numbers and so you can see the code down
here has two very different in values
the second one is basically a help menu
there's our help menu number 22 how to
use print without the new line the
solution to this depends on the python
version you are using in Python version
2 you can do print Hi and then you add a
comma afterwards print how are you and
you have Hi how are you in version 3
print hi comma end equals and it'll add
a space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but
generally you just want to put a space
and put a space on the End Print how are
you and now we get Hi how are you number
23 how do you use the split function in
Python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma Max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is the split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one and just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is python object oriented or
functional programming python follows
object oriented Paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented Paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming Paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports Lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
Paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is Def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for I and VAR print I so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six it'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 another line 6. number 26 what is
asterisk args and asterisks quarks args
used in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
iterable object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic quarks I can actually tell it
what I want to send so used in a
function prototype and to accept varying
number of keyworded arguments it's in
both our iterable objects so you can go
through them one at a time and the def
function chords you can now set like
color equals red units equal two so
you'll see that especially in machine
learning there's a lot of like they'll
have inline equals true that kind of
thing number 27 in Python functions are
first class objects what do you
understand from this this means I could
return a function if you went from
another function I could create a
function and treat it just like an
object I can assign it to a variable I
can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print nay underscore underscore name
justify your answer the double
underscore name double underscore is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
Dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the ray
along each Dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as NP you don't
necessarily have to use MP but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an NP dot array of one
two three four five and then if we want
to get our indexes of n maximum values
in an empty array we can do one way to
do it is to take our array sort it then
do minus in colon that means we're going
to do once you've sorted it you can do
minus in in would equal then the number
of indices so it's not the actual letter
N colon and really this is about
understanding this notation that we can
sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of Ray of arrays we
have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important here
is that one it's a numpy so that leaves
a out and then we're stuck with three
other options and I'm going to say the D
is out none of these and let's look at
NP dot concatenate versus NP dot v stack
concatenate would put one set after the
other so you would end up with probably
give you an error because one set is one
two three and then we're going to
concatenate array 0 1 2 and 1 array one
two three the array of arrays onto the
end of that what we really want to do is
stack and by the ways you can actually
switch there's variables you can put
into concatenate obviously they can
change this so you could use the
concatenate with a lot of fudging around
but really we're looking for is v-stack
v stands for vertical versus the H deck
which is horizontal and if we do a
v-stack we can simply do train set comma
test set and stack them together and so
we have C resulting set equals np.v
stack train stack test set both option A
and B would do horizontal stacking but
we would like to have the vertical
stacking option she does this again you
could add the axes in and use the
concatenate to stack it the correct way
number 33 how would you import a
decision Tree classifier in sklearn We
have
sklearn.decision tree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn Ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
last part happens to be correct and it's
really just a vocabulary knowing where
is the decision tree class specifier
stored what module is that a part of and
it is of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34 you have uploaded the
data set in CSV format on Google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the Google Docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string IO dot
string IO request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a CSV
there's obviously many ways to read a
CSV but data equals pd.read underscore
CSV Source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have DF name and DF
location colon comma brackets around
name comma where and then we have DF
equals PD data frame a b b x x u u comma
21 1650 33 columns equal name and age so
let's take a look and see what they're
looking at we have just glancing at the
questions they want to know is it the
original data frame or is it the copy of
the data frame and you can see here that
one is view the original data frame and
two is a copy of the original data frame
two is a view of the original data frame
and one is a copy of the original data
frame both are copies both are views and
if you're working with pandas you know
that unless you specifically in certain
things tell it to do it inline and a lot
of functions don't allow you that you're
always taking a slice and it is always a
copy so C both are copies of the
original data frame number 36 you get
the following error while trying to read
a file temp.csv using pandas which of
the following could correct it so here's
our error Trace back most recent call
last file input line one in module
Unicode encode error ASCII codex can't
encode character oh I hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PD read CSV
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not encoding or coding setup and
then we have encoding equals utf-8 well
that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
Unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with in a plot given below
so looking at this we have import
matplot Library Pi plot is PLT and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show and so
this is a little bit of a vocabulary
test the vocabulary is it width equals
three line width equals three LW equals
three or something else and the
vocabulary word that we're looking for
is LW equals three which stands for line
width in pi plot Library Pi plot Number
38 how would you reset the index of a
data frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary Challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we're
double checking our indexes to the
column and to the main index and so the
values match correctly where re-index
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that is external and we have a data
frame to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in Python the functions
used to copy objects in Python we have
copy copy for shallow copying and copy
deep copying for deep copy number 40
what is the difference between range and
X range functions in Python well this is
a good one we have matrixes and arrays
with a matrix the range returns a python
list object X range returns an X range
object and with arrays an x-ray returns
an X range object X range creates values
as you need them through yielding the
key here is that X range Returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in X range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number 41 how
can can you check whether a panda's data
frame is empty or not the tribute
df.empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have down
here import our pandas is PD we create
our pandas data frame equal to an empty
array and is DF dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number 42 write the code to
sort an array in numpy by the N minus
oneth column this can be achieved using
ARG sort function let's take an array X
then to sort the N minus one column the
code will be X to X to colon n minus two
dot args sort so let's see what that
code looks like we import numpy as NP
we'll create our array our numpy array
which is uh one two three zero five two
two three four so we have three
different entities with three different
columns and there and we go X of X and
so we take X of all the rows first
entity well in this case it's actually
the second one because it's zero one two
dot ARG sort so that would be the second
entity or minus two would also be the
same you could also do instead of one
you could also do minus two there
instead of the one ARG sort and then we
get an output of the array one two three
zero five two two three four number 43
how to create a series from a list numpy
array and dictionary so we'll go ahead
and input import our numpy our pandas
and have my list and you can see here we
have my list equals list of a b c d e f
g over all the way through so my list
now makes a list of that for array we
have NP dot a range to 26 my dictionary
will create a dictionary with a zip my
list my arguments so I'll just use the
numpy array we just created with my
array to go into the dictionary and the
solution is simple with the PD dot
series my list
pd.series my array PD dot series my
dictionary so it's all about knowing the
dot Capital s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget
that capitalization number 44 how to get
the items not common to both series a
and series B and you can see here we
have a set of series A and B we have
series one and two and we have one two
three four five four five six seven
eight the solution is we take a panda
series we have a series U equals a panda
series NP Union one dimension series one
series two so we can now make a union of
them we now have series one Panda series
with an intersection and then we can
remove one from the other series U is
series U dot is in series one so if the
union is not in the intersection then
you know it's a unique value a little
bit of logic going on there and playing
with three different terms to get the
answer we want 45 how to keep only the
top two most frequent values as it is
and replace everything else as other in
a series so again we're working with
pandas because if you're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as PD we'll go ahead and create
our Panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random State
100 so 100 in the numpy one and then we
have our Panda series you can see here
we're random integer numpy random not
random integer one comma 5 by 12. and so
the solution for this is we go ahead and
we've created a PD dot remember the
capital S Series solution we're going to
print the top two frequencies and that
is our series dot value counts and then
we take series values count dot index of
up to two so we're going to take
everything up to two and then we'll do
the series is in so if it's not in the
first two then it's going to equal other
and this would be something you'd want
to write down on paper if you're if it
looks confusing take a moment pause the
video write this down and see if you can
figure out how the logic came together
and try to throw yourself a couple other
little logic puzzles like this number 46
how to find the positions of numbers
that are multiples of three from a
series and in here we're actually going
to use a numpy to solve it the first
part series lets you know it's going to
be a panda series and if we come down
here we have NP dot ARG where this is a
vocabulary question series with remember
the percentile three is the remainder so
if the remainder equals zero then we're
going to generate that string where the
object divided by three equals zero has
no remainder so that we know it's a
multiple of three number 47 how would
you compute the euclidean distance
between two series and this one's really
cool because we have our Panda series uh
p and Q and what I like about this one
is they give us two solutions you can go
with and really you should kind of know
both the first one would be yes you know
what the euclidean distance is and that
is is we can take the first series minus
the second series squared and then sum
them up and then we do the square root
which is the same as taking the power to
0.5 doing the power to 0.5 is easier
than doing the square root so a lot of
times you'll see that as a switch but
you could have also done the square root
and use the math in there so there's
solution one you should know your
euclidean distance and then solution two
is the numpy solution so we have NPA dot
linag.norm that's how we're going to
compute our euclidean distance
P minus Q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it 5 minus one when
this creates a 25 by 25 data frame and
so our solution is to do the DFI
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon -1 so we're taking all the
rows all the columns minus one so our
stepping -1 going the reverse Direction
and then we're just going to use across
all the different columns on there let
me say that again the first colon is
going to be your row starting row
stopping row step minus one that's all
this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49. if
you split your data into train test
splits is it possible to overfit your
model and the answer is yes is
definitely possible one common beginner
mistake is retuning a model or training
new models with different parameters
after seeing his performance on the test
set my favorite example of this is you
have your script put together and you
keep hitting the rerun button until you
get the answer you want not taking the
answer it first gave you or running it
over an array and recording all the
answers to see how they vary number 50
which python library is built on top of
matplot library and pandas to ease data
plotting the answer this is Seaborn
Seabourn is a data visualization library
in Python that provides a high level
interface for drawing statistical
information informative graphs so thank
you all for watching this session on
python developer full course I hope this
video was useful and informative if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comment section A
team will help you solve your queries
stay safe and keep learning